[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
everything
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
something special for them we're
predicting the future we predict that
the position on the board will happen at
least once today all right well can you
spot David Howell's little Easter egg in
the studio this is the second day of the
air things Masters two players will be
knocked out so welcome to the action of
the air things monsters
I'm really looking happy with himself
the king can't move wait wait wait wait
wait this move is breaking the rules
whoa everything under control but
suddenly the position has changed let's
just looks looks glorious for white big
Choice from origin irrigation there we
go the other lunch continues
there's a big threat on the board Magnus
Carlton is furious it's going straight
for the kill Wesley so has blundered
he's blundered at night a white king is
trapped this is
Magnus Carlson's showing his genius
and he certainly started off with some
genius Chas yesterday Magnus Carlsen he
uh had a fantastic first day off the air
things monster is done here again to
guide you through the second day of the
tournament Grandmaster David Howell
International Master Tanya sachdes and
ground Master Rover tax and Robert what
did you take away from the very first
day of the 2023 season we saw some
brilliant chess some absolutely dominant
performances from some of the best
players in the world and some surprises
like Arjun aragaisy sweeping Andreas and
today Tanya the first two players will
be knocked out of the tournament a lot
at stake today so much Kaya they use
that one life they're on their very last
chance at that Championship now they
have to block out what happened on day
one give it their all it's go big or go
home for these four players yes and
David you commented two seasons on the
Champions chest or with a Time control
of 15 plus 10. yesterday we had 15 plus
only three seconds increment did you
like it I did Kaya it's faster it's more
Furious and but yesterday there was
still a very high quality of Chess we
didn't see too many one move blunders we
saw the players adapting to that faster
time control and it's only going to
promise more drama for us here in the
studio also for the bats yeah and we
still have eight players in division one
in the air things Masters they are
spread out
of many different time zones Magna
Scrolls and he has actually traveled to
Canada
to visit his friends the chest cross and
it did seem like he enjoyed himself
yesterday Tanya he's got his
cheerleaders with him now rumor has it
that he is in Canada for the protest
league as part of the chess brought
teams but I also hear that he might be
there to have a little bit of fun okay
so it's really going to depend on how
disciplined he can be how much farting
he's doing but it worked out to
Perfection on day one yeah and it was a
team effort yesterday to uh to get all
the technical stuff working for Magnus
Carlsen he is the reigning champion in
the Champions chess tour and started off
the season in great fashion
E6 now the white Rook has landed on a
square that the White Knight used to
occupy but still an outpost still
defended by White's past Pawn in the
center and
his bishop and even if black trades off
that Rook it will just be replaced by an
equally powerful Pawn Magnus centralizes
his Knight wow nice move and adding even
more pressure onto those two uh kind of
most important Defenders exchanging
pieces as well as Robert mentioned
helping uh when you're ahead of material
Serana I think he is completely
hopelessly lost I don't say that very
often as a commentator but this position
it's he's getting obliterated in this
one this is Checkmate incoming uh
Serrano's down to a minute and a half
and the clock is not even his biggest
problem Magnus did get his Rook to the
seventh Rank and Serana resigned
wow peace sacrifice and I know your
first instinct was what he's given up a
bishop he's London Bishop for two points
it's total chaos despite the reduced
material and Black's King is on the run
it feels like Eric I see the nerves of
kicking in he's giving a few checks to
gain time on the increments
are leaning back though and it's over
you want peace he won a piece the black
king now cannot take that white knight
because then you lose your bishop and
Eric I see we almost missed it there but
spun it in his favor mostly so maybe the
single worst opponent to play when you
need to win
he's just breaking off in the center
targeting that D3 pawn and says come and
take my seat for Pawn not only do you
double up your own pawns but watch out
for that pawn in the center wow we're
all reacting here in the studio because
Ralph is maybe out of desperation
sacrifice the peace he's given up his
Knight just for a couple of Pawns Knight
in King versus King you cannot win that
it is a draw and that means what's this
song moves up
what a day we had first day of the year
things Masters and I want to introduce
you guys also to our fourth expert in
the studio International Master Ivanka
houska who impressed you the most
yesterday that was such a frantic day
yesterday but I have to say the person
who I really liked and really enjoyed
watching was Hikaru Nakamura because he
wasn't playing from his normal home he
was paying from California because of
personal reasons but he still managed to
put all that behind him and just
demolish kukesh crushing win for Hikaru
Nakamura in his match yesterday same for
Magnus Carlsen winning in only three
games against Serana Wesley Seoul got
that one win he needed to win his match
against Ralph marmadov
but the biggest surprise yesterday must
have been the match between Arjun
aragaisy and alireza fuja the two 19
year olds Arjun winning all three games
I mean it was actually quite shocking I
mean not the fact that far Asia lost but
the fact that he lost by such a margin I
mean he is after all number four in the
world but uh he has been in somewhat
hibernation and I think the rust really
showed so today the heat is on for him
yeah and luckily for farusha he does
have two lives because this is double
elimination that means you can lose one
match and still win the whole tournament
but the second you lose a second match
you are knocked out of the air things
master so the four players who won their
matches yesterday they will play winners
semi-finals starting later today the
four players who lost yesterday they
were knocked down to the losers bracket
and will play losers round one starting
in
eight minutes and first of all we have
Serana against fuchsia what you expect
from us and this one is going to be wild
I mean both players have very aggressive
Styles Serana this could be a career
defining moment for him so he will want
to be doing well especially with the
white pieces and when it comes to
farooja well his pride has been hurt and
he needs to recover and one of the
things about farooja is that he's a
little bit impractical and that keeps
his opponents on his toes and for Serana
you mentioned it could actually be quite
important for him we know the two
players who go home to today they get
home with 7 500 but for him earning even
more money could be important exactly I
mean this type of money could actually
mean that he could employ a second he
could perhaps get a team behind him it
just gives him opportunities that he
might not have had otherwise yeah a lot
at stake today for Alexey Serrata a
total of
235 thousand dollars is in the prize
fund in the air things monsters and we
also have to mention the other matchup
in the losers round one Mama Dove
against young gukesh I know again
another thrilling matchup you have
mamadov he's very much a romantic player
he likes the coffee house kind of chest
when you just throw your pieces at The
King and I have to say mama actually
came very well prepared against Wesley
and he could have turned that match
around and when it comes to the 16 year
old gukash over there I mean that kid is
just running at a fast pace you know of
course he won the play-ins but yesterday
it was his off day but uh well boy yeah
this is going to be a fight yeah at only
16 years old a young chess genius who
has and you brought this with you today
iwaka he has composed a quite
sophisticated study yeah I mean it's
super sophisticated he composed it when
he was just 15 years old in honor of the
Dutch Grandmaster Jan Timon now the
position that you're gonna see ahead of
you is actually the end of a study that
he did that was actually like 13 or 14
moves long and here we've caught the
very end of it it is white to play and
it's very sophisticated very difficult
so get your friends around solve
together and I'm going to give you a
small clue okay and it all hinges on
this Black Knight stuck there on H4 it's
kind of offside it's not doing anything
and chess is all about timing and now is
the time for white to strike so enjoy
this complex puzzle courtesy of gokash
but I hope you guys all enjoy it wow we
are challenging all of you at home to
take a look at this study and find the
next move for white a fantastic study
composed by at the time 15 year old
gookash and we will pick a winner tweet
your answer using chess Champs and uh
one winner will go home with an air
things device signed by my Miss Carlson
and Magnus Carlsen he is definitely one
of the big favorites to win the whole
Champions chess tour 2023
if I can ask you
um to write how you think the top five
overall standings in Champions Chester
will look like this season is alireza
playing or is he into fashion now should
I put myself yeah okay
[Music]
okay I'll go with Magnus okay first one
is a long name
my mother is watching us I have to be
careful
you know what I can be confident no I
can put my name
you know I just beaten Magnus here in
Arkansas I'm returning my favor there
returning a favor it's a good old friend
so you have Nakamura on top what is that
yeah he's just been like winning all his
events whenever I see him play he wins
so it's probably gonna take this one as
well um dink has bad internet so he he
is left out
I just put myself in the middle yeah
your handwriting is very nice
that's all that's your only bet yeah
[Music]
look at that
Magnus Carlson little arrogant or
refreshingly feisty David well it's the
top place they don't lack of confidence
do they and they do back it up on the
board so fair play to them definitely
and one name that actually many of the
players put in the list there was Jana
pomyachi where is he on the ponyachi
he's not playing division one he is
playing division two in the air things
monster some huge names competing also
in division two and he did win as much
yesterday against Olympus was there any
pickup sets would you say Robert in
division two yesterday I think Vladimir
krumnik losing his match against uh
Salem now Salam is a monster it's not a
surprise that he won but I think the
many fans of the former world champion
will be saddened to see Vladimir lose
and go to the losers bracket yeah and
there were some upsets also in division
three there's also a division three with
32 players and there were some upsets
yesterday yeah 32 players know more
because players like Liam lay Alexander
grishok Vincent kymer all had to leave
the tournament they suffered two match
losses they're gone some huge names but
we are following closely division one
and coming up first today is the losers
round one Serana against farusha and
mamadol against gukesh later today
Wesley so is uh going to play against
Hikaru Nakamura and the winners
semi-finals and you actually gave me
some info a minute ago Robert Wesley
song is currently playing some chess he
is he's playing bullet chess on
chess.com I saw him getting warmed up
for Hikaru Nakamura he's neat going to
be I have to be perfect in time trouble
playing against Nakamura who is the
speed chess champion also because
actually do you think that's the reason
David he's actually now warming up to
face Nakamura later today yeah there's
mixed opinions on this whether it's
actually a good form of preparation I
remember doing the candidates for Rouge
staying up all night playing hundreds of
bullet games and then falling to defeat
the next day when it came to classical
chess but it's fair enough he wants to
get some confidence he wants to get
those mouth skills working and you need
him against Nakamura yeah but first it
is losers round one and on the loser is
round one they play best and two rapid
games and the winner will go through to
the losers quarter final the loser in
the match today will be knocked out
we're gonna follow the first game
between Alexa is Serana and alireza
farusha farouza had a bad day yesterday
so what you expect from him today Tanya
I'm expecting an angry alibraza today
that was the Shocker of day one all the
favorites went through won their matches
in dominance style and Arjun versus
alireza was the big match which which
stunned us all and just the style in
which alireza lost as well I mean three
to zero that was unbelievable so I'm
expecting an angry alireza looking for
that win but he's playing against Serana
and Serana is a dangerous opponent what
kind of stuff kind of styles are up
against each other in this match Robert
it's interesting because Alexis Serana
is extremely well prepared otherwise the
first doesn't get that same nod for his
opening repertoire but you get him into
a middle game where it's a neutral
position both sides having to calculate
all he raises at his best uh-huh and
it's been a little bit it hasn't been a
while since we've seen the best stuff
for Rochelle though David yeah we saw
glimpses last year of course he did play
uh in the candidates in the St Louis
rapid and Blitz he was on fire just
crushing everybody there but it's just
few and far between his tournament
appearances and that's why the rust
builds up and the longer you go without
playing especially as a young player the
hotter it becomes and we saw that
yesterday Eric icy just blew him off the
board with some uh really impressive
tactics so uh he'll want to come back
today for Asia he will be better that's
guaranteed and he'll also be a bit angry
with which uh tends to help the top
later I'm looking forward to what is
angry chest how do you play when you're
angry uh more aggressively one two four
okay
here we go this is day two off of the
air things roster is game one on the
losers bracket and here we go we have
some moves on the board we do it's a
Queen spawn opening it's the Queen's
Gambit but the Queen's got a bit
declined so far
um white here is very flexible the
Knight comes out they call this the main
position or at least Alexander grishek
does because black has six or seven very
viable uh moves here and what are we
predicting it's a big moment for black
to decide because you can develop the
bishop just one square ahead on E7 David
and that becomes the Queen's Gambit
decline as you're mentioning or you
could be more aggressive and take it all
the way to B4 to pin that Knight on C3
and that would be the ragozan and I see
Ali Reza slowed down already so he's
thinking about what his approach will be
oh will he just capture the C4 Pawn yeah
he's uh none of those but he's also
going for one of the most trendy
variations wow okay a capture here Queen
takes D4 bring the queen out early comes
with some risk attached uh warning there
that your queen will get kicked about a
bit but uh this is still very well known
territory the has been a lot of debate
about this opening over the last couple
of years I would say and David you said
yesterday you're not a fan of the
isolated Pawn we see this Pawn on D5 the
Queen's Pawn it's all alone which means
it's hard to keep defending and look at
White's forces all of them staring down
at that pawn so that is where the
central tension lies it's all about is
white going to be able to win that pawn
and will black at compensation if that
pawn is indeed lost yeah and it will
revolve around that square and maybe the
square in front of that pawn often if
you can blockade an isolated Pawn uh
you're doing well in terms of
stabilizing here white gives a check
Serana has played instantly up to this
point showing confidence we mentioned
he's just a monster with the white
pieces he's up there with the very best
in terms of opening preparation when he
has white maybe less impressive with
black but uh here already Persia
thinking I'm expecting him to just block
this check the Black Knight sitting at
home asleep on B8 comes out there we go
Knight C6 and uh yeah here white will
have a couple of moves I do believe that
you can just push your E Pawn forward
one square maybe even two squares to
really challenge Black's opening but it
definitely feels like up there's up to
this point for Russia I'm not sure where
he's freestyling yet but he's just uh
less confident maybe he hasn't checked
this exact position this morning
and E4 they say is Best Buy test and I
think here is no exception push that
pawn two squares forward your King Pawn
and we just saw it on the board this is
threatening because the Rook stares down
the D file at the enemy queen that can
spell big trouble for farugia there's
this problem with the D5 Pawn being
isolated now under attack by most of
White's forces this feels like a
dangerous situation for alareza and
Alexei is the better prepared player of
the two you know and the fact that
Alexei is better prepared and he paused
for a second means he didn't expect this
black knight jump to C6 and he's really
trying to take advantage now if erosion
doesn't move quickly I fear for him in
this game uh you really need to know
your stuff here it's not the type of
position you can work out and be super
accurate in so uh what do we think what
is he contemplating big problems already
let's show uh the threats along the D
file of course this pin and pawn takes
Pawn monster threat right now uh you
could maybe even get rid of this Knight
traded off that is a defender of Black's
isolated Pawn in the center
hmm I'm wondering whether you can get
away with castling here but you have to
calculate for Regis in calculation mode
trying to work out whether he can get
away with that one I don't really see
what else it looks like if you don't
Castle you're just losing a pawn anyway
and that's the big question for alireza
right now and as we can see he has gone
into a think tank so he's not familiar
with it understandably so because get
this guys only two games so far have
happened in this position with E4 on the
board so it is New Territory for these
players which is why alireza is taking
his time and David you're on point that
shot Castle is the way to go a D5 Pawn
looks so dangerous with that bin it
needs to calculate these lines and I
think it's a good time to get into that
what happens after shot castle and
capture on D5 yeah process of
elimination black doesn't have that many
logical moves here actually no natural
moves at least and if you Castle your
king you you seriously have to calculate
here not just uh Bishop takes Knight but
also maybe just to capture reports in
the center and after the Knight
recaptures you're pinned along the
defile of course but maybe you're in
time to break the pin here black is
ahead in development if you look at
White's pieces the white bishop's still
asleep at home white hasn't castled this
king is very vulnerable on the open file
so it feels like this is hanging
together for black but maybe white can
finesse this somehow and just one more
move in this variation if white takes
the bishop on E7 and black takes with
the queen this showcases what the
problem is with keeping your king in the
center it looks like White's about to
scoop up at night the rook and the
Knight team up on his 95 but look at the
queen on E7 staring all the way down at
the King on E1 once that Bishop moves it
is checked to the enemy King that means
you don't have time to take the bishop
with your Rook that leaves alvareza not
just okay but even better leading in
development and going after the
opponent's kick yeah and suddenly this
will backfire on white suddenly White's
in uh huge trouble a deadly attack
facing down against that uncostaled King
this is why we always run a castle by
move 10 move 12 uh if we don't want to
take big risks and what's making him
pause then this doesn't look too bad for
black in the current position if he does
Castle maybe maybe there's something
else maybe white doesn't take on this
Square yet again I'm hesitant to suggest
a trade on the center here because
sooner or later there will be a nasty
check maybe we flick in Bishop takes
Knight we're showing some long
variations here but this is what's going
through for courageous mind there's lots
of captures in this variation there's
lots of forcing moves so it's actually
easier to calculate but there's so many
options that you suddenly have to spend
your time it's such an important moment
for furuja right now with all these
concrete variations that need to be
looked at and this time format is so
much about psychology as well now Alexi
Serrano just did not get his kind of
positions against Magnus out of the
opening but here the more that alireza
thinks the more time he thinks I think
Serana just gets that much more
confident he's happy he's pleased with
the opening outcome that's not a good
message you want to send out to your
opponent
yeah he's going to be gaining so much in
confidence every second that farisha is
in the tank here Serana and uh big
success for him in the opening and I
spoke to a few players just trying to
get their sense of what happened
yesterday and one of the words they used
for Serrano was unlucky they felt that
in the match against Magnus Carlson he
was not getting the openings that he is
most comfortable in and as we see here
in game one he is well ahead in the
clock the evaluation Bar says the white
is the side for choice at the moment and
we see by farusha the fact that he's not
making a move he feels like this is a
dangerous position there's tension in
the center it doesn't have to be
released that soon because of this pin
down the line from Rook on D1 to Queen
on d8 so this is a nice position for
serrana it's in his wheelhouse it's his
repertoire and this is really a danger
zone for farugia wow he's now down to
almost nine minutes on the clock that's
a huge thing the only pin is not the one
on D file the other one that he needs to
be careful about is that Knight on C6
which is spinned by that Queen on A4
which means that black doesn't have the
possibility to push that deep on and
block these Central files because if you
go D4 in fact whites two pieces uh the
Knight The Rook and the queen a third
piece as well targeting that pawn on D4
you just end up losing that pawn so this
is not even an option for black yeah
it's not an option and for sure just for
a second there he looked really pained
on the camera he looked like he hated
his position and as Tanya says here
Knight takes born you kind of attacking
everything and this will be almost
winning for white immediately so uh the
sticks are extremely high not just in
the tournament but also in this exact
position Pawn takes Pawn is a threat
version needs to deal with it and he
needs to do it quickly more than five
minutes can you actually allow yourself
that in this time control Robert I don't
think so and not only is it the time
Patrol is a problem it's a two-game
match so you start feeling the weight of
this game it's not like a four game
match you lose game one you get a few
whites to get back in it if he loses
game one I mean he has to give it his
all in the second game and he has to win
that on demand so he is in trouble right
now they're pins left and right uh the
both kings are in the Sun enter but the
problem is that this Pawn sticks out
like a sore thumb on D5 that black
isolated pawn and that is the target
alireza look at him he's biting his
sweatshirt he doesn't know what to do
he's worried does my opponent have four
or five more moves of theory up his
sleeve and that is scary territory for
the young player who now lives in France
yeah and uh serrana we joked yesterday
that was it a possible picture he looked
Frozen he was so stoic I drink as much
against Magnus but today just a few
moments ago he kind of uh kind of
stretched it out he was looking a bit
excited and I think he knows he has
caught for Asia off guard this is as
good a chance as he's gonna get today in
this match and it looks like Oliver is
hiding his face behind his hoodie right
now in a big thing right out of the
opening you know in my opinion alireza
is the kind of player who when things
are not going his way tends to go on a
bit of a tilt and I'm just wondering his
match against Arjun was he that
devastated out of it that he just
decided you know what I'm not going to
prepare I'm not going to look at too
much ass I'm gonna get my rest and see
what happens I'm gonna wing it but when
you're playing against Serana winging it
is not a great idea yeah yeah that's the
way to lose freestyling against the top
players you have to have a match
strategy you have to have an opening
plan and especially he's playing one of
the main lines uh playing C5 in the
opening like that with black everybody's
been doing it over the last few years
everybody knows their stuff they've all
been studying that exact line Serana has
prepared a tricky rare variation we
mentioned only been played a few times
uh but for Asia he maybe should have
known uh what he should be doing here
and down to six and a half minutes
already it's like it's frozen someone
needs to wake him up someone needs to
give him a shake and he knows how
critical this moment is right and
finally at long Lassie castles as king
let's see how quickly Serrano plays
because if he keeps blitzing out moves
we know he's still in his repertoire he
has looked at this with our silicon
friends or mortal enemies whatever you
call the engines but if Sonic keeps the
pace that is really okay he's moving so
quickly this is this is not over the
board inspiration this is preparation
and this must be so annoying for alireza
to experience I like say just playing
immediately yeah it's Mind Games we talk
about the psychological battle sometimes
and in the opening there's uh so many
ways you can hurt your opponent either
with great preparation sometimes you can
Bluff them just by pushing them onto the
defensive Valley but he's doing all of
those Serrano he's bullying him on the
clock he's bullying him on the board
he's set up this really tense pin on the
defile and ferrugia was struggling to
find a move last move and castling was
by far the most natural he played a
natural move it still cost him about
eight nine minutes and now he's got an
even tougher decision ahead of him and
what hurts you the most is when you take
that eight minute make the right move
and then your opponent immediately
blitzes out a response and then once
again you go into a think tank where
what on move that's move number 10 and
alireza is down to five and a half
minutes Bishop E2 is the accurate move
that we were talking about the most
tempting option to take on D5 was not
the right choice to open up that file
the e-file with your king in the center
it looks like Serana is just on top of
this game he's got his preparation on
point and alireza is in trouble already
yeah and it's really unpleasant this
last move it's just a quiet move for
white keeping the tension and farouza
probably he spent the bulk of his time
thinking there just on the forcing lines
on the calculation your opponent plays a
quiet move and you're like wait I wasted
all my time working out all these
complicated lines and then you just do
that like
it's Phil it feels like uh yeah he's
thrown away that time on the clock and
yeah so start those calculations Anew
because there still is the threat upon
capture's pawn bishop captures Knight
all of these captures available to Alexi
serrana and his King is feeling a bit
safer some of those variations that save
black were because there was a check
along the e-file the bishop sits in
front of the king so in some of these
tactical sequences white will actually
be uh for the good because that Bishop
blocks any sort of check not to mention
that if white has a free turn maybe the
best move is to Castle the king get out
of the center and then continue to use
this pressure on the clock and the board
against other further this actually is
as scary as it gets for a top level
chess player yeah scary on the clock as
well four minutes now it's hard to kind
of offer him advice uh for Russia I
don't know what I would be doing here
just pure panic I think if I were in for
your shoes right now what is his biggest
problem because I have to say the black
king it looks quite safe I mean it
doesn't look like there's huge trouble
it's the clock he's down to four minutes
on the clock and and we see he's taken a
drastic dramatic decision to make this
creams Panic he's pushed that deep on
because of course afraid of giving that
up on D5 with so many pieces hanging D4
but it just loses a pawn you can simply
pick that up with the Knight white has
got three pieces attacking that pawn
black has only two Defenders and now
ferrugia down on the clock and down upon
yeah and I'm trying to figure out what
he wants next maybe he'll trade off a
set of nights and once white recaptures
again you can take with the Rook you can
take with the queen then he might move
the black queen out and start at least
creating some annoying threats against
White's undefended Queen side so in
terms of practicality it looks like a
decent decision he's at least going to
survive the opening but it has come at
the cost of a pawn and the cost of a lot
of time on the clock of course but the
best players in the world did rather be
down just one Pawn if it means that
their pieces get activity and as we see
in the analysis board Black's pieces are
free-flowing down material up in terms
of development the White Tank still
being in the center and if the Queens
come off the board let's say the Queens
get traded did Black remains down upon
you may think well I'm only down one
Pawn I have some chances here in an end
game because that pawn on e4 while it's
extra it's not going anywhere so that is
what alireza fuja has considered I think
with the lead on the clock that serona
has he can milk this endgame Advance
forever and at some point the clock will
be a huge issue for farugia Yep this
looks like the best version can get
right now just an end game uh queenless
position at least down the point and uh
Serana he will stop to think he's played
very quickly up to this point but he's
saving that time in the bank for later
and uh yeah it just looks like a master
class so far I really need to go and
study for Savannah's games when he has
white because every time I see him he
just seems to outplay his opponents or
seems to get a big Advantage even
against the best in the world it just
feels like if it was the same position
but future had 11 minutes on the clock
we might not have been so critical about
the whole approach he has sacrificed
upon to be able to get out of this
opening trouble makes a lot of sense it
really makes life easier you've got more
space you trade off more pieces at least
you're not losing on the spot but once
again the clock is going to tell at some
point and we see Serana doing what we
are advised when we start playing chess
when you're up on the material try and
trade off as many pieces as possible so
he goes for the idea of trying to get an
end game with Queen D4 and I don't
expect alireza to accept that trade he
says not happening moves away with the
queen yeah he Dodges the queen trade but
immediately Serrano replies again he's
hammering home the point he's oh well I
was gonna say almost 10 minutes of the
clock he's more than 10 minutes up on
the clock at this point he drops his
Bishop back for a defensive move for
white that Bishop was previously very
proud on G5 but now he's just
controlling all the squares lining up a
discovered attack against the black
queen and he's covering everything he's
going to Castle next with a pawn
Advantage he's not here by accident he
defeated Fabiano caruana to make it
through to division one he has performed
admirably in the rapid Chess
Championship he beat Vivid Gujarati and
Shakura mamador of in match play in the
global championship and now against
alireza faruja he is playing instantly
and David I think you and I are two of
the biggest culprits of this we get
ourselves into way too much time travel
meeting our opponents well ahead on the
clock and here we see ferujo when we're
not playing it ourselves but watching
someone else it feels like suffering and
I feel for farooza here because he's
just down the pawn with minimal to no
compensation yeah that's why we're not
there Robert playing with these uh
Giants because we get into too much time
trouble ourselves uh but for Asia he
needs to dig himself out of this hole
how do you guys deal with kind of being
in a funk it feels like farouza right
now he's just not himself
but the one thing about fuja is you
cannot underestimate him just because he
is low on time we've seen what a beast
he is with just seconds on the clock
he's one of the fastest players in the
world so Serana also needs to be careful
about not falling into the Trap of
playing against feroza's clock he still
needs to make objectively good decisions
on the board and keep that Advantage
going and we can see alireza is creating
a mess on the board look at that last
move notice that last move Bishop to C5
now the queen on A5 is hanging a
discovered attack but alireza doesn't
care about that he actually
counter-attacks White's Queen in the
center and wow no what just happened oh
knows the attack on his Queen and he
counter attacks against the black queen
I'm not sure that would have even been
on my radar that move Knight A4 what a
cool move and it's a double attack he
hits the black queen he hits the black
Bishop he's forcing the Queens off the
board and this has happened the Queens
are gone and what you were talking about
when your head material let's trade
pieces and now black shuffles back let's
trade those pieces when once the bishop
goes to E5 Bishop C3 just trade off more
pieces you have a healthy extra Pawn in
the center as long as you can defend it
and with the Knight okay he's doing just
that I think Alexis serrana is just
feeling it right now he got the exact
type of position he wanted as I was
mentioning a few moments ago that
players were telling me they felt like
Serrano was unlucky against Magnus just
didn't get the positions that he knows
very well and he has just that and more
in game one against feruja yeah ferrush
is in the funk and uh serrana is in the
flow he's just doing everything right so
far extra important okay no Bishop trade
there but uh plenty of options you can
just solidify your Central Pawn if you
want you can kind of go in with the
white knight there is an attack maybe
against this A2 Pawn uh the black Bishop
buying it from afar but I wonder whether
it's Serana cares too much about that
one uh he would like to keep a pawn
Advantage if he can this is very clever
I've got to say this last move from
ferrugia yeah and the more you look at
it the more you like it because you
realize that it's not just the A2 Pawn
that's hanging but also the E4 Pawn in
the center which means you kind of have
to give up one of them a natural looking
move like the advance of the the F Pawn
next to the Central Pawn to defend it
just means that you lose your material
advantage so always are there being a
little tricky while Serana looking like
Mr Cool on camera yeah for the first
time at least Serana has a question to
answer he's played perfectly up to this
point uh we do see that the evaluation
bar confirms his Advantage he is Upon
Our Patrol but still some work to be
done converting these advantages against
the top uh those Elite GMS it's still a
lot of work in such a position when two
pawns are attacked you're always is
tempted to defend your Central Pawn you
don't want to give up your Central Pawn
so I'm expecting Serana to make the
decision of actually keeping that E4
Pawn guarded while giving up the A2 pawn
and also opening up the a file in that
process the Knight jumping in to see
five attacking the B7 weakness lots of
attacks here yeah lots of threats for
Asia leaning back now two minutes
against over 10 minutes yeah this is the
right time to think this is the right
time to just calm yourself down you know
you've done a lot of good work already
and uh yeah how is he going to approach
it that's the big question for alireza
remember on the losers bracket it's best
out of two rapid games this is the first
game one more rapid game if they are
tied then it will be decided in
Armageddon tie breaks and one of these
two players will be knocked out today
the winner of the match will go through
to the losers quarterfinals
and we have a move on the board wow
serrana he's just doing the one-two
punch he was thinking to figure out a
plan he played that pawn push that Tanya
was recommending keeping his Center nice
and defended and then hops forward with
his Knight putting furniture back on the
clock and alireza farooja was the 2021
bullet chess champion he took down a car
knocked more in the process we know what
he's capable of but bullet chess is when
both sides have one minute it's faruza
with one and almost two at this point
and then we have Serrano with 10 that is
not good news for alireza yeah it's a
rapper chess against bullet chess and I
think we know who we would want to be
here in the studio whose time we would
want to have yeah and uh yeah the
knights attacked options do we move that
night we can bring it to some juicy
squares we can bring it into maybe the
A6 Square attacking Black start Squad
Bishop I'm looking for options here
maybe we can land it on D7
and okay of course he doesn't go for
either of those he goes for something
potentially even stronger he's playing
an amazing game because there are a
series of one move threats that he feels
that he can ignore and create better
threats for himself what he's doing is
giving up his Knight where it sits
taking this bishop in return so not only
will black have a compromised Pawn
structure where it will also have the
pair of Bishops look at that black
knight it's dominated by White's pawns
they're just keeping control of the
forward jumps and that means the bishop
pair will thrive in this position
serrana is playing a masterpiece thus
far let's see if he's able to convert it
because I would not envy the task of all
the Razer Fusia yeah these Bishops are
just gonna be so beautiful uh I think
having the two Bishops is my favorite
thing in the whole uh I was gonna say
yeah it's just my favorite thing
but uh yeah I mean here is like the uh
epitome of uh strong Bishops you can
just plant your Bishop on C4 look how
powerful they are controlling the whole
board look at this black Bishop it's
just a whole it's just a big Pawn here
uh block of wood on B6 locked in doing
nothing and of course he plays that move
Outpost for the bishop and uh this one
feels like uh Serrano has almost got it
in the back strategically black is
busted but uh he will be looking for
counter chances for Asia he's playing
bullet remember and uh after a couple of
moves he drops his Knight back this one
is dominated so he's at least trying to
reroute this piece I like that idea I
like the idea of trying to bring that
Knight to D6 an important defensive
resource uh we've been singing praises
of white double bishop and you want to
get rid of that you want to put pressure
on that once that Bishop from C4 moves
away you can actually push the C Pawn
yourself open up that dead Bishop on B6
which is really uh dying for some life
in this position so Ali Reza still
holding on still fighting with just a
minute and 20 seconds on the clock yep
I've got Serana still with plenty of
time in the bank and uh again I'm
expecting him at this point to just play
a kind of smooth seamless game and
convert this everything perfect so far
Robert and I feel like for farooza you
need to think you need to Envision a
future that seems best for your chances
and what that would be from my
perspective is taking away the pawns on
the left side of the board the Queen
side pawns if they evaporate that's two
for black one for white you go down a
pawn but with only pawns on one side of
the board that means that the Knight is
a better Defender so I do think that
there are some long-term chances here
for frugier the issue is he doesn't have
that that much time so long term may not
be that long for someone who only is one
minute and 20 seconds yeah and Serana
here he has a bunch of plans he can
start trading off all the Rooks if you
imagine all the Rooks disappearing from
the board then the Bishops only gain in
power they gain an influence uh also it
might be time soon to start advancing
your majority in terms of Pawn structure
white does have four versus three on the
king side so uh normally you should play
on the side you're stronger I wouldn't
be surprised if those white pawns over
there do start throwing themselves
forward in the near future and Serana he
has fans out there we saw Aditya
cheering on the young Russian in this
first game of today do share your
thoughts your questions your selfies
using the hashtag chess Champs on
Twitter you can also reach us in the
twitch chat ask your question come with
your comments let us know who you're
rooting for and we will address uh
questions from the twitch chat as well
we love having you guys joining us for
another exciting day of Chess and I just
looked across I saw Robert give a nod of
approval on this last move away not the
first time in this game it's
unbelievable play he's just restricting
all of Black's forces his Bishop was
under attack instead of sliding It
Forward into the center he goes to the
rim just making sure those pawns can't
move bring his other Rook into the game
now all of White's pieces are doing
something useful this is just such a
great performance and yet there's still
so much work left the top players they
do not go down without a fight another
raise the first he's remaining solid
even if his position does not look
desirable he's not going to make this
easy for Serana I look at that night
maneuver he jumps back with the Knight
trying to trade out one pair of Rooks
and now the Knight is headed towards
another Direction it wants to come to
that C7 Square where it does hit the
bishop on A6 it will land in the center
of the board from E6 to D4 so there are
a lot of night jumps that white needs to
watch out for uh and alireza is not
going to make this technique easy
Serrano still has a lot of work to do
yeah if one of the Bishops disappears
then we can start talking about serious
drawing chances for black I don't think
we'll see for Asia win this game he's
definitely not thinking about the result
here he's just trying to survive and uh
to put tany's idea on the board if white
does for example Advance support I'm not
sure which one then uh the Knight will
hit the bishop you don't want to allow
that trade but the Knight will at least
find a Central Square you might have to
trade it off if you want to prevent it
from landing on a nice Outpost so
farouzo he's kind of contorting himself
he's wriggling away trying to find some
activity for his pieces but Serana says
no I'm just going to step back with this
bishop and uh okay after Knight C7 is he
going to eliminate the Knight once it
gets here does he have a way to keep the
bishop pen intact
if you can he should win maybe he'll
just play around the night maybe he'll
just ignore it through now finally under
one minute what is the winning plan for
sirana in this game great question Kyle
if we had the answer we'd be playing and
winning these games but the key to this
position I think because of the clock
situation is you need to keep some of
the tension and then Serana says no not
at all I'm going to trade all the pieces
but that may look like we're liquidating
into an even end game just because the
materials even doesn't mean the position
is level look at the white king it's
about to run up the board if you see a
direct line diagonally up to A4 and it
can go up there and start harassing
Black's pawns so this is a an
advantageous end game for white the
bishop stare across to the king side
pressuring the black pawns over there so
it's white who can play on both sides of
the board that's the power of the bishop
pair
and this last move is six it might look
like it's got no idea but again it's
about those night jumps alirez are
relying on that Knight on C7 to get to
B5 to get to D4 trying to eliminate one
of the Bishops if he manages to trade
the Knight for a bishop he saves half a
point yep he will get the draw if that
happens but it's a big
he needs to run away from this trade and
there we go again he's utilized this
pattern many times Robert touched upon
it yesterday nights can be dominated by
pawns but they can also be dominated by
Bishops and often when there's two
squares in between them so this bishop
controls a lot of squares that the Black
Knight wants to use and yes The Bishop's
been kicked back but he's kept the pair
intact and uh yeah there's a clear path
for the white king sooner or later
you'll start stepping forward on the
side you're stronger and the players are
really speeding up here especially for
Azure so let's just see whether serana's
technique is sufficient it's definitely
very favorable this end game but still a
lot of work to be done one of the ideas
that white skin has is to move closer to
the C5 pawn it is a big weakness in
Black's Camp so imagine those light
squared Bishop steps one square ahead
and then the king takes its spot then
you bring the bishop back to attack that
pawn on C5 and create and show that the
weaknesses are going to count meanwhile
it's hard to come up with a plan for
black
that's often the case when you're
playing against the bishop the bishop
and Knight for black don't really work
so well in tandem uh it's very hard to
find a productive plan for them the
Black Knight is stuck where it is
because that black A6 Pawn black has two
isolated pawns on the left side and uh
that A6 Pawn is an eternal weakness and
I'm not sure what he's doing other than
just trying to hold the fort here for
Asia and sooner or later he will be
completely tied up on one side and
Serana will switch his focus and he's
already switched Focus he's going for
that isolated Pawn that we mentioned and
the only way to defend it is David is to
fall back with the Knight to C7 and it
might be tempting to actually trade that
Bishop but that would result in an
opposite color bishop and look at this
he sacrifices a pawn but this I don't
understand just grab the A6 spawn thank
you very much yeah finally the kind of
strategic Advantage we've been talking
about is going to become a material
advantage it's going to become something
more tangible but uh yeah I guess if you
can get one set of Bishops off the board
while the white king is stranded on the
side he will have some hope
oh I say that reluctantly because I
think this is hopeless for black now but
Robert it is something I was attempting
to foreshadow earlier though if white
takes the A6 and the C5 pawns but has to
give the B2 pawn and the bishops get
traded we may get a situation where it's
an extra Pawn for white but all pawns on
the same side of the board those may be
easier to blockade that is what alireza
is hoping for he's praying at this point
he's 20 seconds and Alexis Serana has
nearly five minutes on the clock so he
is trying everything he can he sees
certain positions they give him the best
chances but they're just chances at this
point as the advantage grows for Serrano
yep and this is textbook in terms of
clock handling for white Serana he's
spent a lot of time but he's used it at
uh the wise moments and he's still got
five minutes 20 seconds to defend this
position you will get a position later
when you have to answer very difficult
questions there might be a race between
pawns for example and to calculate that
with 20 seconds he might be uh bullet
Champion but yeah this one
is going to be an uphill struggle and uh
yeah Tanya I agree you should just grab
that pawn first what's wrong with that
one it's very admirable the way allureza
has been defending this game so far he's
been playing majority of the moves in
about a minute on the clock and he's
managed to survive it creative chances
look at that he trades the H2 Pawn for
the C5 pawn and the material balance
still black has got all the pawns intact
yeah I'm not sure I like that too much I
really kind of enjoyed the fact that
white had a majority on the king side
just saving it for later you could start
pushing on that flank when you're ready
he's kind of banking everything now
Serana on the white B Pawn running up
and promoting long term yes he might
pick off that straggler on A6 it's going
to fall in the next few moves but
Black's Knight is active blacks Knight
can go towards those King side pawns
maybe some offensive counter play and
you were mentioning it might be a race
it might very well be because look at
that night it's threatening the bishop
on C5 it has to fall back a nice Square
there making sure that the bishop
dominates the Knight not allowing the
Knight to jump forward but it can
because if you trade it will be a draw
on the spot with the opposite color
Bishops so Serrano making his intentions
clear he's never going to trade that
Bishop for the night yeah it feels like
he's a bit nervous though Serana again
just changing posture slightly on camera
his last few moves I don't want to say
ugly but pushing the white pawns now on
the king side whoa now all of the queen
side pawns have disappeared but the
Knight is trapped that is what Alexis
serran has been and he brings his Bishop
back the Knight is stuck so if the white
king slides back which is about to do
then the dark Square Bishop can join in
and attacking the Knight I think he's
winning that piece
went down to his last few seconds that
version and now Robert it's a simple
plan straight path towards that black
knight for the white king I think this
was a really cunning trap he said yes
you can get your ideal Pawn structure in
terms of just on one flank but uh you've
had to plant your knight on this
horrible uh Square you had to misplace
it and I don't see any way out there's
no Escape Route for that black knight
the only chance for Russia now is to
create a past Pawn this is the reason
for his last move he wants to start
pushing the black H Pawn forward and uh
hope it will be enough of a distraction
it's a race and uh does white lock it
down now on the king side maybe G5
stopping Black from creating a past Pawn
will that provoked resignation wow
suddenly has no plan the Black Knight is
stranded and lost
uh looks like no he still has some time
at this
he gets the king opposition but what he
wants to do is give up this Knight and
dart his King in to the enemy territory
I don't quite think it's sufficient but
if the black king runs all the way in
and then back to take this Pawn on G5 in
the dark Square maybe there are some
chances to start trading off the pawns
create a passer it looks completely
hopeless but that's what he's hoping for
that maybe Serrano will make a mistake I
don't think so giving up perfectly he's
played this game yeah he's played so
well and I'm expecting the king to drop
back and just to show Robert's uh idea
that the only chance to try and save
this game is to jump in with the black
king to kind of go in but it takes so
long you can pick off this Knight at
will and uh it feels like this bishop
should be able to kind of get its way
around at some point to go for the black
pawns I'm not sure exactly how to finish
this one off for white you do have a
whole extra Bishop now but you have to
at least keep one Pawn you need to
promote later to win this game so Serana
he's doing the right thing again sitting
on his hands just not committing yet
he's going to pick off this Black Knight
there's no way and it's going to come
out anyway so he's just trying to find
the way he can win it on his own terms
maybe without allowing any counter play
for the black king
looking for good for white two minutes
it should be enough yeah he is going to
go on to pick up that night because you
don't want to move the bishop allowing
the piece to escape out of the danger
zone and one technique can be once
Black's King enters you bring your own
King to defend that bishop or need to
defend those pawns and eventually the
bishop will go on to attack Black's King
Side Pawn we're going to see this being
played out white will pick up the Knight
black will move with the King forward
and I'm just wondering if Serana wants
to bring his own King to defend that
Bishop to keep the F3 Pawn defended
think that looks like a very uh clever
strategy Tanya although yeah still some
little ideas to work out a bit later on
the fact that saran is thinking leaves
been really devious up his sleeve he has
not catched the knife he might make the
pawn F4 wow giving up his Pawn for free
but establishing a past Pawn that he can
defend with his bishop and that should
land a winning end game so he could take
the Knight of course or get pushed upon
it there we go yeah but I only figured
it out because he was thinking like he
was spending time what else is he
calculating besides King takes Knight
Alexis Serana is a brilliant player this
game has been magnificent what a
performance by him whoa and okay we have
to go back to life boards everything
just happened there in the blink of an
eye and uh wow White made a new queen
with the eporn we'll go back and maybe
uh show that an action replay but uh
there we go is about to resign White's
Pawn Central Pawn did run through
promote and uh just in time to stop
Black sport and there it is he starts
off with a win Alexa is Serana ranked as
number 17 tea in the world a crushing
win over alireza veruja ranked at number
four in the world taking the lead here
Alexis Rona you seem so impressed with
this game Robert that was one of the
cleanest games I think I've ever seen
wow I mean it was that dominant from
start to finish great opening
preparation forcing Oliver Arizona's
back foot in time trouble and then
thinking of the critical moments and
finding breakthroughs like a pawn
sacrifice in the end game from the
opening to the middle game all the way
through to the very last Pond perfect
game incredible take us through the
highlights David yeah I just want to
show you how Serana finished it off as
Robert said perfect game this is going
to end up in some strategy books that's
guaranteed at some point and uh here we
were mentioning that white could simply
pick up the Black Knight some
calculations would be done but it should
be winning you only have to work out an
answer to Black's King running in
instead Serana came up with an ingenious
solution he realized that black knight
is trapped anyway he first pushed a pawn
forward before the black king can run in
and after a capture he simply took the
night now and this blockade ensures
Victory Black's King now if it wants to
come in which it did uh does allow the
black the white porn sorry to run
forward we'll see what happened there
but if you just stay then White's King
will slowly but surely creep in to
support its past Pawn so just to show
how the game finished the black king
came in Serana calculated this so
quickly now we saw everything happen in
the blink of an eye white promoted first
just in time to come back and stop the
black porn you just sit in front of it
blockade it and uh the white king will
come over to assist its capture in the
near future perfect game by Serana
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
percent of games
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
foreign
we're gonna take a break now for anyone
who are not subscribers on Twitch for
everyone else we're gonna dig into both
of the games in the first round of round
one on the losers bracket
[Music]
Robert calling it one of the cleanest
games he's ever seen Alexa is Serrano
with a magnificent win in the first game
here I have to say it was a very
impressive game you do not underestimate
Alex Alexis Arana he might be ranked
number 70 in the world but boy is he
dangerous with the white pieces and now
it's all about farooja whether he can
compose himself he does have the white
pieces next so he's just gonna have to
go forget what happened and just keep
playing just never let that tension die
and the other match up on the losers
bracket you cash against the mamadov we
had a win for the young 16 year old what
happened yeah and I have to say it was a
very impressive win from the young
Indian you know he just came very well
prepared it was mamadov who was under
pressure on the clock the whole time and
he just seemed to be struggling not just
on the board but also mentally as well
it just looked like he hadn't shaken off
those demons from yesterday and in the
end you know it was a big face but it
all fell down to a one move blunder by
namadov and after that you know this
this teenager he's a tactical genius
yeah and he doesn't let those chances
slip yeah and we do have a puzzle a
study a challenge for all our viewers
today from a study composed by gukesh he
composed it when he was only 15 years
old yeah and what what are we looking at
here yeah I mean this is the end line of
a study that composed and the one thing
I want to say is we've seen a lot of
answers on Twitter not many people I've
got it right don't be seduced by
material is All I'm gonna say but uh
just think about the opportunities that
white gets because this night is
stranded it can't join the action very
quickly and you have to remember some of
the golden rules and end games
okay that's a big big hint I don't want
to spell it out for everyone but it's
white to play try and find the plan and
once you get it you can appreciate the
genius of good cash yeah we're looking
for the next move for white you can
tweet your answer using the hashtag
chess champ maybe you want to tweet us a
picture of how you are solving this very
sophisticated uh study maybe you're
solving it with your friends family
co-workers what do I know tweet us using
hashtag chess Champs one lucky winner
will get an air things device signed by
Magnus Carlsen and composing a study
like this at only 15 years old first of
all will all Grandmasters do this
compose studies is this normal
um quite frankly no I mean it's very
rare to see someone study a composed
studies and it's also very rare to see
someone who's so young actually have
that interest so I mean no this is the
short answer to that question he is
young genius gukesh and he is in the
lead in his match on the losers bracket
second game is coming up very shortly
this is day two of the year of the
Innings monster more than five
five minutes can you actually allow
yourself that in this time control I
don't think so whoa now all of the queen
size phones have disappeared but the
Knight is trapped there we go
all right you guys some more action is
coming up have you guys composed Studies
by the way
uh composing that's another level yeah I
love solving them and while Ivanka was
showing us the study I was trying in my
head to understand what really stood out
to me was that cookies at just 15
composed the study absolute genius but
more than that shows the maturity that
he studied was an end game study not
with a lot of pieces it's all and that
is just a reflection of his maturity and
his creativity
what uh what a chess genius yeah what a
guy and he's in the lead in his match
remember on the losers bracket they play
best out of two games so this is must
win for alireza Borussia and for Mama
Dove and here we go game two has started
and we gotta remember now in a must-win
situation wow it's an open Sicilian it's
a night of Kaya your favorite opening
remember now he's lost four games in a
row wow has he ever been in a situation
like this I doubt ever in his career to
be honest and uh okay it's a revelation
of the night off White's Bishop coming
out to D3 and a nice little trick here
nice little tactic uh that we have a
little chuckle about here in the studio
but we have to show the idea on the
board because white is giving up a piece
but uh he it's just a piece of bait here
it's poisoned this night on D4 you
cannot of course take it because your
queen will be lost he's pausing I don't
think he's trying to uh work out if he
can take this Knight because there will
be a bishop check discovered attack and
next move the black queen drops so uh
we're going to head back towards more
standard conventional ideas and now the
White Knight is hit it will Retreat I'm
not sure which direction and uh the game
will go on and once again we see aloys
as the first one to go into the think
tank not a positive sign I think in this
this game which he has to win on demand
to force the playoff alireza is not only
fighting against Serana but his own mind
David as you pointed out that's was his
fourth loss in a row and that is going
to be super hard to block I think this
is big disadvantage to alireza yeah and
he has to avoid going into the tank for
too long this time we know the clock
cost him in the last game and uh okay
still early days he's thinking a little
bit now but Robert who do you think this
opening is going to favor I just think
that sometimes your strength can be your
weakness because one of Alvarez's
biggest strengths he can play any type
of position uh he is feeling at home
totally comfortable no matter what the
Dynamics are but Alexis surround on the
other hand he studies very deeply we saw
in that first game there he knew the
opening better here in game two it's
been an offbeat opening the queen out
early for black but he is the one who
has not spent any time whereas farouza
he continues to think here and part of
the reason why is that black queen
slices across the board the white king
will not be able to easily Castle so
he's not just thinking about where to
move his Knight is alireza fuja that's
under attack in the center he should
figure out what is his five move plan
where is his King eventually going to go
those are the big any questions that he
needs to answer right now before he
makes this turn five move plan wow he
ignores anything he just goes straight
on the attack what is with these
with these just never defending the
attacked piece but it's always as if
they seem to epitomize the concept of
offense is the best defense the Knight
is attacked he says I don't care about
it I'm gonna go for your own night and
that's absolutely crazy because if you
do take the Knight the centralized
Knight on D4 white picks up the Knight
on F6 and there's another Knight hanging
but also Black's Rook is hanging on h8
tactics everywhere yeah it's just total
chaos a big mess but it feels like a
mess that will favor white simply black
isn't developed and Black's King
potentially weaker in the center here so
I don't think he can stomach this I
think this Knight will be defended uh
you can defend this with its fellow
Knight maybe maybe with a bishop but uh
it's very complicated I'm happy that I'm
not playing this position as black
against varusia I've got to say but
Serana he will find a way to keep some
measure of control at least and uh
Robert in terms of a five-year plan or
five year plan uh what do you think
Serana is gonna go for here well The
Five-Year Plan is across 20 no in this
position I think that Serana he is
looking at that Knight he does not want
to give it up without a fight and what
is concerning from his perspective is
he's spending time it was just talking
about how well prepared he is he's
clearly out of his preparation he's on
his own which either means that alireza
did not make the most principled reply
in the position and maybe there's a
slight inaccuracy or it just can't study
every single line Under the Sun and now
he has to figure it out I do think
sliding the Dark Sword Bishop up makes
the most sense let's just defend our
night right with our Bishop we don't
want to block our other Bishop because
Knight V8 to D7 keeps our Bishop on C at
home so I think that after the Knight
develops the White Knight moves out the
way and then you kind of regret putting
your knight in your Bishop's path you'd
love to jump over that Knight to E6 with
your Bishop that's not legal
unfortunately so he has in fact
developed his dark Square Bishop instead
of bringing his Knight out well the
reason he took a little bit of a think
there was because once again we have a
position that we haven't seen before it
is brand new directory for both these
players and the one point that alireza
needs to keep in mind or at least show
what the point was with moving that
Bishop from C1 to G5 in the previous
movies that the B2 Pawn is also
undefended in certain positions you have
to be careful with that because you can
end up losing the queen but now for
example David if you were to fall back
with the Knight to B3 to defend that
Central Knight there are so many tactics
that you have to keep in mind is light
takes the Central Pawn a possibility and
we need to take a look at that because
wow white might be losing upon here and
let's just show the tactics now your
Bishop on G5 is hanging if you trade the
bishop on E7 black can't pick up the
Knight on C3 into meso time hit that
Queen on D1 or even stronger oh yeah
that is probably they say when you see
Checkmate look for better so you did a
good job there but also Knight takes C3
very strong there Tanya but I'm not
going to argue with Queen after
Checkmate and so Bishop B7 is not the
possibility and Knight E4 is what white
is relying on but it doesn't stop that
because you pick up the bishop on G5
white has to recapture the bishop and
now we're talking about that Queen on B6
it slides in gives a check and it's a
double attack white ends up losing that
Knight on G5 and this is huge trouble
and I'm just wondering if this move
Bishop G5 was in fact a bad move wow and
uh play transitions into a totally type
of a totally different type of position
I think he was afraid of this he might
have spotted this Tanya perhaps too late
for user there and he was forced to give
up his dark Square bishop and jump in
with the white knight a double attack of
course but uh black can hold both pieces
by return treating and just to catch up
with the game the night drops back and
the bishop It's All About Now a fight
for this outpost on D5 this is a
beautiful Square for the White Knight
supported by the bishop queen porn but
black has the bishop pair and can play
around the square this is very typical
for a sicilian I've always slightly
preferred white in these positions but
uh it's very much a matter of taste it's
uh going to at least enter a maneuvering
stage now both sides eventually will try
to get their kings to safety and maybe
Advance pawns on opposite flanks uh very
tense what do you guys think what are
the chances of this match actually going
into an Armageddon right now with Fusia
having lost four games in a row and he
has to win on demand chants are much
higher for Alexi Serrano holding this
game I think he just has such a solid
base to his position in any night orif
this is the opening that we saw in this
game the D5 square is so important the
Knight sits there but look at black
fighting for that square and not to
mention that only black has a dark
Square Bishop so if that Knight does not
capture the bishop on the dark squares
watch out in the long term you have your
pawns on light squares it means the dark
squares are exposed in White's Camp so I
just don't see what white goes after
here I like Alexi's position I like his
clock management and I just feel like oh
there is has not found his footing in
this two-game match this is his only
chance and he's doing everything he can
but I think that Alexa has been very
solid
again he hasn't put a foot wrong the
whole day just just a perfect game with
white and now solid with black that's
all you need to do at the top level just
survive the opening equalize and try to
turn things in your favor a bit later on
but as Robert says solid base a solid
start to this one is black at least he's
done something the first you didn't in
the previous game he's just uh
consolidated
things under control and for threats
keep coming he's hitting that undefended
white Bishop at some point I'm expecting
surrender to Castle and he's out of the
woods in terms of the opening no
problems at all it is a must win for
alireza Russia to have any chances of
taking this to Armageddon the situation
it's the same for Mama Dom he lost the
first game to get cash he has to win the
second game should we take a look at
what's happening I can see the bar is
liking the situation for gukesh with a
draw or a win he will be through to the
losers quarterfinals
and with a loss that one will go to
Armageddon but I do suggest we jump over
to take a look at what's happening
between gukesh and muhammadov
and okay still early days in this one
only one set of Pawns have been
exchanged it does look like a filler
door defense let me check yes it was and
uh here I've always been very biased
towards White you have a nice Pawn in
the center on e4 you have great
attacking chances where it's Rooks are
already centralized connected in the
center it definitely feels like mamadolf
look at the camera actually he's
suffering but he's taking big big risks
with black it's not objectively correct
this type of opening but uh at least it
keeps a lot of tension it keeps a lot of
pieces on the board and white has got
this huge plan of going F4 of pushing
these spawns and you hit that Knight on
E5 the Knight on F6 is soft imagine a
trade there where black skin side Bond
structure gets destroyed and gokish
needs just a draw to win this match I'm
loving everything that he's done he's
developed all his pieces he's taken out
the time to bring the Rooks to the
central file the bishop on D4 looking
strong the Knight on H4 eyeing that F5
Square F4 a huge threat on the board big
questions to Ralph what is he going to
play to counter all these ideas now
we've said like a million good things
for white we need to find some positives
for black now
um yeah I'm out of ideas but I will say
that he's giving it his all because uh
what the words David used objectively
the position is better for white and
that is true but if you are objectively
very solid for black then you just might
allow your opponents to make a quick
draw he it's it draws the equivalent to
a loss for Ralph momentov he's just
trying to keep some sort of imbalance so
we don't have a symmetrical Pawn
structure that's the good news there's a
rook on E8 for black staring towards
that white Pawn in the center it's a
very strong Pawn but maybe if you're not
careful it could come under Fire and
there's this Knight on H4 for white it
is aiming towards the F5 square that
will lead to an attack but maybe it's
also offside and there could be a way to
take advantage of that fact I love
White's position I think that Ralph also
is enjoying good Cash's position but he
at least is creating a position where
it's not just relying and opening
preparation both players are on their
own yeah both players are on their own
and uh I'm wondering you mentioned that
there's a big threat here Tanya and wow
he's prevented that threat uh in a
really committal way we've got to say
this one look too strong you cannot
allow White time to kick away the
central night but he's weakened his own
King in the process that is such a
drastic commitment on the king side and
I am not loving it it might have been
the only way to stop F4 but does it
really stop that far because now that
you've gone G5 I'm actually super
tempted to push that pawn even further
you know you were trying to stop my idea
but why should I you're hitting my
knight I'm hitting your knight and in
the entire bargain your king gets super
weak on G8 yeah
be an open King for the rest of the game
for Ralph uh very complicated uh
decision there um I guess the only
alternative for white would be to land a
knight in F5 if the Knight could sit
there forever you're gonna launch an
attack you're gonna win this game for
white but it can be eliminated so at
least uh Ralph here has some measure of
stability at least he controls the dark
squares but uh what do you think of this
one Robert it looks uh yeah very
committal if we both said but maybe it
was necessary he needs to take his
chances and while we acknowledge that
white has the better position from an
objective lens it does give the
opportunity for him to create an
imbalance and that's where these top
players go wrong most often if you just
give them a solid static position
they'll maneuver around improve and they
will not lose that edge here with the
move G5 happening your Knight's under
attack so F4 is a brave decision that
Tanya is calling for it's not our pieces
it's easy to make that move but for a
gooket she's like wait a second he does
it all right he does it he listens to
Tanya here uh maybe you you know you
know gookish better than we do but that
is a big moment because if black takes
this Knight on H4 I think he should do
that and white takes the Knight on E5
and pawn takes back black is temporarily
up a pawn the dark squares are under
Black's control the Knight on F6 can hop
over to H5 use those dark squares to his
Advantage so this is what you dream of
when you need to play for a win you may
lose the game but you do have winning
chances yeah for example here go cash
would most likely drop his Bishop back
I'm hesitate to kind of choose a square
you can make an argument for both
hitting either this Pawn or hitting this
pawn and uh okay he chooses immediately
of course go cash and yeah he's doing
the right thing when you only need a
draw just play your normal game don't
play don't make passive decisions don't
make negative decisions just forget the
resultant and that's when the best
results come yeah he's playing the board
not the math situation currently and I
love this idea Robert you were talking
about that extra Pawn but who cares
about the extra Pawn look at Black's
horrible structure on the king side and
that pawn is not going to survive for
too long one of the moves that comes to
mind is King moving forward to defend
that pawn on 86 and we've been talking
about this F2 Square David inside of the
bishop Landing there the queen can land
there putting a huge double attack you
hit that night you hit that pawn you win
that extra pawn and in the bargain what
has happened is that Black's King is
super weak I'm loving this approach by
gokish he needs a draw but he's not
playing for one and often that's the
best way to get it yeah
it's a great game from kakash so far we
were talking about creating endgame
studies this is just a really mature
performance and it just looks tough for
Ralph this game we can't look at on its
own it's because of the previous game
that he's taking all these big risks but
it looks like those risks are not paying
off right now and yeah it's tough to
offer advice I'm looking for ways to
kind of defend everything but I don't
think those ways exist right now
what would you be thinking here Robert
in terms of just trying to cling and
together kind of survive for the next
few moves I think he might have to
advance his Knight right the Knight on
F6 needs to jump forward up to H5 maybe
to G3 F4 but I do see the problems he is
going Knight H5 and this may be why he
loses the game as he's playing all the
moves that I've been talking about uh
but if he could plant his Knight in the
dark squares that does give him hope his
Pawn on H6 can be captured likely will
be captured but he's immediately going
to uh cement that night on the dark
Square so if black can completely
control that color complex note that
there are light Square Bishops on the
board that's good news for black who has
great control over scores like F4 and G3
a thanks to the pawn structure yeah and
we complimented uh Serana for his clock
handling
so so convincing here 10 minutes on the
clock and he's already made some very
difficult decisions aggressive decisions
uh it just feels like he's in the flow
he's trusting his instincts and that
really pays off maybe due to the
confidence he gained in the players a
few days ago we have a question for you
Mr David Howell on the twitch chat what
chess book would you suggest for an 1800
player okay uh interesting question
there's a lot of Chess books out there
these days
um it depends what you're looking for if
you're looking for a kind of general
advice then
I think it's a fantastic book uh it you
know shows some positions and you they
look like very normal positions from an
everyday game because they are in fact
from games and you can work through them
and they have uh analysis throughout the
chapters that can help you uh improve
each other it's an old book but okay and
for basically any level could enjoy that
book I think so I think it is geared
towards the 1800 level player so that's
the perfect answer for uh this person in
the chat so I think it is geared a
little bit for a more advanced player
but it's very helpful for players of all
ratings fantastic what the book is
currently on your nightstand uh chess
book yeah I don't know is it a chess
book or is it definitely no chess books
right I'm in a book club so a new book
is always there really yeah what are you
reading now then you said you'd uh only
read about five chess books in your life
so I mentioned one out of five I don't
know about my spot I didn't know whether
that was a big secret as I was asking I
was like wait was I supposed to say this
but yeah is that so yeah I have not read
many chess books so that is the one I
have red
because I'm a bad student when I was
younger my coach would say read these
books and I'd be like yeah yeah you know
ah so you've been more working with
analysis computers stuff like that no I
just there are a lot of give me a lot of
puzzles so I was always working on
puzzles and studies and things like that
but never reading a book from uh front
cover to back I just wasn't really my
thing I love to read now but back then
it wasn't a big reader how interesting
well how about you Tanya favorite the
chess book do you have a chess book that
you're reading currently I do love books
I'm pretty old school like that and I
have read more than five books but yeah
I would
toast that I would really recommend the
girlfriend series I think they're really
brilliant the positional decision making
especially I really like that and one of
the recent courses that I finished not a
book is accessible course and that is
the check meeting manual okay it's got
these different patterns and great for
tactics it's actually one of the courses
that I finished before the Olympiad but
it didn't help check made in one before
yeah it's been a while
ouch that is one that I would really
recommend and ramesh's new book a funny
story around that it's a great book by
the way
it's on calculation and improving your
calculation technique it was at the
finals of the tour last year this was
in Miami the one before the finals and I
remember that Prague I think had won his
match against Magnus and then Ramesh
went and gifted this book to Magnus and
I was like that is not great timing
Ramesh but Magnus loved it and
immediately was solving exercises
tonight really it's a great book and
definitely one to check out Tanya do you
know where that book is right now
that book is right next to my bed and
it's
that exact exact one I I opened it the
other day I was like wait why is Ramesh
signed this book to Magnus and I I
really you know yeah I realized one time
Magnus uh like he was just like oh take
this book you know you learned something
from it I think he was trying to mock me
and I just did and uh I haven't read it
but that exact book is by my bed I was
amazing to say because Magnus had just
won the tournament when Ramesh gifted
him that book and he didn't care about
what he'd just want he immediately sat
down and started solving it
incredible why is the best okay and the
name of the book was I I know that it's
on calculation and I'm gonna look up the
exact name calculation by Ramesh you
sure you read this book
[Laughter]
well uh while we're talking about
calculation and uh actually I think that
one book of the year and many awards yes
um yeah a couple of moves on this board
uh it's just uh kokesh restoring the
material balance and Ralph trying to
survive on the dark squares a bishop
trade Black's Queen is going to be lured
away from the King side it's called
improve your chess calculation that's
the one by uh rubbish yes Ramesh the
coach of pragnananda
and some other young Indian yeah pretty
much all The Grandmaster from India
right now and the one thing that you'll
notice about them just how good they are
in calculation this is the book you need
to get fantastic tip for everyone out
there yeah go out and get that book all
right we have a few moves in this game
is kukesh getting closer
to the match win it feels that way I'm
not sure whether he's played the
strongest moves necessarily but he's
played very solid moves very good moves
and
um okay meanwhile mametov is doing a
good job of Defending uh he seems to be
making moves while his hands are on his
head so I don't know if the pieces are
levitating in front of him or how he's
doing that with the mouse but Black's
Knight has at least found a nice solid
defensive Square holding everything
together plugging a lot of weaknesses
around the black king the white Bishop
not looking great I was going to say now
you really need to relocate your your
pieces that white knight needs to find a
better circuit there is a very weak Pawn
on the H4 square that uh gokash could go
for later but most of all he's still
taking no risks white is super solid he
hasn't burned his bridges in terms of
going for the attack yet the reason I
like mameto's position is I believe that
in certain end games if the Queens come
off the board for example that black
could be the side for choice this Pawn
on e4 is an isolated Pawn we've talked
about this a lot in other positions
where isolated pawns they can be
attacked but not easily defended a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn so we
see that momentov he's just finishing
his development he can slide his Rook
over to d8 that would be a huge question
for gokashan if he brings his Rook to d8
right now we may see a queen sacrifice
for two Rooks two Rooks worth Five
Points each that's ten a queen worth
nine who does that favor here I actually
like the position for black at the very
least I like it for the side that needs
a win you want the imbalances yeah so
for example to follow that variation
through uh the queen could give itself
up for two Rooks technically white is
one point ahead if we do a bit of maths
but in terms of who's stronger here the
black queen or the white Rooks very much
yet to be seen if anything the queen is
the one creating the threats about to
dive in and uh go for an attack against
the white king I would be terrified here
especially in a situation where I just
need to draw to make a decision like
that one so I think Ralph should be
asking the question I'm not sure how uh
go cash would answer I don't think Queen
takes Rook is on the cards here maybe
okay he doesn't ask that question I was
gonna say maybe the queen just moves
away uh or maybe the white Bishop blocks
any attack instead Ralph just makes a
non-committal king move he's getting
ready if needs must to bring its Rook
across and defend this Pawn
now the more I look at it the more I'm
starting to like it for black it's he's
done a great job of uh just yeah
surviving and uh asserting some level of
control
meanwhile White's Bishop is a problem
piece and he's using this to block the D
file that asks the question what's your
queen doing on D2 what's your Rook doing
on D1 the bishop gets in the way uh
starting to turn in Black's favor I
would say
I think one of the ideas of moving that
Bishop blocking the D file is also to
vacate the F1 Square for your Rook to
land that you're always looking for open
files for your pieces especially the
major pieces the Rooks and the Queens so
Rook on F1 will give a direct Target for
white you can start doubling up now that
black has committed F6 white can look at
doubling up what is Black's resource
against this is to try to block that f
file by jumping that knight from G6 to
F4 but then watch out for that H for
weakness yeah that's a very weak point
and it will remain so for the near
future
um so let's see whether kakash goes for
that plan maybe he'll start trying to
improve his Works they really need to uh
wow okay he finds it creative uh way of
doing that Tanya I love it that's
another square and making his intentions
very clear David he did not put that
Rook on F1 puts it on G1 looks like wait
a second I was just talking about open
files that's a file that's completely
blocked but his idea does he want to
push that jeep on open up that g file
Target the black king on G7 the Black
Knight on G6 it looks double-edged to
open up the white king as well as the
black king but it seems like that's what
he's going for unless it was a mouse
slip I don't think it was a master maybe
he meant to play Rook F1 he can correct
that now but uh now Ralph is saying okay
open up the g-fold please because the
Black Brook suddenly on h8 would uh have
a direct line towards the white king no
chance in a game where you just need a
draw you're not pushing that g-pawn I
know we say play like it's a normal game
it's too risky and something that I'm
noting is that time Advantage for good
cash it's shrinking Ralph making great
moves quickly because she's struggling
for a plan and the side that controls
the pawn breaks is usually the side with
the advantage black has this move B7 to
B5 moving the pawn next to the queen
that tries to open up that flank and
create an outside pass Pawn because if
white is to take the pawn on B5 and
black takes back now all of a sudden
there are some runners in the position
and that's scary news for Lucas who does
not have a plan of his own and I joked
about the mouse slip guys but it did
happen he brought his Rook that's just
backtrack he brought to G1 I'm maybe
about to leave her open the king side
but uh after Ralph's reply of Rook to h8
saying yes please open it up he said
okay I'm too scared I'm going back and
he's lost a move Quick Cash it's maybe
not the most useful move that he's given
his opponent but black has gained a
tempo for free and uh he's definitely
showing some indecisiveness and while
talking of weird mysterious Rook moves
Rook to G8 for black what's this Rook
doing blocked by its own King definitely
feels like the players are showing some
nerves and they're just trying to get
quick moves down on the board and
staying flexible with their plans wow
this is getting wild and I think there
are some actual like tactics in the air
white is never going to take this Pawn
on H4 so look at Ralph he moves his Rook
up so he can slide his King away from
his rook's path the Black Knight going
to LEAP into the F4 Square this is
really dangerous territory for gukesh
it's not the type of position he wanted
he played an opening that was supposed
to be very solid comfortable now it's
double-edged it's sharp and I'm liking
the position for Ralph momentov he's a
clear plan in the position and for the
young gukesh his King is going to be the
one that's more danger yeah it feels
like he needs to pull the brake and
somehow maybe get the Queens off just
find uh safety in an end game then again
Robert you mentioned long term in terms
of the Bishops in terms of the color
complexes that favors black too
um yeah hard to offer advice it feels
like nothing's gone wrong yet but it is
certainly momentum black right now
these last few moves have been just
super impressive the way black has moved
around with the rook and then boxing is
King on nature making sure that the Rook
on 87 is ideally placed the Rook on G8
is nicely targeting the G2 pawn and I
have to say that despite the pawn
structure it looks like it's a white
skin that might be in danger which is
why the move Queen to F2 offering a
queen trade I like that idea David if
black does trade Queens White's other
Rook can jump over to the F5 can develop
their target that F6 weakness uh this
could be the way that gokish saves this
yeah just to show if the Queens come off
at least you have targets for white you
have some level of safety but uh let's
go back to the players at least in terms
of body language Ralph looked devastated
about 15 moves ago suddenly he looks
really interested in the position
suddenly he looks much more optimistic
about his chances and
um yeah gakash looks like he's still
thinking now clocks are roughly level
roughly balanced it's anyone's game now
Rook F2 who feels really indecisive I've
got to say for good cash it feels like
he's just trying to hold the fort but
that's not a great way to play it's not
a comfortable way to play this type of
middle game and he shows his idea he
wants to fall back with the bishop to F1
and then defend that G2 Pawn but
absolutely agree with you that there
hasn't been that much Harmony in White's
moves the Rooks and the Queen the last
few moves that he's made have only put
them in worse spots and where are you
really headed with that D2 Rook the
after Rook you've got no squares to play
meanwhile black has managed to get all
his pieces on the very best quiz yeah
except for one the queen so we can bring
the queen to G3 then white king is a
world of hurt so I think the queen is
going to slide backwards to E7 then over
to G7 then try to go up to G3 you need
to bring that last piece the biggest
piece the best piece into the attack and
as David is showing you that's where the
queen belongs step one complete he
brought his Queen back to E7 this is
getting more and more dangerous for good
cash and look at the clocks by the way a
rough moment of nearly three minutes can
kukash his time is getting near three
minutes as well when both players are in
time trouble you want to be on the
attack and that's what Ralph momentum is
starting to bring at kukesh's King yeah
positions like this all you need to do
is imagine you know how am I going to
deliver a Checkmate which piece he needs
to land where and that's how Ralph very
quickly came up with this really scary
plan uh I'm fearful gakesh I think
Armageddon is quite a possibility here
because what are you doing with white
you're just completely tied up your
Bishop your Brooks your queen there's
nowhere to go no way to improve your
position and uh three minutes on the
clock I think you need 30 here to work
out a defensive plan for white this is
terrifying for white and we were just
talking about the opening and how much
Advantage it seemed that gokish had and
everything looked great and now suddenly
Ralph has the initiative he's bringing
all his pieces every single one of them
against White's King kokesh is on the
defense the only hope I see in this
position is that if black was to slide
over with the queen to the G file maybe
he can try to trade off a pair of Rooks
on the D file he moves The Rook all the
way down and the reason he does that is
he's vacating that D2 Square for the
other Rook to jump in so that he can
control and defend that G3 check that
Robert was talking about and also
potentially offer a trade on the back
rank in Black's position once the Rooks
double up
yep but he has wasted a bunch of time
with his Rooks this Rook was here what
five moves ago his other Rook has spent
five six moves getting to a very passive
square and he's gonna have to move it
again can Ralph take advantage of the
tempo here and find a threat I think the
most logical as you say Tanya is to
slide across with the black queen what
else could he be looking for there are
ideas of sacrifices at some point in the
near future Black's Bishop Black's
Knight could capture one of the white
pawns around the king and just blow open
the position but it's about getting it
in the right order do you jump in with
the Rook first you jump in with the
queen first how do you land a punch with
black in hakara Nakamura likes to give
the advice you need to play good moves
quickly rather than the perfect move
slowly and he made this move just now
did Robin sliding his Rook over giving
up the H4 Pawn I love it open up files
against the white king here have a pawn
what happens when you lose pawns you
gain an open file so I think Ralph spent
a little bit too much time it's a bit of
a speck out of sacrifice but if he had
played that move in say 15 rather than
50 seconds he would continue to put go
cash in trouble on the clock and now
this is a tough position as David said
you need 30 minutes to figure it out
rather than three but go cash he picks
up that pawn he's showing no fear Ralph
slides back this is anyone's game at
this point is anyone's game White's
going up a porn but black is going all
in on the attack against the white king
there's bound to be further sacrifices
it's bound to be a kind of long-term
attack can go cash survive that's the
big question either you Retreat your
knight right now or you move your Rook
out the way I guess to defend it for
example the night Retreat though will
allow the black queen to slide over and
look at this look at the battery that
black is lined up against the white king
this is just fearful uh I mean I'm
terrified if I'm defending this one
kukesh finds a different defense he
steps his Rook up defending the Knight
with his Queen but uh still Clinging On
to dear life Black's Queen has uh poised
herself ready
to give a check the bar is going
slightly up for gukesh yeah this last
move maybe Ralph missed it I've got to
say
uh pause for thought because actually
visually it looks like uh something
should be wrong for white but it is all
defending uh each other all those pieces
actually perfectly placed to defend
that's a stunning resource that gokish
has found in just seconds he plays the
move Rook G3 visually does look like
something should be hanging but actually
the tactics all work out for white and
if you manage to trade off the Rooks the
attack is gone you're up upon and I
think you're absolutely right that this
was a resource that Ralph missed and we
see him slowing down after a little bit
you know he's played all these amazing
moves jumping with the Rook sacrificing
the pawn but now that attack comes to an
abrupt halt How do you even respond you
can't pick up the Knight on H4 the queen
is hanging you can trade pieces on G3
but after all the trades that will
happen on G3 it will be the king who
will be the star of White's position
defending that Knight on H4 we have a
result you guys and the first player is
knocked out of the air things monsters
division one alireza Borussia he loses
also game two to Alexa sarana that means
young ferocia he is out
Serana goes through to the losers
quarterfinals is this a big upset Robert
I don't think so of course alireza fuja
is the favorite in that matchup but in a
two-game match uh the side that is lower
rated has better chances and Serrano
played a great game one he played very
nicely in game two I saw that off to the
side of the screen so he deserved it he
moves on he fights another day and
kukesh he's looking to do the same in
this one and yeah it's getting worse and
worse for Ralph mehmedov I mean the way
that gukesh has handled the pressure has
been uh just really mature yep the last
three full moves have been disastrous
for black uh just trading off a set of
Rooks losing that pawn and now all the
cash needs is one or two accurate moves
to fully rebuff the attack and he should
be able to convert this and he has an
extra minute he has draw odds those
bonuses in his court as well
um yeah I'm starting to not see actually
any weight forward for black I think
white can just push the pawn to G3 hold
everything there we go from gakesh cover
all the squares kick away the Black
Knight defend your own Knight and uh
there we go once the retreat begins it
might not stop and
put cash doing all the right things in
terms of defending this one and now once
White's pieces start moving forward
there's not going to be any stopping off
that G3 really nice move pushing that
Knight back and now the Bishop from the
first round can actually go to E2 also
hitting that Knight but another nice
move by go catch a different approach he
moves the queen to the open file so
eyeing that F6 Pawn there Rook G7 big
threat on G3 so gokish still needs to
find an accurate way to defend it yeah
and the clock under one minute now could
play a factor this was very much a
bullet game uh only a three second
increment these guys will never have
more than a minute I feel for the rest
of the game Khan gukesh conquer his
notes he's not known as a online
specialist yet as a blitz specialist
whereas Ralph is very experienced in the
Blitz and bullet time formats so could
that uh maybe be a glimmer of hope for
him and cash down to 35 seconds for
himself he plays G4 great move but Ralph
he has that experience he was back in
the ICC when it just started he knows
how to play in these formats and you see
his night hop into a great square and
white trying to do the same but it can
be eliminated and that gives black an
attack I actually love that his Knight
is planted on F4 it cannot be kicked out
by any of White's pieces yeah whereas
the White Knight can be eliminated at
any moment and suddenly threats uh
they're back on the board Black's Queen
could try and grab a pawn at some point
okay nice defensive move kukesh holding
everything together yet again yes he's
Advanced his pawns but from a human
point of view as long as you cover them
as long as you defend them black is
running out of ammunition 20 seconds for
a Ralph 25 seconds book of cash
what is going to happen all bets are off
uh although objectively it does feel
like white should have some control
Queen effort he tries to get the queen
into the game from the other side you
can think about a position where the
queen lands on C5 or on 86 really
putting the attack but that Rook on the
open file D file gives gokish the
defensive resource I like to smooth
Queen E3 taking away a lot of squares
from Black's Queen yeah but uh then
again Ralph is also finding some good
squares for his pieces the Black Knight
now sitting pretty in the center and
there is a past Pawn in the position
Black's E Pawn protector Plus Pawn will
start motoring down the board I'm
expecting now uh you might not get
another opportunity five seconds for
Ralph you have to move okay Black's Pawn
advancing white trying to kick away the
Black Knight it's just blow for blow
black trying to get his ideas on the
board and good cash every time trying to
shut the door and if you have to retreat
for black it's not going to be a good
sign and two seconds
he's getting the moves off if they're
coming in fast Brooke goes you want to
stop that pass pawn and well look at
Rough metal if he brings his Knight in
because the bishop captures all of a
sudden black has a very far Advanced
pass Pawn you see the eval bar dip as
well this is anyone's game unless kukash
has a draw by repetition that's what he
needs to find he only needs a half point
to win the match yeah I don't think he
should be aiming to win this one anymore
Black's Pawn is too strong okay the
Rooks are off you need to give Eternal
checks otherwise the Blackboard is going
to become a new Queen suddenly the
stakes are extremely high for good cash
this is not an easy position to develop
to defend with only a few seconds left
wow that black pawn can start running
any moment maybe even now does white
have enough checks with the queen Ralph
is banking no on being the answer
wow you have to hope now you just have
to cross your fingers and pray uh for
good care she's giving some checks but
the black king is running towards the
queen side the checks are drying up oh
my gosh he's trying to run behind its
paws use him a shelter but maybe there's
only one or two paths towards the draw I
wouldn't be surprised if at any moment
only one white move makes the draw but
he doesn't have a check along the E file
the black queen takes control of it I
don't see it I don't see it either
fourth check and then King goes to A6
and there are no checks on the board
yeah oh my gosh oh there's no more
checks there's no checks he's making a
new Queen there is a threat oh my God
yeah this one looks like it's winning
now for Ralph mamadov now just give a
check don't allow Checkmate what had the
sneaky threat of bring the queen to the
corner to A8 to mate but now all tracks
have dried up and uh this one is Game
Over Look at that celebration from Ralph
mamadol she wins it he wins it one of
him incredible play there so resourceful
it's the bullet experience it's that
speed chess experience that Ralph has
over the years
oh his young rifle couldn't keep up wow
you can't replicate experience and that
one was going both players I mean just
making moves and they barely had time
and Ralph momentum he earned that
Victory from the start he played
exciting chess he went for he didn't
mind losing the game but he made sure
that he had chances from the start and
he won
we're gonna see Armageddon you guys
fantastic and that was uh some
explosions in the end there what
happened here David I'm trying to work
out what happened it was so complicated
uh we talked about this queen end game
where the game was eventually decided
already at this point the checks looked
like they dried up and it looked like
gokesh was crashing to defeat he didn't
find a way to stay in the game it looks
like he should have given a check from
the center but even here he has to find
some miraculous resources to survive it
looks like the checks are uh disappeared
now but you could throw your Pawn
forward trying to create a checkmating
net and after porn takes porn you throw
another Pawn forward trying to deliver
Checkmate but for a human this is too
difficult to find I think most of us
here we wouldn't find it especially with
a few seconds left on our clock and just
to show how the game ended after a check
the black king did hide another threat
now of Checkmate and the killer blow was
just a quiet move the king steps back to
defend and note how after this queen
move black can make a new Queen very
safely because this Pawn is actually
defended the White Queen can only give
one check but no more two queens are
better than one and Ralph took the
Victory and that means in about nine
minutes we will see Armageddon tie
breaks to decide the match between
gukesh and mamadov but the other match
on the loser's Market is decided and
Alexei Serrano goes through to the
losers quarterfinals congratulations
like say
oh hello thank you a crushing match
against the Fantastic Olive Russia how
happy are you with your performance
today
yeah today I play the Amazing chess uh
yesterday I lost much without any
chances and I wasn't quite happy with
spellings that I play against
alireza I didn't think that I have a lot
of chances but
I was really happy that at least I
played it shows the game with white it's
gives me more opportunities like
and I was very lucky with opening I also
prepared it against Magnus and
in this game it happens and it worked
quite well I just got
a lot of advantage and a lot of time
and wind came very confidently first
just because of opening
fantastic so you were actually able to
use some of the preparation you had for
Magnus yesterday to beat alireza today
yeah yeah a bit
to be honest I didn't expect that the
Magnus will play it I just prepared it
maybe for the next game maybe for this
match here and hopefully it works in
this match suddenly yeah and what does
it mean to you to now well first of all
you made it through to division one and
now you're through also to day three
here in the air things Masters what does
it mean to you
it means a lot and it is really a cool
result that I
continue to show very good chess in
in Rapid online I'm very happy with it
and very satisfied
and and before of course even just to
qualify to division one is an incredible
good result
so and now I managed to do the address
yeah just amazing
fantastic Alexa congratulations on a
great match I just have one question for
you who would you rather face in your
next match Wesley so or Hikaru Nakamura
probably restless so I will play with
someone of them yes
oh oh I should
oh my motherfuckish no no so you will uh
play uh the loser from the winners
semi-final between Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so
it will get tough much
everybody's tough here but you must be
feeling quite confident after your
performance today
probably yeah
well I like saying we have to say big
congratulations on a huge performance
today and best of luck tomorrow as well
thank you thank you for joining us
all right that is a very happy Alexa
serrana making it through to the losers
quarterfinals to face either Wesley so
or Hikaru Nakamura who will meet each
other and the winner is semi-finals
later today but we're gonna see some
Armageddon chess for the first time in
the 2023 season go cash and marmadov
they have to decide their match in
Armageddon
how exciting is that Tanya super pumped
to see that one I think we all love the
Armageddon understand with the new
bidding format it's going to be that
much more exciting but I have to add the
Alexi looked so happy and so excited
about his win until you mentioned that
he'd either be playing wrestling record
that's when you just took all of that
away yeah you know I've commented so
many Alexis matches on chess.com
throughout the years so many successes
you just have to be honest with the guy
your next opponent your tournament's not
over your next opponent will be one of
those two so good luck to him it was
great to see him happy and he played a
fantastic matches he said so himself
yeah what a day for Alexa Serana and the
chess continues you guys Armageddon is
coming up very shortly
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you did you not notice your
king was in check and still can't figure
out why the pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
if you're not a subscriber to Chester
home on Twitch we're going to send you
to a twitch break now if you are a
subscriber well we're going to dig into
all the action happening today
[Music]
we're gonna see how do I get done for
the first time this is how exciting is
that yeah my nerves are dangling I mean
I can't imagine how the players are
feeling actually right now I mean it's
also a kind of different mindset that
each has
um mamadov of course he will be riding
hi you could just come off a victory you
know in a clutch win with the black
pieces you know here's that proverbial
man in the dark and he's found treasure
and then we have good cash of course who
he's just uh thinking he had it in the
bag he just threw it all away but I have
to say kukash he did say that he's been
training for these kind of moments
really yeah you know during the pandemic
while other players were kind of
improving their chest he especially
focused on playing under pressure and
actually adopting the right mindset to
him you know he says okay there's nerves
there's going to be disappointment let
me just Embrace that and let me get on
with the job in hand so it's going to be
very very interesting and that must be
so important now only having 10 minutes
to get over a devil devastating loss get
ready for Something Completely new with
Armageddon where there's also no
increment yeah and it actually did say
you know what he would be doing what he
will be doing during that break he will
be meditating
he uses that just to calm the nerves and
just to get ready and focused for what
has to be done next and it's going to be
very interesting because we don't know
if he will be playing with black visas
who will be playing with a white piece
is the time control oh yeah
I'm like literally working myself up
into a state of excitement I mean I
really can't wait yep
the action continues uh everyone these
are the results from losers round one
Alex say Serana is true to the losers 40
quart finals knocking out alireza
farusha baraf muhammadov and you catch
they will play Armageddon tie breaks to
the side who has knocked out and who
goes through
and one thing is for sure they're gonna
need great air quality to play in
Armageddon and someone who has an air
things device at home is Grandmaster
David Howell
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Big D welcome to CCT Crips come on in
it's the hallway I call it the tunnel of
love this is where a true professional
chess player gets ready for the day this
is where I take my two hour baths every
day this is where I make myself look
oh Jesus Christ come into the bedroom
this is where whoa sorry about this this
is where the magic happens
that's where I get my eight hours every
night so this is going to be the office
this is where the streaming setup is
going to be it's going to be a desk the
whole way across the wall the living
room this is where I get my zen time my
chill time you've got the sofa you got
the fireplace in the corner and this is
where I spend most of my time I make my
trademark noodles my girlfriend insisted
this is here I hate it but she said we
couldn't get rid of it she's gonna kill
me these are my most prized possessions
my dad's robots and here you've got mugs
shout out to Princess Di but my favorite
of course this one
now we're done with the house tour it's
time to check out the latest addition to
the apartment air things have sent me
their latest model The View plus and
it's time to check out how the air
quality is here
[Music]
now it's time to configure this bad boy
connected what I love about the air
things device is that I always know the
air quality I do work a lot from home as
a chess player so I need to ensure that
the office the living conditions are
perfect and things have helped me to do
that
what a cool apartment David thank you
I'm cringing inside now everyone's seen
me uh you know you know my glory but I
hope they enjoyed it and I recommend the
Athens device yeah and what a nice
Olympian gold medal you have there all
right you guys we have to get ready for
Armageddon for the first time the season
Robert what are the regulations in
Armageddon okay well the base time is 15
minutes so the side that bids the lower
amount of time gets to choose their
color most often they'll choose the
black pieces and if the game ends in a
draw the player with the black pieces
moves on so 15 minutes for the side with
the white pieces and then for the side
that gets black well depends on what
they bid yeah and the player with the
white pieces has to win the game and I'm
curious do we have the bids in from
gukesh and mama don't we do go cash has
been 15 minutes Ralph Mama Dove has been
11 minutes with the lowest bid he could
choose colors he has of course chosen to
play with the black pieces he will have
11 minutes against gukesh with the white
pieces with 15 minutes no increment in
the Armageddon gukesh has to win this
game all right Tana what do you think
about the bidding here I think gokish
wanted the white pieces and he's happy
with it the game that he just lost to
Ralph the position was great and he just
did not have enough time that will play
a very crucial role so he did not want
to compromise too much on the clock it's
very important for gokish to just forget
what has happened the momentum of the
match has shifted slightly lukesh took
the lead in the first game went on to
lose the second one super important to
forget that just get it out of your mind
there's no increment here and uh big
momentail yep and we have updated so he
didn't bid 15 minutes I actually don't
think you're going to be allowed to bid
15 minutes he beat 11 minutes and 45
seconds so that's actually quite close
very close and we see Ralph went for 11
minutes ago actually just won by 45
seconds I call that a loss it depends on
you know your Vantage Point I think
Ralph really wanted the black pieces so
it's sort of a small victory for him and
I think that makes sense because kukesh
is not as experienced in these online
Blitz and Rapid time patrols so Ralph he
doesn't mind having the deficit on the
clock yeah so to be clear Ralph Mama
though bidding 11 minutes sort of one
the bed could choose colors chose now to
play with the black pieces and we'll
have these 11 minutes do cash we'll have
15 minutes with the white pieces and he
has to win the game
so bidding 11 minutes and 45 seconds go
cash do you think he also kind of wanted
the black pieces here it shows that
probably he was would
have been whites
then it's 45 it's still quite high and
uh yeah it's interesting the dynamic now
because remember it's 1-1 but both one
with the black pieces so he has to turn
it around he's the one with the weights
on his shoulders now in terms of getting
a playable position and it's very very
different from his previous white game
in that one we saw Philadelphia fence
White had the space Advantage White had
the attack very active pieces early on
but now we see kokesh switch away it's
one D4 this time and a slower slav uh
this variation of the slav uh when I was
commentating on Vikings day with Peter
Smith we were joking this came up every
round in the Masters or challenges it's
so topical so popular right now black is
Rock Solid but uh White often gets the
bishop pair and that makes a lot of
sense when all you need is a draw to go
through and moment of choosing an
extremely solid approach of the slav
here I think for gokish it's going to be
very important to just try and keep as
many pieces as possible and try and get
Ralph in a Time scramble get his clock
as low as you can before you create
Dynamic possibilities in the position
yeah no increments so you can hustle on
the clock for sure and there's no safety
there once Ralph ticks down below a few
minutes and uh a queen trade what do we
think it looks inevitable now but who's
this gonna favor and paper it should be
black I think that Ralph is showing his
experience in these formats in the
global Championship he lost a nail salon
in an arm again where Ralph actually had
the white pieces so he knows from his
past what he must do he's offering a
queen trade and as David just said this
should favor Black the position becomes
easier to play the time deficit doesn't
seem to be that instrumental in White's
Advantage here because black has so much
time remaining and the pieces are coming
off the board I like what Ralph has done
but still so much life left in this game
yep a lot of life left but the reason
here we are maybe favoring Ralph's
chances slightly is because the pawn
structure is completely symmetrical and
uh it's very locked up in the center
white even if he establishes that kind
of symbolic advantage of the bishop pair
that we see the first imbalance of the
game black as double pawns white has the
bishop pair it's still very hard to find
anything concrete to do with those
Bishops especially White's dark squared
Bishop not an impressive piece right now
very much locked in and uh black despite
the double pawns does have a semi-open h
file it's hard to pinpoint any
weaknesses in the black Camp it's going
to be a long grind if kakash wants to
win this game I like this approach by
wider putting the king in the center
It's The End Game the Queens are off the
board you want to make sure that your
king is an active Beast connecting those
Rooks but watch out for that H2 Pawn you
don't have the time to move that King
side Rook The Rook on the right side all
the way across the H2 Pawn hangs and
right now Ralph with another big threat
he moves the Knight forward to C4
attacking that B2 Pawn but does this
allow white the opportunity to grab the
Knight yeah he's allowing a small
imbalance and uh as white we've
mentioned it before if you want to win
if you're in a muslin situation you have
to add up the imbalances and hope that
they total up in your favor later and uh
rather than allow this Knight to live he
did eliminate it so it has come at the
cost of his Bishop pair but after this
last move especially he's banking on the
fact that this Pawn is going to be
caught in no man's land caught in
White's half of the board and maybe a
Target long term not just that David
look at the center now it's all white
hair white can't start advancing that E
Pawn at the right moment the C4 Pawn is
a weakness I like that last move A4 by
gokish really taking control and space
off the queen side making sure that the
black pawns can't Advance easy the
Knight can potentially jump to B5
threatening of fork I think a cage can
be pleased with the outcome of the
opening yeah this last move I've got to
say jumping in with the Black Knight to
C4 allowing this exchange it shocked me
I know he has to make quick decisions
Ralph because it's Armageddon but did he
need to rush with that it looked like he
had the perfect structure when only
needing a draw yeah it was not a big fan
of the move Knight to C4 I think it just
gives everything he could possibly dream
of and imbalance a pawn to Target and
now all of a sudden it's Ralph who needs
to come up with defensive ideas he plays
this move F5 wow he wants to control the
light squares his Knight can hop in
behind rather than in front of the pawn
and continue to control the squares but
that pawn on C4 it's a long-term
weakness and look at go Cash's move here
A5 he wants to slide his Rook up his H1
Rook eventually can come over the C file
to put more pressure sure on this
potency form I did not like the sequence
events that led to this Pawn being
overextended and I think Ralph is in
some trouble here yeah just one rash
decision and it looks like he's
suffering the consequences he's had to
take a time out to block the further
advance of this uh Intruder this white
apron but now it feels like the time to
go for that plan that Robert mentioned
go for this Pawn uh it's definitely a
weakness and once you've freed up your
Rook once you've for example moved this
Pawn to a safer Square out of the eye
line of the black Rook then this guy as
well is freed up to start attacking and
yeah it looks like gokash he's got what
he wanted very stable position with a
couple of small imbalances and uh enough
wiggle room to try and work things in
his favor there we go H4 putting that
pawn on a safe Square freeing up that
white rook in the corner Advantage white
we've got to say on the board and clock
right now
I like that Google has kept a
four-minute advantage on the clock very
important in the Armageddon and the
whole idea is to try to get your
opponent really down on the time with no
increment H4 a nice move as you were
mentioning the C4 Pawn is the long-term
weakness and yes Ralph only needs a job
but I don't see a direct path to it
especially with the Queens off the board
I'm really liking the way kokesh is
handling this end game yeah if you could
take all the Rooks off the board then I
would say yeah drawers the most likely
result but now there's no fully open
files to achieve that for black
um yeah the more I think about it the
more I really just like that decision he
made earlier off but he stuck with it
now he's committed to it and wow nice
move by go cash yeah mistakes are for
common Pairs and first there was the
pawn on C4 and then also up through A6
by black it's the pawn on B7 so go cash
he is not being subtle he is not hiding
his intentions he slides his Rook over
to the queen side so he can push the
pawn in front of it open that Rooks file
at the end of the line This is Pawn on
B7 there's going to remain remain an
eyesore black is going to use his heavy
pieces to defend it whereas white can
slide a second Rook behind the first one
and continue to pile up pressure it's
going to be a defensive task for Rafa
Madoff he is down under eight minutes no
increment I'm liking this more and more
for good cash yep one target is enough
to tie down Black's pieces and then go
cash will initiate step two of the plan
he'll be looking for other targets maybe
ways to step forward on the other side
of the board where he has this nice v
formation with the white pawns but he
also has a poor majority five versus
four on the rest of the board so it's
still looking good for white but he'll
be looking for the most accurate way to
try and press this Edge that he's got
and Ralph has also moved his Rook into
the defense I think what he wants is
that once you try to open up the B file
this B7 glaring weakness that you're
talking about after a move like B3 black
will have the option to also push his
own beep on because notice that Knight
on D7 after an on-person you can pick it
up with the Knight you can defend the C4
uh Pawn as well I do not believe that
black will allow the B7 weakness to
remain B5 will be coming up David at
some point that's very clever Tanya just
before it's too late before this Pawn
becomes fully backward and becomes an
eternal weakness tied down on B7 to step
forward I must admit sometimes I do
forget about these uh types of moves
when it does allow one person we're just
taught don't allow one person and uh
here however it does activate the Black
Knight and uh if there is a trade of
Pawns yes white has opened up a line
from the whoops sorry my arrows uh White
has uh
I'm getting better with the mass but uh
these Rooks don't really do too much
right now it's more important that the
Black Knight has found an active Square
uh so nice defensive resource and that
is cut out uh by white I was gonna say
and black prepares it by playing Rook B8
uh getting ready again to initiate all
of those exchanges by uh trying to
bypass that white Pawn on A5 Ralph
really creative there he's made up some
time on the clock he's only down less
than three minutes now but uh an uphill
struggle still ahead and I love this
move B4 that just was played by gookash
because if you don't take ampersant
ctxp3 now you can never do it and
White's next move is to plant his Knight
into C5 it's very well defended by those
pawns on B4 and D4 and if you can
capture and open up the B file on the C5
Square oh that's really bad news both
for the B7 pawn and the C4 Pawn that's
the first one that we said we were not a
fan of so this is a big moment for Ralph
he has to take on Busan and he I believe
at least and he's making this move quite
slowly so that's good news for good cash
who can continue to use his advantage on
the clock yeah really clever most of us
would be inclined to just push the
pulling forward one square but he
spotted that actually he wants to force
black to take this Pawn anyway and uh
why not force his hand by pushing two
squares forward again not on my radar
because I was so inclined to avoid him
passant but a very sneaky plan by gokesh
and yeah as as we mentioned one person
here does favor white backward Pawn
clear Target on B7 I think the big
question is can black still go B5 and
stop your Pawn from advancing one square
further where you will break it and uh
Ralph answers yes he can he goes for it
now the idea of jumping with the Knight
would just result in trades make it more
difficult to get that win for gokish so
he wants to keep as many minor pieces as
possible trades on B6 does the on person
yeah he does the uh he does go for that
and now I think the question is whether
white can go for the idea Robert
mentioned still Yes it won't necessarily
result in backward points but there are
targets immediately how does black hold
everything together white does land the
night there the Knight can be eliminated
of course and it looks like black has a
very good night against the white bad
Bishop but it's more about the number of
Pawns and here it looks like white can
very happily just uh start grabbing I'm
not sure which one I should go for I can
go for this one perhaps or I can trade
Rooks and then go for this one but uh
this looks like the acid test and okay
we get no answer to that one yet but uh
we could well see the solution soon
first the Knight did land on D5 and
white is indeed going for this Intruder
in his Camp it's not just the A6 Pawn or
the C4 Pawn there's also Knight hopping
up to D7 hitting the Rook on B8 and
going to E5 going to the center giving
the king a check the G6 Pawn is actually
an easy target I feel like black is just
going to lose at least one Pawn here it
might even be worse so Ralph he steals
the First Pawn by taking on B4 and
gookest quickly responds with Rook takes
C4 I feel like the problems will persist
here for Ralph momentov and the clock
it's at five plus minutes it's going to
dwindle as the solutions to his position
become harder and harder to find yeah so
many weaknesses in the black Camp level
material right now but it might not stay
that way for too much much longer can
Ralph Klingon and survive gokesh since
he's been given that opportunity been
very impressive I've got to say I don't
see a wave for black actually holding on
to that pawn for another move your
knight on B4 is attacked right now by
the by the bishop and The Rook it's the
one defending the A6 spawn you can't
push that pawn ahead you can't go A5
because it just hangs The Rook can pick
it up
it's just going to be an end game that
you're going to try and hold upon down
yeah
just have to find the best way to defend
when you are a pawn down I think it's
inevitable now personally I would be
inclined to get rid of that white knight
it looks too strong just traded off for
Black start Square bishop and okay he
hasn't gone for that yet but he does
have the opportunity now if you have the
Black Knight which is very strong at
least you can fight well against the
white Bishop in some circumstances yes
you'll report down forever but you just
got to do it I think here it's a choice
between a bunch of different evils you
have to uh you have to try and wow the
black Rooks jump in jumps in sorry
that looks surprising to me it feels
like something is loose for black the
bar yeah something feels loose I don't
see what to be honest right now it looks
like Black's hunting for counter chances
but
um does white have a way to take
advantage I think it's just a fake pin
because the Knight C5 looks like it
can't move because the Rook on C4 is
loose but if the Knight drops back and
we see uh the stockist suggests Knight
D3 or D7 same exact plan the only moves
that led to a huge Advantage glucose of
course finds it the point is that if the
Rook takes Rook on C4 the Knight can hop
forward to E5 with check for King The
King and this Rook on C4 you're going to
win that Rook on C4 then E6 and G6 are
just sitting ducks they're going to be
targeted and likely won by the white
pieces yeah suddenly big trouble for
black this Rook is attacked and no
matter no matter where you place it I
think there will be consequences for
example if you step back one square
actually the black king is caught in a
mating net I'm trying to find ways to
hunt it down the White Knight can step
back into the center there will be ideas
of for example stepping your Pawn
forward bringing your Bishop in going
for check mate this black king is
actually really stuck right now and not
many ways I see to get it out break it
out find some Escape squares suddenly
big trouble maybe there are more
convincing moves in this position than
planting the Knight back but uh either
way you're a pawn up and you have full
control for good cash extra four minutes
to boot so uh looking good for white all
right and he has to win this game and if
he does he will make it through marmadov
with a draw or a win
will win this match but it's not looking
good for him right now and he is
definitely down on the clock as well
well I like that gokisha slowed down
finally because this is such a critical
moment he knows that he's done
everything right so far he just needs to
find that winning plan that good
technique and he's got the match in his
hands we were singing praises of Ralph's
play in the last game that he won to
equalize the match and I think this one
has been equally Flawless by gokish so
far
yeah and I wonder how many strong moves
does he have maybe we can our stockfish
again uh how big is the margin for error
right now to me it looks like he can
play a bunch of different moves and now
we see at least three strong moves uh
killer moves giving plus five advantage
that is decisive he does plan his life
back on that very strong Central Square
trapping the black king black at least
tries to tie down the white Bishop by
creating that pin again but stockfish
says move the king out the way again you
can give a check with the Knight that
doesn't change anything but you can move
the white king out of the second Rank
and
I think the threats will just build up
they'll be insurmountable soon and the
idea that you were talking about once
you're out of that bin the spawn
advances to E4 you open up the bishop
and do not forget the bishop on G5
Landing would be Checkmate it would be
game over now the reason we want to fall
back with the King and not forward is to
avoid the Knight jumping into B4 and any
such trades uh moves like Bishop B Forum
night before come to mind but we do have
a few moves now the players did repeat
yeah they just repeated once they're not
getting gaining any time because there's
no increment but uh that's often what
they say just show your opponent who's
in control of course gokesh won't repeat
for a third time he does instead put his
Rook on the seventh rank very nice as
well and uh this does hint at a
checkmating pattern if for example the
bishop moves then The Rook will join in
the fun and trap the black king itself
so very nice there from gokish but a
psychological battle just showing of
repeat twice I'm the boss I'm in control
I don't want to draw and uh play on
still in trouble for black and it forced
to Ralph to think a little bit and if
both sides are going to waste 30 seconds
go cash is the happier one and you see
that Ralph's clock is now ticking
towards three minutes 30 seconds he
hardly has a move as David was just
showing the Knight hopping into E5 for
white there might be a Checkmate in
short order against that black king
black has no threats White's up a pawn
has a very healthy Pawn structure no
targets to speak of this is a completely
lost position for mametov on the clock
on the board an excellently played game
by gukesh when he slid his Rooks over
the queen Side open the position up on
his terms and wow we might just see uh
this move 95 it's not very pleasant for
black there really are no good choices
yeah I accidentally predicted the future
there you can also maybe just Advance
white Central Pawn forward open up that
white Bishop it looks like some deadly
checks there as well it looks like
everything wins White's only one Pawn up
but the evaluation Bar says it's uh plus
infinity at this point it's just
completely winning for white
idea David on the board
G5 a big threat yeah uh E5 Checkmate a
big threat you're attacking the Black
Knight I think Ralph here might just
resign he's guaranteed to lose a minimum
a piece uh I think you just have to take
this Pawn allow the white Bishop to jump
in with a check maybe no checkmates
immediately but uh yeah the black Bishop
on d8 will drop off will we see him
fight on or will we see him admit defeat
and leave the tournament shaking his
head Ralph momodov losing all hope I
guess yeah he knows this one is just
over in gukash's favor but he's played
some marvelous chess to win on Demand
with the black pieces in the previous
game how he played against Wesley so
that was neck and neck Wesley did not
seem like the heavy favorite as his
rating would imply so Rafael merov this
is he's the type of player this
tournament is four it's a democratic
meritocratic process he showed that
throughout the Swiss and the plan he was
just as good as the best players in the
world he's demonstrated that yesterday
and today and he is going to lose this
game but it's been a great fight and
guys I love what cookies has done
instead of going to pick up that
material going to pick up that Bishop he
could have won it in one move with the
check okay is going for blood here he's
going for checkmate you were talking
about resignation I think it's going to
happen now Knight E5 it doesn't only
Rook F7 made but also Bishop G5 will be
super powerful as well once the G4 Pawn
comes in when you step up with the King
that will be game over as well so that's
two threats you can't fight two
checkmates in a position yeah you can't
fight two checkmates if you stop this
Rook Checkmate move
the bitcoin's idea uh you end up with a
pawn Checkmate really nice pretty
pattern here the black king trapped
between it's like a sandwich here
between the White Knight and the white
Bishop this one's going to be game over
I think Ralph he might just let his
clock run down but he's not going to
find Salvation anywhere it's game over
Checkmate is coming
what an amazing Armageddon here by
gokish we were talking about his lack of
experience he's been very vocal about
his Focus being on classical play the
reason why he also missed the world
rapid and Blitz he wanted to prepare for
the Tata steel Masters but here he is
just showing world-class performance
starting from the planes up until this
Armageddon an all-rounder will be coming
on
all the youngsters they're just uh
slowly but surely improving uh every
facet of their game every time control
in the past you used to see these young
players they were very much specialists
in either classical or Blitz chess but
now everyone's good at everything it's
unfair yeah and he's gonna face uh when
he wins this match because it's looking
very good for your cash he's gonna Face
Tomorrow the winner of uh sorry the
loser of the match between Magnus
Carlsen and Arjun erag icy they play the
winner is semi-finals starting 10
minutes after this game finishes so we
have a lot of Chess still to go today
you guys because in the winners bracket
it is best of four rapid games and that
as well can be decided in Armageddon if
players are tied so uh the the well day
is still young the day is young but the
day has ended for Ralph momentov he has
resigned there we go the tournament is
over for Mama
he is knocked out of the air things
Masters 16 year old gukesh makes it
through to the losers quarterfinals and
there was a little bit of a blunder I
guess in this game David what happened
yeah and uh I wouldn't necessarily say
blunder at Kaya but just a strategic
mistake which cost him long term and he
will be regretting just one move Ralph
moment off and uh it was actually a
successful opening for black black has
got the Queen's off black has a solid
structure symmetrical structure White's
Bishop pair are not that effective right
now but uh this move allowing the change
of structure was uh one that Ralph
mamidov will regret suddenly white was
able to break the black pawn chain and
this move really uh rubbing it in
pushing the pawn forward Saint to Black
this Pawn will never get connected to
the other black pawns and by stepping
forward once again he's opened up his
rook and just to show one or two more
moves this one was really really classy
from gokesh bringing the white Rook over
to B1 opening up the B file for this
rook and long term he won a pawn never
lost control and used his pieces on
really nice outposts to clinch the
victory
and there we have it makes it uh through
and being from India Tanya you must be
happy about that it's a big moment and
he never got his chance yesterday I
think Hikaru just asserted his
domination in that match but when you're
playing against a player like Hikaru you
can't take it too much too hard you know
you're playing against one of the
biggest the best online players uh well
just one of the best chess players
really in the world but I think ukesh
really showed today that he kept that
behind him he took an early lead in this
match went on to win an Armageddon which
is very hard to do when the momentum has
shifted so definitely all credits to him
and he's got 1.3 billion people rooting
for him right now yeah that is a nice
fan base for young cash and for the
first time seeing Armageddon with the
bidding process and everything what did
you think of it Robert I always enjoy it
because we see how the clock has used
the weapon from the start of the game
Ralph had to make some quick choices I
believe that if he had even time it was
just any other game he would not have
brought his Knight forward as David was
showing that was a critical strategic
mistake so you use the clock against
your opponent and did just that he did
it effectively he deserved to move on
yeah and it must be hard David to win on
demand you have to win with the white
pieces yeah it's such fine margins
sometimes you get out of the opening you
realize wait there are no winning
chances at all yes I might have four or
five minutes extra on the clock but
um yeah that you can't take that clock
you can't take that time forward with
you so it's all about the position all
about those little nuances in the gokish
there very impressively navigated found
some winning chances put the pressure on
and yeah as Robert says deservedly in
the semi-finals yep and we're joined
bike congratulations on winning the
match
hi thank you
can I ask you guys first of all what was
your thinking behind the bidding process
bidding 11 minutes and 45 seconds uh
against Muhammad of in the Armageddon
um actually I I wanted white but uh I
also wanted him to
get get below 12 minutes so I thought 12
minutes was a decent bid at first but it
turned out he also bit 12 minutes so I
had to go a bit less aha so I chose
level 45. okay so you were happy that
you ended up playing with the white
pieces then
yes fantastic and how happy are you with
the way you performed today and the
first game was fantastic
yes really happy with the first game it
was very clean game with the black
pieces and uh
uh yeah he he didn't really play that
well but uh anyway anyways I think it
was a good game from myself and second
game yeah I it's always hard to play
play this must win I mean must uh draw
games with wipe because sure trying to
play uh be careful but it should be
um
like uh more optimistic uh I I tried to
play some normal chess but at some point
I just
I just panicked in the time trouble and
yeah I think I had a Perpetual in the
end instead of Queen and six I could
have gone uh queen bed but okay
it was he he kept on uh
posing problems so he deserved
and um
I think again a very good game for me
absolutely
congratulations on that win you took the
early lead in the match but then Ralph
came back in game two and I want to ask
you what did you do between game two and
the Armageddon to switch it up
um
nothing actually
I
just I just checked the game check the
second game and I was a bit upset but
then I uh
yeah I didn't really do anything
but then you still decided to change up
the openings you didn't go for the ideas
that you had in the second game even
though you had a pleasant position so
the inspiration to play something
different how did that come to your mind
um
actually I
saw it in both games and
uh in the second game I wanted to do
some things already like
I was expecting your bookings in them
this is a very solid line but the yeah
and the Armageddon I thought
I had to play some normal stuff or not
not be too solids
I I was still expecting them to go Kings
Indian but yes lab was quite a
surprising
I I didn't really remember this bishop
g69 well so I just did something over
the board and
I got a playable position
all right and now your cash tomorrow
you're gonna play the loser of the match
between Magnus Carlsen and your fellow
Indian Arjun Eric icy will you now be
following that match to see you're gonna
face
uh probably yeah
both those players are very interesting
players so I'll anyways follow the match
yeah it'll also be uh uh
I will also be curious about whom I'll
be facing tomorrow yeah oh it's gonna be
a lot of fun big congratulations on your
match win today go cash
yes thank you thank you for joining us
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
it's time for another twitch break if
you're not a subscriber if you are a
subscriber well we're gonna look into
the winner semi-finals coming up shortly
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I think I have to take a look at the
bracket now because we have not finished
the first few matches on the losers
bracket two players are knocked out and
two players have not made it through to
the losers quarterfinals and uh what did
you think of the matches here oh they
were very very thrilling very exciting
and it did seem at one point very
one-sided I didn't expect alexio Serrano
just to overhaul faroogia and farouja
suffering his fifth loss in a row and he
looks absolutely devastated on camera
and then Mama Dove and look at Cash what
a roller coaster look at cash so calm so
collected and you he didn't seem phase
at all by the fact that he lost the
second game and he just went to business
and absolutely demolished her mamadov in
the play the Armageddon yeah and now
these four players can lean back and
enjoy the winners bracket winner
semi-finals is coming up which of those
two matches is Magnus Carlson against
Eric icy or Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura are you most excited to follow
I miss fans I'm very very sorry but it
has to be the match off between the two
juggernauts that are Wesley Wesley so
and Hikaru Nakamura I really intrigued
actually how things are going to develop
because Wesley has been playing titled
Tuesday and as of now he has like nine
and a half out of ten he has an insane
score so yeah I mean whether this is
gonna work out well for him I don't know
but it's risky business because
traditionally you should be like
preparing yeah okay well is he finished
is he ready to start the other things
monsters now just finished his last
round was a joke
wow all right well so that's how Wesley
sauce been warming up to face a car
today I I know we haven't seen anything
from Hikaru but uh we'll find out
whether that was a good strategy or not
and when it comes to the other match up
between Magnus Carlson and Eric icy is
traditionally been very one-sided in the
world champions favor guys yes he scored
one point of him but
the other the other matches really
hasn't gone his way so he will be
looking upon this as a learning
experience perhaps uh just use all the
knowledge that he's gained previously
yeah two cool matches is uh coming up
you guys we're gonna follow the first
game between Wesley saw and hikaron
Nakamura and Wesley Seoul he has some
big goals coming up in 2023
your top three goals that you hope to
achieve in 2023 if the first one would
be to qualify to the candidates
I've only played the candidates once and
it didn't go very well in 2018.
so I'm very excited to see what 2023
holds uh there will be some over the
board tournaments here and there but
almost half of the tournaments are held
online and they're very important they
got a lot of stakes I'm very pleased to
win last year's the global chess
tournament I'm excited to be part of the
new Champion Chester and chess.com it
interesting to see what this new
partnership will will hold for them win
some big online tournaments that would
be very nice for me as a player I'm
trying to balance myself between being
very good at classical while also doing
that bad online and speeches because
they're very different things and so
this year is going to be exciting as
well as a challenge and my calendar is
actually getting very full at the moment
I also need time to spend between
resting or covering and also preparing
and number three would be
too ambitious but now it's a
reach the top three
goals were is when we saw one of them
winning at least one online event and
this is day two of the other things
Masters he is playing the winner is
semi-finals against his fellow American
Hikaru Nakamura these are their stats in
Rapid chess oh yeah they played a lot of
games forward yeah I think I mean I'm
surprising it's that made that money
could all different formats including
Blitz but recently Wesley so has had the
upper hand he took down Hikaru Nakamura
on route to winning the global
Championship which earned him his spot
in division one here he beat him in Taza
still India when in the rapid game so
Wesley has done well against Hikaru in
Rapid chess wow one of you players and
he's gonna start out with the white
pieces Wesley so been warming up playing
a lot of online chess today do you think
that's a good idea David uh I'm not sure
I could do it I don't have the same
energy levels as some of these top
players anymore but uh Wesley yeah he
had a bullet Marathon just before he
played title Tuesday I think he must
have been playing online now for three
four hours he's got no excuse is he's
going to be feeling warmed up at least
so as long as he's feeling confident
which he must do after winning title
Tuesday then it can't hurt that much
and Tanya what do you expect from this
matchup Wesley saw in the car with
Nakamura are just two Giants and chess a
lot of fun yeah that's what I expect now
when these two Play In classical matches
we've often seen those games fizzle out
into draws but when they're at it in
speed chess they go for it we see so
many decisive games I'm expecting Hikaru
to have the very Hikaru strategy of
trying to bring Wesley down on the clock
flag him really make him make those
mistakes when he's low on the clock
because Wesley is such a difficult
opponent to beat otherwise with his 15
minute and a three second increment time
format speed and intuition are the two
very important factors and that's what
it looks like Wesley's been working on
with all the bullet and the title
Tuesday uh the practice that he's been
getting in before this big one yeah
and look at Hikaru whoa what is that
about uh I guess uh the game should have
started maybe some technical issues uh
he's impatient to get going maybe he's
hoping to strike Hikaru while Wesley is
still recovering from title Tuesday I
mean while we're off it's the Kingsport
opening we often see the Italian or the
Spanish when these two play the Italian
is a good sign it means there's not
going to be any quick draws it's not
going to fizzle out anytime soon which
has occasionally happened between these
two uh in Rapid chess but uh the Italian
guarantees all the pieces on the board
for a long long time
uh maybe a theoretical battle to start
this one off David I'm just glad we're
not going to see the position that
you've set up for us on the chessboard
on our screens and that's already happy
moments for the fans yeah I wonder if
any of the fans have caught that on the
chessboard in front of us later on you
can try and figure out which position we
put on the board for you guys but uh
meanwhile this one we've seen it a
hundred times before uh Hikaru is maybe
the biggest specialist on the black side
of the Italian game he sets up with a
bunch of uh difference in a bunch of
different ways and often he loves to
drop back his Bishop his dashboard
Bishop to A7 and as we mentioned
yesterday white has a variety of plans
to choose from you can start bringing
one of the white knights around to the
uh to the king side you can start
gaining space on the queen side
eventually it's about who can push
forward in the center first but just a
very tense position Robert yeah and it
was a big decision by Hikaru to put a
ship on one square rather than two on
the a file because instead of fighting
for space he says I am just going to be
safe and sound Retreat my Bishop on the
dark squares and it allows White to push
forward on the queen side you can go B2
to B4 just continue to push those pawns
forward at the right moment and the
Knight that just jumped in front of the
Dark Sword Bishop it is going to go next
to the King on F1 in some moment and
then jump forward either to G3 or E3 in
a standard fare in the Italian yup still
very well known uh well-known stuff
while traveling Parts here first black
because you're slightly cramped white
has more space especially on the queen
side therefore uh Hikaru goes for traits
and a set of Bishops off the board
I at some point here Hikaru okay he's
looking off to the side he's uh looking
confused but that's because he's trying
to recall he's uh trying to remember
what his opening notes say for sure he's
seen this type of position before and uh
smiling that Hikaru maybe this last Rook
move I think maybe not the most popular
option has thrown him off slightly so
he'll take us a few seconds to recompose
himself and then make a decision but
Black's position is very healthy uh
despite the lack of space The Rook from
B1 really is making the intentions clear
at some point you want to try to advance
this B Pawn to B5 and open up the B line
now also notice that how after the trade
of the light Square Bishops there have
been some weaknesses that are created
and White's Knight can find itself
Landing up on the F5 square one of the
plans that white has is to jump back
with the Knight to F1 go to G3 go to F5
and try and Target the king side and
look at the decisions that the players
have taken I was talking about White's
intention of going B5 Hikaru says None
of that's happening not allowing it goes
B5 himself blocks the pawn structure on
the queen side and a very interesting
decision here Robert by Wesley the
rook's done its job on B on the B-Line
he slides back on the A-line just
anticipating and opening up of the a
file yeah it's a little Shuffle and now
we see that hikaru's Rook has left the a
file and scoot over to the B file so
there's a game of cat and mouse going on
and the point is that you leave the
tension but at some moment there will be
a pawn capture on B5 now that's
available black never wants to take that
pawn on A4 because as soon as you do
that then you're left with this A6
weakness it's going to be lost in many
of these positions white could just pile
up the pressure that would not be a good
choice and that's why black decides just
to move the Rook out the way
preemptively now if the capture on B5
happens the pawnkey abstract the Knight
protects the bishop over there on A7 and
there's just no issues to deal with on
that side of the board so this is a
tense Affair thus far not a single Pawn
has been traded we'll see when that
first happens
yeah it's extremely tense this little
dance between the Rooks it's very
sophisticated stuff it's beyond most of
us we've got to say but uh it shows that
actually both sides just want to stay
flexible they want to only later decide
where they want to put their minor
pieces and only later decide when to go
for those Pawn breaks which will signify
the beginning of the real fireworks and
uh yeah it's I think both players will
be very happy with the type of opening
that they've received it's just very
tense and at least to start this this
semi-final it's uh promising science um
one of the plans that white has in these
positions we've been discussing about it
where to put that Knight on D2 we see
that it's coming in the way of its own
bishop and Wesley shows the path he goes
for the idea that we were discussing
falls back a little bit but only to go
forward in the next move the Knight
comes back to F1 it is heading towards
that F5 Square he also opens up his own
Bishop so continuing to develop but also
keeping the tension on the board not
trading any bonds the Lost sorry I was
gonna say the last time I looked at this
type of position was an Anish giri's 184
chessboard course oh really uh it always
seemed to say it always seemed to fizzle
out to a small wise Advantage but not
enough to win uh let's see if that's uh
if this game proceeds along those paths
well speaking of chessable courses that
is one way to study chess we know books
is another way Robert revealing to us
that he's not a huge fan of Chess books
earlier today and we actually have a
question on Twitch from powered by
glucosis and I'll ask you this Robert so
as a 1500 player is it more important to
play to improve or to read and look into
strategies
both all the above yeah I think that
sometimes we do puzzles for example and
we need to work on a pattern recognition
that sort of muscle memory and that's
useful for a growing player the issue is
when you do puzzles you're getting a tap
on the shoulder that there is a solution
there whereas we've just seen in the
games from the air things Masters that
there may be one solution but you don't
know that it exists you have to find it
on your own so I think that you have to
read but you also have to play to you
can't just get that experience anywhere
in the middle of a game a training
session and you're finding those best
moves with the clock pressuring you as
well I think you have to do all the
above so yeah so as a 1500 player do
everything yes if you oh if you have
limited time though if you're working or
going to school you only maybe have half
an hour or an hour every day to work on
chess what should you prioritize David
My Philosophy has always been 50 playing
and 50 other stuff so that other stuff
could include analyzing the game that
you have played could include reading
books following broadcasts commentary
watching videos but I think playing is
at least 50 that has to be it um just to
kind of get that muscle memory to get in
the flow to get in the mindset because
it is a sport after all it's a
competitive uh field chess and you have
to kind of put yourself under pressure
in order to improve yeah I think the
most important thing and not to forget
is to actually just enjoy chess a lot so
if you've got limited amount of time do
what makes you enjoy the game if it's
solving puzzles do that if it's playing
bullet do that the more you'll do it the
more you'll enjoy it the more you'll
improve just make sure it's not 100 time
spent on bullet
that can be tricky I remember this is um
I'll call it a blunder by Magnus Carlsen
uh he posted some videos with tips for
beginners and he also uh posted later uh
sort of the what do you call it not
blunders but the the lupus bloopers is
the word I'm looking for where he said
sit by the board and play with yourself
what's to live by yes
but keep sharing your questions and
comments on Twitch as well we'll bring
up as many as we can to our experts in
the studio here you do have some moves
on the board what do you think so far in
this game yeah so far it's just
maneuvering moves uh neither side is
really kind of setting out their battle
strategy saying I'm coming for you on
this side of the board whitesnites have
just uh hinted at some jumps later on
they've parked themselves nicely in
front of the white king defending the
white king but also ready to spring
forward if given the opportunity but
this last queen move does show a bit of
hesitation from Wesley he's just saying
to Hikaru you can't really break out
either so I'm gonna wait and wait and
slight space Advantage for white on the
queen side one very classical plan in
these positions for black is to open up
the center you want to try and get a
successful D5 break in but it also needs
to be timed really well we see this last
move by Hikaru bringing the queen up now
he can also double up the rook and the
Queen on the D file which is
anticipating that D5 break because a
threat is stronger than execution so
he's really just preparing it at some
point I'm expecting Hikaru to come in
with the central break yeah
and there will be various ways for
example if he does land it now of course
you can prepare as Tanya Advocates there
but if you do land it then white has a
few possible answers firstly you could
just maintain the tension it's not clear
whether black is really threatening to
take your Pawn or to push forward if you
are scared of that however you could
capture it for white and here the
question would be whether Black's
Central Pawn is weak or not here it's a
Target but it's sufficiently defended so
I would say that this actually favors
black this small transition it's uh yeah
it's definitely revolving around whether
Hikaru can land this type of idea
pushing the pawn forward in the center
at a favorable moment if he can he
solved all his issues if he can't then
it's really hard from a human point of
view to find a plan to find anything
productive to do and I think it's
important for Wesley so not to push his
Pawn from A4 to A5 that would be so
tempting for many of us let's attack
this bishop on B6 when given the
opportunity but that closes down the
queen side permanently you want to keep
the tension because at some point your
Rook on A1 may be active invaded on its
starting Square so you want to take on
B5 when the moment is right you just do
not want to eliminate that as an option
so much more likely from Wesley's
perspective is to hop that Knight on G3
up towards the enemy King with Knight to
F5 and watch out for sacrifices on the
H6 Square it'll give up a minor piece
for two pawns but the black king will
lack shelter that could be very
dangerous but I think that's when your
time King that you've got a rook on E6
because those plans are super risky for
black you can't end up getting
checkmated but that Rook on E6 will be
eyeing key defensive squares if that
sacrifice was to appear on the board so
that's a happy Rook there yep uh Happy
Rook happy life that's the as the saying
goes but well that's the thing doesn't
go but uh wow Robert guess what move has
just landed on the board Pawn takes porn
the only one we were saying would never
happen and I'm shocked I've got to say
Hikaru worsening his Pawn structure
maybe feeling the tension he's just
trying to say okay yes I'm gonna be in
uh kind of left with this isolated porn
but I'm going to try and swap it off I'm
going to try and eliminate it next move
and if I can trade these pawns then I'm
very happy Suddenly It's symmetrical
Pawn structure equal position but the
question is whether Wesley he's got one
move maybe two moose uh does he have to
take this Pawn immediately first
question and second one can he strand
black with a weakness long term
uh commit or decision I don't like it I
don't think black needed to go for this
I think there were plenty of other
things to do we mentioned going for the
central break but uh yeah he's playing
on the side where he's technically
weaker what do we think of this but if
he manages to swap all the queen side
bonds I think that would be a happy
decision and a happy outcome for Hikaru
starting this match now this is a four
game match it's a long day ahead for
these players you want to with the black
Pieces Just make sure you neutralize all
of White's Edge it's definitely a
committed decision but it looks like
it's got a very concrete idea ahead I
like this point that you make David of
going A5 and just swapping off all the
pawns off the board yeah and if you can
achieve it then he's solved his issues
this is what the top players often often
do they just work out they can calculate
they make exceptions from the general
rules we were saying never take that
pawn you make your own weaknesses you
isolate your pawns but they spot those
exceptions those uh rare instances that
they can go for these ideas and this is
the justification let's wait for Wesley
to figure out whether he can punish
Hikaru for at least temporarily breaking
his structure why is he taking this long
to capture the pawn is there an
alternative that we're missing out on
well the part's not going anywhere so
perhaps he'll leave the pawn on a form
hop forward with Knight to F5 so I think
Wesley he understands that this is a
critical moment that black is trying
just to liquidate completely on the
queen side and there's also the question
of if he does take on A4 which Pawn does
he capture oh which piece excuse me just
capture he could take with the queen he
could take with the Rook so there are
several options here for Wesley so and
he doesn't want to rush this and allow
hikar to immediately equalize
question for you guys uh should we uh
jump over to Magnus Carlsen against
Arjun aragi to take a look at the first
game in those in that match up it looks
slightly more exciting still very tense
in that one as well uh only one set of
Trades uh in that one one set of pieces
off the board but yeah maybe we do it
yeah is about to solve his issues by
trading off uh his a pawn here so
um there we go A5 and if those pawns
disappear equality let's check out
what's happening in Magnus Carlson
against argenteric icy yeah big matchup
there as well Magnus Carlsen energy and
everybody they played each other a bunch
last season on the meltwater Champions
chess tour
and here they are in another match up
the bar in the middle
what are we seeing from the get-go in
this matchup yeah so it's it's very
tense but Arjun has made a very
ambitious but committal decision over
the last couple of moves he's Advanced
the F Pawn down the board so he's
initiating a potential Pawn storm
against the white king if he gets Thai
margin here I don't think he'd hesitate
too much he would throw the black G Pawn
down try to dislodge the White Knight
and uh just all the pawns would head
towards that white king I don't like
what Magnus has done with this queen
I've got to say I'm not sure how it
ended up there and uh White pieces are a
bit locked up for uh for now
um still white is solid of course
shouldn't be too much wrong objectively
but uh yeah he's down on the clock too
practice calcium very ambitious play by
Black by Archer and here in this
position on the king side as we see but
I think this is exactly what he needs to
do in this match to come on top he
cannot fear Magnus Carlson this match is
so much about psychology for Arjun as
well he needs to believe that he can win
it he needs to make the most of the
smallest opportunity and chances he gets
and I think his best shot is to try to
create a mess on the board try and get
messy positions against Magnus because
if you try to play strategically he's
just going to outplay you Archer yes
committed stuff on the king side but I
like it it creates pressure and Madness
there going with his Bishop to B5
because watch out that pawn on E5 is
weak he wants to trade the Knight on C6
and then start attacking that Central
Pawn on E5 Yep this is the target as you
point out there Tanya and the one
downside behind advancing pawns is they
can't move backwards they do create
weaknesses and this Pawn can never be
defended by a fellow pawn it will tie
down at least one black piece and as you
mentioned there's a bit of a threat if
black does for example ask the question
of the bishop Magnus won't hesitate you
capture if the queen recaptures this
Pawn drops and of course you don't want
to saddle yourself with weak pawns on
this flank also the white Bishop on B2
suddenly comes back to life re-energized
and on this diagonal it looks perfectly
placed I don't think Arjun wants to
allow or entertain this possibility so
what can he do instead he's likely to
play the move C5 to C4 himself just
shutting down their Bishop on B2 it's
often worth giving up material to shut
down your opponent's pieces the E5 Pawn
feels a lot safer with the bishop out of
the equation and that actually leaves
Magnus with a tough choice do you really
want to take this Pawn on C4 have double
isolated pawns yourself I don't think
you do and we actually did just see
origen make a move he doesn't push the
pawn he plays Bishop of F6 which does
immediately defend this Pawn E5 but
already I'm thinking about exchange
sacrifices we've seen so many a world
champion Champions over the years
including Magnus Carlsen eventually try
to plant a rook on D5 I don't think it's
good right here and now but at some
moment look for that kind of exchange
sacrifice you know getting a strong
passport in return opening up a nice
Outpost for the White Queen uh the
problem here maybe is that black would
ignore the Rook at least for a move or
two longer and uh yeah a very thematic
idea there instead Magnus captures this
Black Knight and Arjun is hesitating I'm
very surprised here I've got to say if
you take with the pawn long term these
are extremely weak and easy targets for
the white dot Square Bishop for the
White Knight but uh if you take with the
queen I guess the reason he's hesitating
is because the pawn will step forward uh
reinstating this threat against the
e-pawn and if you defend it you lose
time with the black queen you've lost
two Tempe and watch out for Robert's
exchange sacrifice you could land at any
moment Rook to D5 yes it comes with the
custom material but you get so much in
return and uh Arjun he's weighing up
that up he has captured will he drop his
Queen back and will Magnus go for this
idea
the questions there and we see him
taking a little bit of of time here I do
not see another way to defend the E5
Pawn it's also interesting that white
has the possibility to build up more
pressure against the center Pawn he
drops back with the queen and one idea
Rook D5 again super combative with an
exchange sacrifice but this is the other
plan that Magnus has gone for he wants
to really double up the pressure on the
E5 he's looking at setting up that Queen
and Bishop battery along the diagonal
Arjun swipes up The Rook all the way to
E8 so that he can fall back with the
bishop to see it a retreating move by
the bishop just making sure the pawn on
E5 remains defended yep it's just Battle
of plans right now and the more we look
at the position the more it feels like
this is a real hole in the in the black
Camp if the white knight could ever land
there that would just be glorious I'm
not sure the path unfortunately it does
take a few moves but if you imagine the
White Knight on this beautiful juicy
Square then uh yeah you can present this
black you don't even want to tolerate
that but uh it takes too long and a big
decision there by uh origin because he
could have brought his Bishop forward
and said he retreated backwards he's
covering that D5 Square If instead of
retreating to F7 he brought his Bishop
forward to G4 I just want to show
quickly how domination happens you can
wear Rook D2 and say oh my kingside Pawn
structure it's in Shameless if Bishop
takes Knight Pawn takes wage is gonna
double Rooks bring a rook to D5 black
dark Square Bishop is very passive and
White's King can actually sneak towards
the center of King F1 King E2 very safe
there while Black's Pawn structure is
actually the worst one you don't want
pawns on the same color as your own
Bishop yeah this bishop is just terrible
for the rest of the game just uh
resigned to being a Defender he's going
for an idea real but he anyways goes
Rook D3 to try and double up the rook
and bring that Rook to the seventh Rank
and it looks like he's building a lot of
pressure here yeah it looks like Magnus
is turning this slightly in his favor at
least momentum wise but will aragaisy
fight back for example we mentioned a
possible Pawn storm at some point I
don't think you can go for it right now
to listening to weakening but first he
takes the time out to defend uh the
seventh rank Magnus can he up the
pressure it looks like all of these
pieces are pretty much on their perfect
squares right now and uh can he improve
that's the question or can I regards he
just knuckle down solidify and hope to
counter later this is your worst
nightmare against Magnus where you've
given him all the play and Magnus we've
seen him just convert these positions
flawlessly he just keeps building the
pressure move by move until the opponent
cracks it looks like the kind of
position that black has just got to keep
things together it's hard to come up
with an act active plan and there we see
the Rooks have been doubled up currently
the D7 square is defended but it's going
to be an uphill task to keep the defense
going and on the clock as well Magnus
ahead by almost two minutes guys earlier
I said the bishop pair were my favorite
thing in the world can I retract that
statement look at that Bishop but that's
not a bishop to be fair to you that's a
big Pawn sitting on F6 so it's not
really a bishop pair for black you can
keep your statement thank you very much
like that
well how about you guys Tanya and Robert
what do you prefer I know there is
always like a big discussion do you
prefer the bishop pair the knights the
bishop and the Knight what do you prefer
you take it first I'm a bishop person
and I have to say I love the Bishops but
of course it depends on the position
when you've got a bishop there you're
really looking for an open position so
that your Bishops can be on these
diagonals these are long range pieces
they need space to breathe and to really
Thrive and flourish but in this position
as we can see the Bishops are behind
their own pawns and there really isn't
that much to play for also Knights are
super tricky so be careful of them and I
would say In classical games I love
myself a bishop pair but if it was
bullet Blitz give me a night I need aha
okay how about you Robert I think I grew
up preferring my Knights over Bishops
maybe because I like viciana as a player
he tends to give away his Bishops for
enemy Knights but as I've matured I'm
gonna put that in quotes because really
you actually did yeah I'm just a big kid
over here I do prefer the bishop pair if
I can just get a neutral position with
the pair of Bishops I already feel like
I have an advantage and so yeah I would
go with the Bishops okay I saw Robert
enjoying that effort by Serana earlier
with the Bishops just maneuvering them
just every move Robert would take a step
of approval so I could tell his answer
was coming yeah and with AI we're sort
of getting you know even clearer answers
to the big questions in chess what will
AI say what what does AI prefer
Alpha zero in that famous match against
stockfish a Fishback now it would often
give up several pawns for the bishop
pair but it's only a very specific
circumstances when you can guarantee
that the Bishops have range that they
can be like archers just looking afar
across the board and Target everything
in lock positions then it's less clear
so what you're saying is the holiday I
would not like the bishop here we see on
the screen in front of us
the Big Pawn there not helping white
pieces are just in perfect places the
Rooks are doubled uh they're defended
the pawn structure is preferable for
white and look at this the Knight F3 was
putting pressure on E5 but Magnus pushed
his H Pawn not to create left for his
King but to bring his Knight back just
to head forward to G4 and he induced the
weakness with origin playing H1 simply
to stop that night moving this is Magnus
at his best maneuvering chess and he is
the one with the upper hand here and
when Magnus beat Arjun in the final of
the was it Julius bear generation cup uh
last season he did mention in the
interview that he was playing Auntie
young player chess especially against
Argent he was playing openings where it
wasn't necessarily anything forcing he
wasn't going directly for the kill but
he just gives Arjun a bunch of very
difficult strategic decisions and
actually it's very difficult to answer
them especially against someone like
Magnus who will punish you if you make
the smallest inaccuracy and it feels
like Arjun somewhere maybe around the
moment we joined it maybe missing
Robert's uh Pawn to C4 push there
locking in the white Bishop he's let it
slip and uh ever since it's been going
steadily downhill it's white fully in
control black is stuck Frozen I don't
see any productive moves and uh White
has clear plans of improving his pieces
uh every step these lasting moves have
been so impressive by Magnus absolute
plaster he fell back with his Knight
provoked a big weakness in Black's camp
with that moves then just simply comes
back the Knight has done his job returns
to this post where it attacks E5 what is
black done now Arjun is left with
another weakness on H5 the ball is in
his court every move is difficult to
answer he's burning the clock he's down
to wait what is that three minutes on
the clock and a really passive position
for black yeah really passive and white
can switch Focus white can play on the
king's side potentially you could
certainly imagine the white king moving
out the way the white Rooks shifting
across and then opening up some lines on
this side towards the black king you
could imagine white switching towards
the queen side hitting this Pawn in the
center and then flicking a pawn push up
here to open the position at the right
moment just to try and gain some space
Magnus is super flexible and okay Arjun
moves his Rook Magnus says okay I'm
clamping down I'm closing the position
even further now there's a nice juicy
Square later for the White Knight I
don't think you want to rush in but uh
definitely no Pawn pushes for black on
that flank Knights thrive in these close
positions I think he closed it to open
it on his own terms Magnus might bring
his King up to H2 Rook over to G1 and
push his G pawn and I think origen
understands that he cannot sit and do
nothing because when that side of the
board opens up it's all fun for white
miserable for black so he plays B5
trying desperately to claw open the
queen side unfortunately all of White's
pieces in good place there so he does go
forward with your knight G5 idea David
he gets that Dark Sword Bishop off the
board E5 becoming even bigger Target C5
now cemented on a dark Square you don't
have a dark Square Bishop to defend it
uh I would not like this position at all
for black I just don't see any plans
then again white has traded his
beautiful Knight for that big Pawn that
big kind of stuck piece on F6 uh that
dot Square Bishop so at least he has the
Solace of opposite color Bishops here if
it does go down to an end game which is
miles away unfortunately but if it does
get to an end game then he might hope to
hold this one Eric I see it's just the
clock it's just the position right now
two minutes now suffering on both yeah
very difficult stuff and we often talk
about opposite color Bishops and how
that might end in a draw but not this
one because it's all about which Bishop
has targets and while the E4 Pawn for
white can be defended it comes back to
that decision that Arjun made with that
F Bond the E5 Central Pawn is a weakness
forever he falls back on F7 I don't
believe that Magnus ever wants to
retreat with the Rook of course he could
but he doesn't really care about an
attack on that Rook because imagine and
visualize if that work was even picked
up by the bishop just how strong white
spawn there would be
put that on the board
for example if white weights let's say I
make a pawn move the Rook drops back yes
white can move the Rook maybe just some
active squares but even if we leave it
uh let's say for example let's make a
queen move then yep super strong pawns
now in the center white still has ideas
of attacking on this side and uh great
positional compensation instead Magnus
he doesn't play the slow approach of
course he goes in with his Queen he's
going to zigzag her into the black camp
and just increase the pressure
slowly but steadily it's just getting
worse and worse for black better and
better for white but can Arjun solve his
issues maybe with some tactics at some
point as he ticks down to one and a half
minutes on the clock
you don't want to be in this situation
against Magnus on the board but uh yeah
when Magnus is on the clock he also
hustles because he calculates so quickly
you need time to find tactics and origen
does not have time he is down under a
minute and about to be 20 seconds he
just doesn't have a move he can trade
pawns on C4 but chess is not a game
about one little trade it's about coming
up with a plan Arjun has no plan he is
just trying to fend off all of magnus's
threats his Rook on E6 blocks his own
Bishop but if he ever moves that Rook
away that gives white more control along
some squares in the Deep files so this
is so unpleasant to have he does swap
off a pair of Pawns we just saw that uh
but now what maybe he's best served as
moving his King side to side and saying
that perhaps Magnus has no way to make
progress yeah argue that black has a
fortress okay first he solidifies
another Pawn but look at that white dot
squared Bishop now if Black's Central
Pawn ever disappears that white dark
Square Bishop rakes across the board and
uh yeah this WOW Magnus just whitening
his eyes
I think shocked by this last decision by
air I see it did feel to me like Magnus
was trying to provoke this move I think
Magnus would have happily invested two
or three moves to provoke black to push
his Pawn to G6 but uh Magnus now just
needs to find a killer blow and black is
just Holding On by a thread in this
position with those Rooks one of the
ideas that one can actually have is to
trade one pair he could also put the
queen and triple up on the D file and
then go in with the Rook go to D go to
d8 trade off make you know more use of
these dark Squad weaknesses that we're
talking about imagine if one pair of
Rook Rooks gets traded off the E5 Pawn
will be such a glaring weakness in this
position yeah I like that uh that idea
as well uh Tanya of creating the
alakyne's gun just moving The Rook for
example sliding the queen behind and
then just breaking in through the open
file uh towards the black king it takes
a while I'm not sure whether you have
that luxury but uh that will be on
magnus's radar or as you said just swap
off one set of Rooks looks very simple
you could also land on the seventh rank
I'm not sure where you're going from
there but very many tempting uh moves
and it's theory of two weaknesses black
has this huge huge problem on E5 of
course but if you can just create one
more weakness one more Target for the
white pieces that will overwhelm the
black defenses and I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus pushes his Pawn to
G3 and then eventually the second Pawn
to F4 and opens up that Bishop on the
long diagonal because if that pawn E5 is
gone the full length of diagonals open
for that Bishop the queen would like to
join the party and deliver a Checkmate
this is looking very scary for our
generic guys if you could ever line up
the White Queen on the same diagonal as
a bishop
I like that new feature David I'm
learning I'm learning Tech stuff very
cool yeah it might take a while but
types of ideas
all right in less than a minute for
Arjun erag icy what do you think right
now Robert will the Indian lose this
first game in this match yeah he's
playing Magnus Carlson he's down a ton
on the clock he has no real ideas in the
position so I feel like Magnus he's
spending his time here he knows that he
doesn't want to give Arjun a series of
easy moves because with Black's last
move it seems like he wants to move his
Rook out of the way open up his Bishop
things of that nature so I think Magnus
just trying to be precise right now
because the next few moves will be
easier for him to play and more
difficult for Arjun uh-huh
Magnus Carlsen is under three minutes on
the clock this is the first game in the
Winner's semi-final match between these
two the winner of this match goes
through to the winners
final and the loser of this match is
knocked down to the losers bracket to
play the losers quarter finals tomorrow
you do have two lives in the double
elimination format wow and a slight
surprise to me at least because we were
just highlighting some potential
checkmating ideas on the dark squares
but Magnus is offered a queen trade
first he dropped back his Bishop to A1
white Bishop in the corner nobody puts
it in the corner it still looks pretty
good there but uh yeah the queen trade
heads towards the end game but the
problem for Arjun is the Rooks are still
on with the Rooks off you could maybe
hold a draw if you're lucky but with the
Rooks on whites Rooks clearly Superior
to those passive uh to their passive
black counterparts what do we think of
this decision
surprised but I think positionally it
seems to work really well he knows he's
got a long-term Advantage with all these
Bond weaknesses now what black can count
on is that B3 weakness that white has a
lot of weaknesses for black but White's
got one and that's the pawn on V3 he
offers one Trader Rooks the more the
Rooks get off the board the easier the
defensive task gets for Arjun but yes
Magnus will trade off one but not the
other
Brooke sorry and we launch up the board
with that work white Rook going after
the isolates uh the black A6 Pawn is the
first Target five seconds as well oh
sorry uh
13 seconds for Argent but uh not much
time at all no and he finally takes the
pawn E5 we've been pointing at it for in
the last bunch of moves he takes it and
the F4 Pawn is next the A6 Pawn is
hanging The Rook just patrolling the
sixth rank here Arjun trying to find any
idea just to stay alive here but with so
little time and I think white can just
start scooping out the material yeah one
Pawn down and it's uh about to increase
magnus's lead first he gives a check oh
discover checks all over the shop here
if Magnus wants first he can just step
his Bishop out the way just uh avoid any
Rook taste Bishop ideas and the threats
continue There we go White's Rook is
going to jump out the way I think we
won't see Arjun fight this one on much
longer you're facing the best end game
player of all time and you're pulling
down with a bunch of weaknesses
yeah it's uh it's that it's just been a
master class for Magnus in terms of
strategy uh strategic play this was
super tough from start to finish for
Archer it was all about giving Magnus
the kind of position where Magnus is the
only one playing and putting that
pressure move after move it's just a
nightmare against him and we see now he
is a couple of Pawns up it's not even
about the the concept of two weaknesses
everything is a weakness in Blacks Camp
right now Arjun with F3 attacks the
Magnus would have to attacks the bishop
but also defends the E4 Pawn the bishop
will fall back the G6 Pawn will hang and
now he goes for Rook beard that's an
interesting move but what is the point
you can just pick up the bishop and G4
yeah it's desperation he's hinting at a
counter-attack uh if the black Rook can
get active maybe start checking the
white king especially after a trade on
G4 black will have a couple of Pawns
next to each other but it's just uh yeah
it's just a bluff unfortunately I think
with a few seconds left on the clock
Arjun is just playing for tricks and
they don't quite work
has magnets calculated at all I think he
can just figure it out at this point oh
okay yes he has he gives his Bishop back
just to create a pass Pawn over here the
G6 Pawn is still hanging he'll have two
Advanced pass pawns that cannot be
stopped and the material count is still
in magnus's favor after all of that so
uh Arjun he's just playing on just to
get these final moves in but that H Pawn
cannot be stopped anymore yep that's uh
white porn will cost black as Rook if
you want to stop it uh actually you
might not even get given the opportunity
a rook trade and white will make a new
Queen Arjun is about to resign losing on
time as well and he logs off immediately
oh wow it's a win four Magnus crawls in
the in the first game in the winner is
semi-finals he's playing a match against
Arjun Eric icy this was only the first
game Arjun did play with the black
pieces and he still has three games uh
to win the match he can still turn it
around this one is still going on this
is game one between Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so the two huge Americans and
what's happening the bar is roughly to
the middle in this game it's roughly to
the middle but uh Wesley so has got a
bit of a problem that black a Pawn on
that very strong past black apron is
still alive and how does he pick it up
the white king isn't entirely safe if
you look at the black Rook The Black
Queen they're both aligned towards that
white Pawn on F2 which has just moved
forward one square and if Wesley can
safely pick up that pawn he's uh upper
clear Pawn he's in a very promising end
game but I was gonna say maybe it wasn't
possible but he's achieved it what do we
think serious winning chances here for
white definitely and look at the clock
situation both players hovering around
20 seconds they do have three second
increment and both them are super Speedy
whilst they sell one title Tuesday
earlier today and Magus Carlson he won
his game but a car Nakamura beat Magus
Carlson for the speeches chapter title
now Queen E3 threatens the white king I
think you have to push your pieces
backwards and look at this a rook
sacrifice trying to secure a draw and uh
you saw Hikaru lean back with pride I
think at that last Rook sacrifice it's
almost guaranteed to be a draw at this
point there's no way for the white king
to hide black can give checks forever
and the player's Leaf it is a draw wow
the first battle between them ends in a
draw the second one will start in five
minutes any car Nakamura will have the
white pieces in that game I think we
should take a look at the the game
between Magnus Carlsen and Arjun
aragaisy a big win for minus there David
a very big win and uh just to show how
he Consolidated his advantage in that
one Magnus we mentioned he had full
control we mentioned strategically he
was dominant but uh just this very nice
com Queen exchange and this confirmed
his Advantage removed all threats of
counter Play Once the Queens disappeared
we saw a bunch of weaknesses this Pawn
indefensible this black pawn also in a
dark square a clear Target long term and
uh this central point of course going to
drop off we saw one Rook trade but that
wasn't enough the remaining Rook came in
and this just shows trading pieces
doesn't necessarily uh worsen your
winning chances here it's just an easier
way to pick up the weaknesses in Black's
Camp Arjun tried to cause some trouble
but unsuccessful
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru gokam chess and the botan sisters
come on
look at that chess.com is excited to
announce the community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
and if you're not yet a subscriber on
chess.com on Twitch then we're going to
send you to a twitch right now right now
if not we're gonna dig into the results
so far in the winter semi-finals
[Music]
he's on fire even like yeah I mean
whatever he's doing in Canada is
certainly agrees with him and he made it
look very effortlessly and I have to say
the pressure is now on Origin already to
actually recover from that to find a way
to unbalance the world champion and uh I
would recommend go outside Shake It Off
do something radical because so far it's
not really working and and according to
his track record he does need to make
some drastic changes yeah and minus
Carlsen he won two games yesterday he
basically could have won three games
yesterday starting off with another win
here what's up with him
well he's having a good time yes hi
Tanya alluded to you know he's enjoying
himself and he's always said he plays
fantastic chess when he's feeling good
he's in a good mood yeah do you think it
is maybe a little bit to do with hanging
out with the chess Bros having a little
bit of a good time together with friends
it's all those Good Vibes in there face
it you know if you're feeling happy you
play good jazz I mean it's that simple
yeah and then Hikaru Nakamura Wesley
Seoul a draw a safe solid draw in the
first game there
you know I have to say Wesley was just
prodding probing Hikaru just looking for
those weaknesses you know he just kept
on pushing you know on the king side on
the on the queen side I mean he just
kept on going and I have to say it was
Hikaru who was on the back foot the
whole time okay so Hikaru now we're
gonna have the white pieces in game two
what do you expect
well I mean if I were to say like to use
a football analogy you know it's a game
of it's like a game of chess right and
there's a game of football I would say
it's an advantage to Wesley um Hikaru
now needs to actually do exactly the
same in the the second game yeah so all
the players are working hard and the
winner is semi-finals and we hope you
guys at home are working hard as well on
today's puzzle it's from a study
composed by the youngest player in the
air thinks muscles gukash what is this
Apostle or study about you yeah I mean
you have to remember he composed this
study when he was just 15 years old I
mean he's 16 now but I mean it's white
to play and the whole you know so
in-game study and the whole theme is
that white must take advantage of
something right now if you wait too long
then of course Black's forces will unify
and there will be some defenses so it's
very very very clever and uh gather your
friends take selfies show me don't don't
turn on the computer
don't cheat get your friends together
have a good old natter and see whether
you can solve it together because after
all that's the best way of solving
puzzles definitely and tweak your answer
using hashtag chess Champs One winner
will get a fantastic everything's device
signed by Magnus Carlsen and Magnus
Carlsen is getting ready for game two
here in the winner of semi-finals
guess what move has just landed on the
board porn takes Pawn the only one we
were saying would never happen Hikaru
worsening his Pawn structure wow Magnus
just widening his eyes they're I think
shocked by this last decision by Eric
icy Arjun is about to resign losing on
time as well and he logs off immediately
all right are we ready for game two's in
the winter semifinals of course yeah
Carlson playing arjunera garci Wesley so
car Nakamura what more could you ask for
I know I mean can you believe the lineup
these four amazing players yeah it's
stuck this whole field and uh yeah I'm
expecting a lot more fireworks it's a
long match today it's four games in the
winners bracket so everybody has time to
fight back but uh yeah Magnus whoever he
plays uh in the next round whether it's
the win or loser bracket I think uh he's
been in top form so far he's going to be
the one to stop yeah Arjun all right
guys you're with the white pieces he
lost the first game to Magnus but still
has time to turn this around and what
are we seeing on the board in this game
Tanya wow it's a Queen's Gambit accepted
Magnus has decided to pick up that Free
Pawn and I have to say losing that first
game definitely a big setback for Arjun
when you're playing against Magnus it
really sets up the dawn for the match so
with the white pieces super crucial that
he gets his chances from the opening
Magnus making a bit of a risky Choice
there with the picking up that C4 Pawn
Yeah so the Queen's got bit accepted
this time but this last move maybe not
the most common it does kind of provoke
white it does try to tempt white into
occupying the center white is
temporarily down one Pawn that black
Pawn on C4 the double Pawn won't
necessarily survive that long but Magnus
is saying okay if you don't go for it
now I will defend it and uh Arjun does
open up his light Squad Bishop not
pushing the pawn two squares which was
maybe a more risky but more ambitious
approach instead he's ready to capture
that Bishop he's saying to Magnus defend
it at your peril and Magnus says yes
I'll happily cling to that extra Pawn
can Arjun punish him this is often the
way to try and undermine Black's Queen
side uh structure there what do you
think Robert is this something you know
I must say I'm out of book at this point
I think it's becoming increasingly
popular just because these type of
variations they force a large series of
Trades that these A4 Pawn for the B5
Pawn the Rooks will come off the board
there will see some other Queen side
pawns come off so with Magnus Carlson in
the lead he says I'm okay being slightly
worse perhaps and making a draw he does
not want to give Arjun Eric icy the type
of tactical positions that he thrives in
I think it's a wise opening Choice even
though Origins should be slightly better
yeah man just to show all the traits
that might well happen over the next few
moves if Arjun is feeling peaceful
um okay he plays B3 first of all uh
keeping some tension but now question is
for Magnus how do you answer this one he
could have traded Pawns of course he
could have traded Rogues he could have
then gone B3 hoping to break his Bishop
spring it free to capture this Pawn but
black would just leave this tension and
give back the pawn and I think this is
what you're alluding to Robert A
variation like this where long-term
black will get rid of his only isolated
porn trade-off and very hard to imagine
White having much of an advantage here
Magnus is doing the same thing but he's
saying okay there's still this tension
along the a file I don't think white can
profit from that so we might see a
similar white will regain this Pawn at
will most likely now and Magnus he'll
just try to shore up his defenses he'll
just try and curl up and equalize which
he might well do I'm sure he studied
this one before Magnus the speed with
which he's playing at least that's what
it seems to reflect but I think arjun's
got reasons to be pleased with the fact
that he gets this combative energetic
opening you know it's hard to beat
Magnus if Magnus decides to be solid but
in these kind of positions we can
imagine fireworks in the middle game
very good idea to pick up that extra
Pawn right now because you anyway need
to finish your development you want to
get that Bishop on C4 eventually hope
that the C7 Pawn might be a weakness and
the counter for that often for black is
to strike in the center with C5 as soon
as possible yep I think we'll see this
on the board this is the most likely
continuation right now and when C5
happens like we'll swap off his only
weakness but black is slightly lagging
behind in development if you look at all
of these guys still at home tucked up in
bed and uh okay Magnus first decides to
solve that issue he first develops his
Knight so early days but Magnus solid
definitely playing for equality Arjun
will try and keep as much attention as
possible if you can we have been
discussing ways of studying chess here
in the studio today with some great
questions from you guys on Twitch and we
have another one from Kevin winter I'll
direct this to you first David so is
there Merit still getting out the chess
set to analyze positions Etc youngsters
use apps on their phones to prepare and
practice
uh shout out to Kevin I believe he's a
fellow Brit so hi
um I do like the chess set I'm old
school
um not that I have a chess set in the
apartment
but there's a different feel to it at
least back when I was kind of playing
professionally full time I would always
put things on a board because you
somehow see things you understand a bit
more if you are kind of just seeing
things in 3D and um yeah on a computer
screen somehow doesn't feel the same
often I'm just clicking buttons saying
okay the computer says this so it must
be right but I don't activate my brain
and it's only when I get to the heat of
the action to get to the board when I'm
like why didn't I study this move it's
so obvious for a human and I think
that's the difference I
chessboard over computer yeah
yeah that's a great question and I think
it really depends on how you see
yourself as a chess player if you want
to focus on online play and playing more
and more games online then you can let
go of the chessboard try and practice
and get that board vision from online
chess itself but if you have Ambitions
to play over the board it definitely
helps to bring out the chess set your
vision improves your understanding of
positions just getting the feel of the
pieces it's so different online chess is
just such a different animal from OTB so
if you want to play tournaments get that
chess set out all right what do you
prefer Robert
not studying chess yeah I prefer doing
my job and then watching you know
something on Netflix now but I do prefer
the physical board because if I'm going
to look at a position and especially if
you're working with somebody you want to
just look at it over the board really
dig deep and think about that way
because I think the screen is a bit of a
distraction I know that I get some
headaches from staring at the screen too
often and you kind of don't always feel
fully focused because I don't and I
think that especially when you have the
eval bar off the side you're looking
like okay a white is better because I'm
told so but you're not turning on that
switch like David was saying and
calculating for yourself uh-huh
interesting playing online somehow I
enjoy a lot I really enjoy playing
online but uh in terms of study I think
over the board is just as effective at
least and I mean well Magnus Magnus
Castle is King is this a pawn sacrifice
this black A6 pawn it seems to be the
theme of the day every player we've seen
with the black pieces seems to have a
weakness on this square that tends to
drop off I'm trying to figure out
whether Arjun can get ambitious and just
capture that pawn right now why not why
not that's a great question because you
can pick it up and if black picks up the
bishop on E6 tank that Knight on D2 that
is defending the Rook on B1 black can
swap off the bishop hit the queen but
white doesn't care simply captures back
and you can take the rook and B1 the
Knight will make a retreating move and
everything's under control white ends up
with an extra Pawn Yeah I know PDO is a
favorite saying of Chess commentators
but here no loose pieces no loose pawns
everything's defended in the white Camp
so uh what has Magnus worked out now we
do see a tweet from Grandmaster Jonathan
Tisdale praising magnus's form I agree
he's looking good but he needs to at
least justify this Pawn sacrifice
otherwise Suddenly It's all about
whether white can convert
um I'm still struggling to see it I must
admit do you think it was intuitive or
he really has this figured out because
it's one of those Pawn sacrifices
sometimes you just do because you know
it should be the right answer and then
you saddle with decision
um why did I give that pawn am I
actually going to get this back so I
feel like from Magnus here he's likely
to maybe swap off some material and try
to go after the a pawn it is a pass Pawn
it's an extra Pawn but it's also an
isolated Pawn not so easy to defend and
Magnus does trade the Rooks there and
I'm curious if his move now bringing the
queen all the way to the corner to the
AIDS we're offering a queen trade and
going directly for that pawn on A4 yeah
but it's become a race if white can keep
that pawn while activating his pieces on
the back rank then Arjun is going to
take this one home he's going to win but
if Magnus can somehow Corral that pawn
and just somehow regain the material
equality in the next three or four moves
then he should be safe enough I'm very
surprised if it was intuitive then
yeah it's just a shocked that he's in
such a complacent mood Magnus because he
looks so sharp it looks like he's
calculated everything in all his games
so far in the tournament but there we go
Robert you predicted it it feels like
the only logical follow-up to justify
that earlier sacrifice and Arjun
immediately Retreats saying no trade
instead hitting that isolated Pawn on C7
now does black defend it does black just
say okay I'll trade off my weakness for
your a pawn get rid of that past Pawn
definitely feels like black is the one
fighting for equality now well looking
at Magnus on camera he doesn't look
super happy with the way things have
gone so far Queen C4 I like that archon
decided to keep the Queens on board
rather than just handing over the a file
to Magnus where the Rook would have come
and attacked the weakness one of the big
problems for white in compensation for
that pawn is that he needs to get those
pieces out he needs to develop as soon
as possible that night on B1 the bishop
on C1 get that Rook into the game but
that gives black a lot of time I like
the idea of just going for C5 you've
been screaming about this plan and it's
on the board finally Magnus does it the
problem after C5 for Arjun is going to
be that if you trade these spawns the
Knight can jump over to C5 and hit that
A4 Bond gaining more time yep gaining
more time and the only way to defend it
now would be to bring White's Knight out
but the black Rook could swing across
some serious threats along this C file
it's going to be hard to envisage White
clingy onto the extra Pawn here it feels
like black has mobilized just in time so
is there another solution for Argent
does he have to allow black to improve
his pieces with Tempo the problem is
this is also a threat going for the pawn
with the Black Knight hitting the White
Queen in the process maybe I didn't give
Magnus enough credit maybe he did work
it all out and it was just checking the
details now that you've pointed out the
super crucial threat with Knight B6
maybe it's time to not trade on C5 but
actually develop the Knight on B1 to C3
to fund that bone on A4 fighting against
these threats that we are talking about
and Arjun now this is a bit of a
surprise for me when your pieces are not
out you don't move the same piece over
and over again the queen has been all
over the board falls back once again I
have a bad feeling about this one
and that's the fourth or fifth time he's
moved to White Queen meanwhile these
guys still uh I think they're angry at
the White Queen right now don't forget
to use us but uh how can Magnus take
advantage of this well at least he
stepped away from the fork right Knight
to B6 was hitting that Queen on C4 and
the pawn A4 at the same time now Knight
B6 it only threatens them on which can
either be defended or pushed up to the
A5 Square so I do think that Arjun he is
just trying to avoid Black's easy play
and now the onus is back on Magnus
what's your plan are you really just
trying to swap pawns you are down upon
after all so entering an end game you're
always taught that you do not want to
trade pieces when you are down uh you
can trade some of them but not all of
them and I do think that origen just
taking a safe step backwards he puts the
task back in Max's hands and it's not an
easy decision to make yup here I'm
expecting Magnus either to start
mobilizing his Knight maybe bring his
Rook to a more active Square I'm not not
sure exactly which one uh maybe trade
off the pawns but as you guys mentioned
that only helps whitesnite to jump into
the center lots of questions for Magnus
to answer slightly lower on the clock
yeah at least it might be a strange move
this queen retreat but it is asking
Magnus those questions
and it might be time for Magnus to try
to swing his Rook over to the queen side
as well while the queen is ideally
placed on one file capture the other
file Rook B it comes into mind as an
option for black hair just trying to get
more piece activity still waiting for
white to really blink his eye in the
center and capture on C5 yep it is very
tense it's still that type of race but
neither side seems eager to win the race
in a way to develop their pieces to
activate uh yeah I do feel if white gets
one more move Magnus is going to be
suffering forever so he needs to take
advantage of the tempo he needs to
create a threat he needs to go for that
white a pawn and at the moment is now
and look at him he's all leaned into the
camera he realizes what you're saying
David that this is a very critical
moment he can't give a lot of time to
White Once the Pieces come out the
initiative is gone
yeah White's next move might she sliding
the bishop up to D2 develop it push your
a pawn it's on a protected Square so I
think Magnus senses that the moment is
dire not that he will lose if he makes
an inaccuracy here but it might become
uncomfortable and then hard to defend so
I think that he is thinking about your
night jumps David maybe Knight up into
E4 over to D5 and instead he brings his
Rook to C8 that does prevent the white
knight from developing the C3 tactically
but Arjun makes the simple and strong
Bishop D2 I'm liking arjun's winning
chances move by move unless Magnus
proves that he could stop and maybe
capture that pawn on A4 I think that
Arjun will just have all the fun here
yeah really nice classy move there
Bishop D2 preparing to advance his a
pawn controlling squares feels like
magnus's last move it was yes an
improving move but it doesn't
necessarily threatening uh threaten
anything and yeah I'm inclined to agree
I'm starting to worry for Magnus Carson
in this game but now where does Bishop
on D2 David your idea of jumping forward
with the Knight to E4 hitting that
Bishop becomes even stronger so maybe
it's time to do that bring the knights
into the enemy camp yup black needs to
activate and uh starting with one of the
night jumps looks the most logical and
Tanya it's late in India right now and
we know last season on the tour uh Arjun
he was playing up until the early hours
four or five a.m even uh do you think
that's going to affect him in this one I
can tell you one thing for these Indian
kids they are night outs they love to
play chess late into the night the worst
of the lot is nehal oh really he is up
till seven in the morning eight in the
morning that's his usual sleep routine
so it doesn't matter Argentina more
discipline I think Prague is perhaps the
most disciplined when it comes to
sleeping hours of course you know you
want to play at a better time and
arjun's spoken about that that sometimes
to adapt to these Champions chest or
playing others he's had to work out at
night so that he can stay up late in the
early in the morning wow wow I wish I
had his Drive yeah
but definitely it is something of
concern but for these kids probably not
as much as uh as one would feel it they
love sleeping late and I think that's a
challenge that they've learned to
overcome with time with practice and wow
we've had the idea of night jumping into
anime camp but after a central trade but
I'm wondering because as you were
talking I was the calculating a little
bit can white just get a night sacrifice
in there with Knight takes Pawn on E6
because the black king is In Harm's Way
and many of Black's pieces will be
hanging so the queen that we didn't
really love sliding back towards uh the
A2 Square now it might venture into E6
with devastating effect yeah bang night
takes porn it might be possible here
Magnus surely has calculated this unless
it's just a blind spot we have seen
Magnus from time to time over the last
few moves uh over the last few months
sorry uh make these one move blunders
but surely there must be a counter in
mind just to show Robert's idea after
the pawn recaptures the White Queen
swoops in check and this looks deadly
you're hitting the king but also hitting
two pieces one of these two will drop
off next move so I don't really feel you
can get away with uh with capturing that
white knight but if you don't take it
back your two pawns down how do you
justify that but he doesn't need to
answer the question because Arjun
decides not to go for it very shocking
and I wonder if this was Mutual
Blindness by the two players Magnus
missing 96 and then Archer missing 96
because he just makes the move Rook from
F1 to C1 offering an exchange and this
could be a big Miss by Arjun huge mess
and it's quite a thematic idea in all
sorts of openings not just here but also
in Sicilians in caricons in French
defenses of a night sacrificing itself
on E6 so I'm shocked that both players
could potentially have missed this one
unless Magnus had some really creative
reply that we're not seeing right now
but Knight takes porn looked like it
might have backed a second pawn and
potentially won the game for Arjun
instead a rook swap maybe still got the
advantage I'm expecting uh Magnus to
acquiesce and agree to this exchange but
then what what is the idea how is he
going to regain this past Pawn before
it's too late if the Queens disappear
white is most likely going to win this
Pawn will be too strong marching up the
board Let's uh I'm still shocked you're
shocked because Knight E6 is just a move
that I feel Arjun will at least take a
bit of a tank on and spend a little more
time here but him really just blitzing
out Rook C1 it's a strange decision and
we saw him in his match against alireza
he was so up to these tactics he was on
top of his game he showed a a level form
there absolute top form and he needs to
come up with that energy and that
precision and 96 can come back to haunt
him to miss this opportunity
yeah maybe we need our viewers help to
figure out what what was wrong with
Knight takes E6 it's a bit of a mystery
uh yeah I'm not Sherlock Holmes but I
can't figure out why 1966 wasn't just a
strong movement and it could be in a
sense trusting that Magnus wouldn't
blunder it wouldn't move tactic so maybe
there was some miraculous defense there
but it did look like white could get
away with it now all of a sudden Black's
pieces are flowing that Knight hops up
to C5 it attacks the pawn that extra
Pawn that white has in front of the
queen and that can also jump in towards
where the other night is and attack the
white king so all of a sudden it feels
like Black's task is much easier I think
that Arjun will be kicking himself maybe
he played a little bit too quickly
trying to use the clock as a weapon but
that was a missed opportunity yeah you
can't trust these top players they might
be very very good but occasionally they
do slip up and you've got to be ready to
pounce when the moments come interesting
game we should mention it's a draw
between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so in
game two as well they are still tied
after two games
wow that's a quick draw in that one yeah
it looked like good preparation from
Wesley so just neutralized uh hikaru's
uh advantage of the white pieces and uh
yeah just very solid draw so very
professional game from those two and
what do you predict on this one Robert
draw the draw for sure yeah just the way
this game has been going the pieces
coming off the board already this A4
Pawn under attack it's the only extra
piece for white I think we're gonna see
liquidation and a draw in the near
future yeah let's try maybe and keep
this Pawn intact at least for a move or
two for ardrin let's see what happens if
white for example steps the pawn forward
it's under a fire twice right now so if
we Step It Forward maybe the issue is
that the black Bishop can come and start
hitting it now
Actually All Blacks pieces are working
so well together you mentioned these
nights uh the knights will dance in to
the white Camp if you're not careful
start coming in with some threats but
yeah first of all you just go and pick
it off and Arjun first asks the question
of this night uh he steps forward F3 you
never really want to weaken your king
like this the white king is very very
loose but at least you're saying okay
Retreat please and when the Knight steps
back maybe the idea I'm not sure where
the Knight goes but maybe the idea will
be to step forward and at least now you
have the D2 Square to defend this Pawn
with your Bishop
clever with the night going back you can
also think about developing your own
Knight to C3 after the bishop comes out
to D2 it's all been about development
here White's been really lacking it
Arjun went for that Bond but I think the
slight inaccuracy once again uh when
you're playing against Magnus and you
get these opportunities you just have to
take them because they're not gonna come
again and give Magnus one chance and
he'll be all over the board
so this I think it is the worst is over
for Magnus now F3 it's a long-term
weakness on the king side I won't be
surprised if black decides to drop back
with the Knight to D6 as well instead of
F6 it's a more centralized square and
feels like controls the board a little
more at some point it can for example
you can improve your queen to the light
squares on A6 try and bring it into
enemy camp also from the Knight to D6 it
can jump over to C4 so going to be
interesting to see where Magnus decides
to retreat with the Knight he's got
about four minutes Arjun still almost
double double the time on the clock yeah
super Speedy stuff from our generic I
see in this one and what's Magnus
thinking about it seems to be a straight
choice between two Retreat squares
unless he has a surprise up his sleeve
is he really tempted to jump in with the
other Black Knight hit that white Bishop
I would be scared of that piece getting
trapped yeah I think he learned that
lesson from Alexi Serrano that if he
tries to jump into his night it will be
trapped in enemy territory so he goes
back after quite a substantial thing and
now for Arjun it's time to develop bring
the Knight out to C3 I do believe that
Arjun he has the advantage that is
undeniable but I do think that Magnus is
playing this perfectly well he is a stop
that past Pawn before he can keep going
up the board and he has pieces in the
right location to prevent his progress
but the clock is what I'm worried about
from a magnus's perspective
yep and the Knight does develop to C3
finally it feels like he's getting
mobilized he's getting motoring Arjun
and uh Magnus unable to restore the
balance at the moment still a pawn down
the longer that continues the greater
aeroglyce's chances will be but uh
Magnus is activating slowly at that
black queen now along the diagonal might
start jumping in some juicy squares can
Argent keep control speaking of Juicy
squares it's got to be that D3 Square
you bringing your queen there hitting
that Knight on C3 threatening Queen D1
as well I really like this move and it's
all about peace activity for black in
compensation for that Bond and Magnus is
making sure that he plays with the queen
he plays with the two knights and keeps
the pressure on yep while white is
distracted defending this past Pawn
actually it's the white king that has no
Defenders around it and this is a very
common pattern that plays at the top
level are very sensitive to what
especially once a queen is uh far away
divorced from her own King then there
are often counter-attacking ideas so
every guys he offers a queen Exchange
don't think Magnus will agree to this
one you can't really accept a queen
trade while this Pawn still lives it
will eventually win the game for white
so Magnus will run away but the question
is where and I like this move because
after this wherever you run away White
Queen can jump onto C4 and from there it
guards the A4 pawn it can also go to B5
once again offering a queen trade but
also from a much active spot than where
it was earlier so really nice Queen
maneuver by uh Arjun here yeah really
nice and Magnus still on the defensive
I've got to say this last move
especially from Arjun offering the queen
trade with Queen E2 really classy and
Magnus doesn't give white the time to
offer a second Queen trade because uh
he's attacking this white knight so
maybe tania's moves to defend this
Knight looks very appropriate although
I'm slightly scared of allowing the
queen in with some back ranker back uh
later watch out watch out David Knight
C6 is a huge threat after the queen
lands on C4 true actually both sides
have threats uh this would be a nasty
Fork hitting the black queen of course
hitting the black Bishop uh in tandem so
suddenly it's anyone's game but Arjun
with some accuracy looks like he could
turn this group for some more pressure
on ah and should Magnus be worried about
his clock Robert yeah he definitely
should be because now things are not
clear there's no easy path to trading up
pieces or stopping this Apon uh just a
few moves ago I felt like it should be a
hold and I don't really think anything's
been misplayed I think origen just
playing the ackermans F3 was a nice find
but I'm kicking uh the Black Knight out
of the center now after Queen C4 as both
Tony and Dave were highlighting Knight
C6 is a threat the a pawn is protected
uh that sort of Checkmate on the back
rank there are some funny lines where
there's almost a Checkmate in Black's
favor but I just don't think it's in
time so uh this is a bad moment here for
Magnus as he barely has over three
minutes and for Arjun he has you know
almost doubled his time and with great
winning chances yeah maybe that's why
earlier Tony you mentioned the Black
Knight going back to F6 it's a bit
stranded over there it wants to be on
the other side of the board helping out
its teammates helping out the other
pieces at least if the Black Knight had
gone to D6 as you mentioned earlier
White's Queen jumps would never be
possible so it's tiny little details
like that that kind of decide results at
the top level but uh yeah suddenly
Magnus hasn't done anything clearly
wrong but somehow it's still Advantage
for Arjun and uh spending his time again
wisely this is is a critical moment if
you let it slip if you play one or two
inaccurate moves the pawn disappears
draw so Arjun might as well invest the
time now five minutes to try and create
some winning chances we're expecting a
queen move you can make an argument for
just defending this White Knight with a
bishop for example but uh he has to
decide soon I think he has to at least
put Magnus under pressure on the clock
because there will come a time later
where you need that extra minute or two
to work things out he's definitely
looking at the alternative of Bishop to
D2 as well and trying to see if black
does get greedy with that pawn on A4
does he have a strong discovered attack
on that Queen on A5 I don't see it at
first sight and queen C4 that nice juicy
Square as you call it David so the queen
just looks so attractive and with the
Knight jumping on to C6 I would be
surprised if Arjun chooses another way
to defend this Knight on C3 yeah we
should mention between wow he plays a
great move there from Arjun I was about
to mention that he actually has a
terrible score against Magnus both
online and over the board losing in
fight Kansai recently in their most
recent uh in the most recent classical
game but he has had one win against
Magnus one individual win and that also
came with the white pieces when Magnus
wasn't quite finding accurate moose so
uh something to build on but I see it's
not just who's enjoying the position and
all as well what is that we have an owl
watching what it's my spirit animal
okay how cool is that you guys an owl
watching very nice truly breaks barriers
yeah it definitely does and owls are
known to be wise right yeah and
nocturnal like chess players at least
Indian ones the Indian kids it's the
younger place
and uh wow that's a lot of nights in the
center of the board when Knights land in
a pattern like this there's so much
calculation to be done there are some
threats here some traps for both sides
trying to work out quickly what tactics
are happening and Arjun also has to work
that out with only three minutes left
and uh Robert what do we think here can
white get away with jumping in with his
Knight at some point to C6 does he
capture this Knight just to show one
threat the one you don't want to capture
is this one because suddenly whoops back
right Checkmate you need the White Queen
to come back and defend for example here
if black had given a check first there
was a defensive uh resource you can
swoop back with the queen and neutralize
the checks so Arjun he has to be careful
once you see things like this ideas like
this
the fear of God is in you the ghosts of
checkmates they'll always be in the back
of your mind so what is the most
accurate defense he places and I think
he's setting up a brilliant tactic
because after Knight takes Knight on C3
you'd expect an automatic recapture on
the Square but no he wants this Knight
C6 jump hitting the queen on A5 hitting
the bishop on E7 and Knight C3 can be
captured on the next turn don't forget
white has an extra Pawn trades will help
him try to win this end game so that is
what Arjun has in mind and that is bad
news for Magnus as he has dipped below
two minutes on the clock there are
tactics Galore here I think his best
option is to slide his Queen all the way
back to eight in the current position
you protect your knight on D5 and you're
trying to dislodge White's Knight on C3
because as soon as that Knight leaves
the A4 Pawn will drop I believe that
mags has to bring the queen back to
eight but he just doesn't have that much
time to figure out these complications
yeah crucial position uh let's go back
to the players and maybe we can get
stockfish we need a bit of help here it
looks like Robert dropping that Queen
back you might be right is that the only
move how big is the margin for error for
Magnus Carlson right now one minute on
the clock and queen A8 is not obvious
it's not an instinctive move it's where
it's the move you can get to by process
of elimination by Deep calculation but
Magnus hasn't played it yet he's Frozen
one minute on the clock this is so much
tension on the board right now just
everything hanging the night jumping to
C6 trying to find a good Square for that
Queen
I'm shaking yeah he needs to play
otherwise Arjun is gonna strike back he
looks frustrated Magnus and let's bring
up stockfish stockfish suggestions
does he have several options Magnus is
he walking a tightrope here 40 seconds
now calm down and wow Robert you're
completely correct he can minimize limit
the damage by dropping his Queen all the
way back to the corner but very
difficult for a human to spot it does
take time to work that one out anything
else gives white a significant Advantage
not decisive but uh something to play
with 20 seconds you're gonna find it 20
seconds yeah the second option bring the
Knight back to B6 allows white to trade
the Queens that's clearly not what he
wants but Queen Aid there's still so
many pieces left and he's down to about
10 seconds on the clock and did he lose
connection he needs to make a move yes
seven five seconds for Magnus Carlsen
Gotta Move Magnus and he finds the best
move wow he drinks that water look at
him he's like I deserve a little
refreshment and he plays Queen so the
Knight on D5 is defended as you look at
the best suggestion is White Knight
hopping over to F5 that is too wild but
Arjun has over three minutes remaining
he can find those kind of ideas you see
that says it's about level though so
Magnus he still has a lot of work cut
out for him but Queen 8 was the step in
the right direction yeah especially with
11 seconds on the clock and uh out of
those three suggestions we saw for white
all of them are very tricky for black to
deal with uh so Magnus has questions to
answer Arjun now his job is to just set
a trap at least set a pitfall for Magnus
to fall into and yeah I still think
there's some twists and turns ahead in
this one Arjun doing a great job of
forcing Magnus onto this tightrope and
uh yeah one of those night jumps now for
White's just force Magnus to think don't
give him time to calculate come on Arjun
you can go for it I'm stunned that
Magnus found that move in just seconds
and this is why getting a good position
against Magnus is just half the job done
the guy is so hard to beat even with
seconds on the clock he finds and I'm I
mean queen 8 was a very difficult movie
it's a retreating move and you've got
only seconds on your clock just amazing
stuff there arjun's got a lot of
pleasant choices yeah but he needs to
make sure that he keeps the pressure on
the clock because that's equally
important yeah yeah two minutes now for
Hutch and it feels like the tension of
this game is getting to both of them and
at least in terms of uh time consumption
here and I'm not sure which one I would
go for Knight F5 once you see it it's
too tempting but uh seeing it that's the
first challenge
he'll find it Well he has great success
he's been able to thrive in the lowest
of time controls he won the junior
speeches championship by beating nihal
sarin who had won in consecutive years
so Arjun has proven on the biggest of
stages that he can do it but there's no
bigger stage than facing off against
Magnus Carlsen kind of a must-win
situation I feel like he lost game one
it was quite convincing in Max's favor
he really needs to win this game because
the draw he'll still be losing on the
scoreboard you don't want to go into a
Magnus Carlson white game when you're
down a point so this is a big moment for
Arjun I think he needs to play some kind
of move that keeps the pieces on the
board it's huge this is the moment that
he has to strike back in this match he
has to make the most of this position
that he has and Arjun taking his time I
have a feeling that he will go for
Knight F5 yeah you don't get many
chances against the world number one you
need to take this chance Argent Eric I
see yeah and if he doesn't take the
chance if this game is to draw Magnus
has a chance to end it in the next game
in three Magnus will have white again so
everything writes on this next few moves
for Arjun under one minute now oh David
he's playing on seconds as well yeah in
this type of situation it will be so
easy to take the kind of solid way out
but here you just have to go for it you
won't get a better chance than this
Arjun will he land a knight in will he
just trade off Knights if the white
apron drops it's gonna be a draw so
let's take some very very high okay he
pushes forward this was one of the top
three moves according to stockfish how
tricky is it though and uh Magnus
calculated this one super quickly
gobbling the pawn immediately this walks
into some discovered checks some double
attacks but Magnus I think he's worked
it out yeah he has because you know
there's a stare down between a bishop
and a queen so when the Knight moves out
of the way those pieces will be looking
at each other so there are attacks look
at this it's like a pre-move Magnus
takes that Knight back his Queen is hang
on A5 but if you take that Queen you
lose yours on C4 and if you take that
pawn on D5 you'll lose your Bishop that
is seeing there on D2 so now they're
both around 10 seconds and you've lost
your time Advantage as well has Arjun
messed us up he could lose this I mean
both sides could lose this now it's a
bullet scramble wow Magnus dropping down
to a few seconds he moves his Queen so
calm but uh the worst is definitely over
he has Consolidated equal material
isolated porn for black in the center
but not easy to attack it for white
and uh both Kings some threats against
them it might be completely equal but
still far from a drop but watch out for
Forks all of a sudden there are Forks if
you move your queen to the B2 Square the
Knight hops to the rim of the board and
it Forks the queen of the bishop so
Arjun he's in big time trouble just like
Magnus it's a bullet scramble it
seriously is
yeah very much pre-moves here and black
tonight has planted itself on a solid
Square white tonight is on a dream
attacking Outpost could be anyone's game
but the Knight is getting kicked back
risky move there for Magnus opening up
the black king slightly further but oh
this nitrate and now the game will calm
down I think we're headed towards the
draw
wow
we've got to catch our breath that was a
really tense battle but a draw is almost
inevitable now it's four versus four in
terms of Pawns no passports and
everything else being equal the Queens
will also cancel each other out okay so
even with the clock still ticking with
seconds uh left on the clock there
should be a draw yeah not much left to
play for we see checks on the board and
there's just one weakness that black has
which is the D5 Bond it can easily be
defended by the queen and I think it's
just a matter of time that the players
agree for a draw it doesn't matter how
many seconds they have now and I think
we're going to see a repetition right
here yeah the yoyo string Queen slides
the G3 check back to E1 if a Black's
move uh White might be the first to give
these checks but I think that if manga
slides his King over to H7 we will see
the queen G3 Queen E1 back and forth
there's nothing that white can do but I
guess Arjun gets to land the checks and
force the draw but he's definitely the
one who's disappointed with this result
this was his big chance his big game
against Magnus you can see it on his
face he kind of banged the table there
almost and uh he does look frustrated it
a draw is confirmed and Magnus device
wow that means Magnus Carlsen is still
in the lead winning the first game the
second one is a draw do you think Arjun
is disappointed now uh Robert yeah he
must be kicking himself because he had
the white pieces he was up a pawn he was
doing everything it took to continue his
advantage and then suddenly in the
critical moment he was up three minutes
and yet the advantage dissipated
immediately so even though the result
was never winning for uh Arjun there's
not that big of an advantage he's
probably upset that he let slip that
quickly yeah and how about Magnus then
Tonya do you think he's feeling
relieved he got away with this or do you
think he's upset that he actually did
get into some trouble here 100 relief
that was a difficult game right out of
the opening for Magnus he showed some
combative defense there but Arjun kept
the pressure on I think it comes down to
that one moment where he pushed the pawn
gave up that Advantage Magnus is happy
with this result he survives it every
white game for Argent guns and he's just
left with one
we're seeing some awesome chests between
Magnus Carlson and Arjun eregaissey and
here is today's Lisa vetta learning
point
today's learning point is about not
trusting your opponent don't miss those
tactical opportunities just because you
assume your opponent can't have
blundered and it was here in the game
between Argent aragaisy with white
Magnus Carlson with black that we
spotted a bit of mutual blindness Magnus
planted this night in the center of the
board a very logical move but it did
momentarily allow a bit of a trick
Knight takes porn now was available to
White using the fact the White Queen
from afar is about to land a nasty check
if the Knight is captured White's Queen
replaces the Knight checking the black
king hitting this bishop hitting this
Knight and one of these two pieces will
drop white will emerge with two extra
pawns and a big decisive Advantage
magnus's plan here wasn't really clear
maybe he would have moved his Queen up
the board but then why has he given up a
second Point white would happily step
back with his Knight and the pressure
would certainly have been on the world
number one to justify that momentary
blindness it did feel like this was the
missed opportunity for Eric icy can he
turn around the match now that's the
question it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
it's all about air things and the air
things Masters and having great air
quality we're going to talk to an expert
on the field but if you're not a
subscriber on Twitch here is a twitch
break
[Music]
we're joined Now by Stefan Kuhn he is an
associate professor at Maastricht
University recently done a bunch of
studying on air quality and chess and I
want to start asking you Stefan do you
also play chess
oh uh well I played when I was when I
was a kid but never end down that level
of course uh so I know she has a bit but
I'm not actively playing chess actually
none of us in our in our study is
playing chess really so why did you
choose to use chess when uh doing this
big study that you recently have done
uh let me yeah I'm a labor Economist so
I'm basically interested in how the
environment and conditions air quality
in particular affects our performance
and we have the problem then you know if
we think about our own productivity as
academics or managers lawyers doctors
whatever
um how do we measure our output and
that's super difficult so we came up
with chess because with chess we can
always compare the performance of the
player to what the the chess engine
would predict and then we get kind of an
error rate that gives us a performance
measure and we can link that the playing
you know performance of the of the
player
um to the air quality that the player is
exposed to Aha and so
the study is how a chess tournament
exposed the hidden cost of air pollution
can you explain how did you carry out
this study
well we first uh set up um we had a
collaboration with uh a kind of amateur
Club in Cologne in uh in Germany so they
allowed us to monitor their their
tournament so every year they have a
tournament that's the main Tournament of
that chess club and we were allowed to
install sensors indoor senders next to
the players when they were playing so
the monitor their their air quality and
then we linked this to the performance
of the players and in a sec that is our
our main that was our main study but
then of course we also brought into
whole study and but we did we analyzed
um the all of the bonus Liga so the
first League uh chess leak in uh in
Germany all the games that have been
played between 2003 and 2019 uh to also
see whether our results that we you know
analyzed based on the small chess club
in Cologne also holds for the universe
of games that have been played all over
Germany and we find exactly the same
results and what what is those results
what did you actually find
yeah well uh what we see quite clearly
throughout all the specifications and
all the different tournaments that we
analyzed that if players are exposed to
higher levels of particular meta
pollution
um then they they're playing performance
goes down so that they make more errors
and also larger errors and in particular
and that was was quite nice with the the
chess tournament that we observed and
also the the Bundesliga chefs
tournaments that we observed uh they
have a Time control so after 1 10 moves
they have to uh sorry they have to make
the first 40 moves within one out of 10
minutes and we see when they approach
this time control uh the effect is
largest so we we concluded that the and
if they make if you make decisions
cognitive decisions under time stress
this uh you know lead to particularly
more errors if they are higher if
there's higher air pollution wow how
interesting
yeah so we found as well and uh that
also in the end led to the result that
we uh published
um that the results of our study in in a
very good Channel
Stefan it's been so helpful to have the
air things device at home to guide us
with the air quality I am from India I
live in delhi now it's helpful but also
a little depressing because it's always
red the deli air quality is super famous
and I know one of the big advice when
air quality is bad is to open your
windows but I will tell everyone
watching that's a bad idea in Delhi so
Stefan what do you think uh when that's
not an option to open the window for
fresh air how can how can we actually
improve the indoor air quality then
but I think there's a short term and a
long-term solution so the short-term
short-term solution of course you can
have error filtration systems within
your house so to keep the windows closed
and try to create your own you know air
quality by by filtering the air that's
kind of a short-term solution the
long-term solution is more on public
policy from our perspective I mean we
are only one piece in the whole puzzle
um in in science and there are these
effects of particular particular meta
pollution is huge so they they harm our
health uh quite clearly to their lead to
more to more mortality they affect our
physical productivity they affect also
now as we show our cognitive performance
so I think that it's time for Public
Policy to act and to read to to fight
air pollution on a more you know broader
public level either that or I'll just
have to move to Norway yeah you can do
that Tonya I would like that that's
that's uh also a good idea but let me
remind you I mean of course in Daily
there are sometimes you have a level
that you even see the air pollution so
that in Europe usually we never have but
we have very uh but we we run the study
in Germany where you would say from it
coming from now daily that's a very
clear environment but even here we find
these significant effects on our you
know on our cognitive performance
first of all for
works and for joining our show
thank you for the invitation it was a
pleasure pleasure to have you here
wow I guess it's not a huge surprise
that uh air pollution will affect the
brain it's a little scary right
I'm also glad that I can just uh put the
fact that I'm not a Grand Master on my
back
that's a great excuse I found now it's
the only reason right it's the only
reason David yeah have you do you have
any experience uh Robert you know
working a lot from home that we're doing
these days uh and playing chess at home
as well sort of sensing how the bad air
quality can affect just the brain
capacity yeah but as a commentator I'm
not allowed to open my window because I
live in New York City and there are
Sirens everywhere yeah so anytime even
with my window closed you hear the
ambulances coming by so I don't have an
option so I don't want to know what the
answer is if I should open my window
because my producers they don't live
they should let you open the window oh
all right well well the players have
good air quality they need it because
it's good and quite intense and the
other things monsters these are the
results so far today in the winners
semi-finals Magnus Carlsen is in the
lead winning the first game Arjun area
guys you put on a good fight in game two
but it was a draw and he has to win
either game three or game four to take
this one to Armageddon Wesley saw any
car Nakamura they are still tied two
draws so far in that matchup
what has that much have been like is it
intense is it fighting it's high level
chess not the most adventurous games but
both players are very solid they're just
testing each other out there have been
very minimal advantages for each player
in the two games so we'll see what game
three has in store but so far there's
nothing separating those two yeah we're
gonna follow the next uh game from the
start between Magnus and Arjun Air Guys
the if Magnus wins this game he will be
the winner of the match Arjun cannot
lose this next game they have played
each other a bunch of times on the
Champions Chester over the past two
seasons and it's very one-sided 10 wins
for Magnus Carlson yeah ten to one
indecisive games that is huge and it
looks like Magnus Carlsen is a regards
his Kryptonite he's everyone's
Kryptonite let's be honest but uh yeah
everybody needs to get over that mental
block it feels like that last game some
huge chances especially that uh one
opportunity with Knight takes C6 but
somehow Eric Icy not able to finish him
off not able to put the finishing
touches on these decent games that he's
playing but it's going to be a challenge
though first of all he needs to survive
this one with black and missing those
opportunities is exactly what makes that
mental block even deeper in your mind
that when you get a good position you
still are not able to make the most of
it but you've got liftoff and an English
opening this time by Magnus I'm happy
about that very patriotic uh thanks
Magnus English opening but it will of
course transpose maybe to the Queen's
gamber decline to a bunch of different
lines depending on what Magnus is
feeling right now and the triangle
system for black uh kind of hybrid
between the slav and the Queen's Gambit
declined and okay now the players after
this pawn exchange will head into a
Carlsbad structure Magnus is maybe the
world leading expert on the plans for
both white and black in this type of
setup but the game definitely takes on a
quieter nature after this last couple of
moves Robert do you think Magnus is just
in a peaceful mood here or is he gonna
try and
end the match now it's funny because as
we look at this opening I'm used to
seeing mags having the black side of
this position famous games against
Vladimir krumnik and many other top
players but I think that Magnus he
doesn't need to really do much of
anything he's not forced to play for a
result he can just play his moves he's
playing a stable opening and the
pressure is all An Origin I we do
acknowledge that origin in game two had
a quite a sizable Advantage but that
missed tactic that was really the one
major chance to win the game I just feel
like Magnus has nothing to worry about
from the perspective that he is the best
player in the world he is Magnus Carlson
last time I checked so he doesn't need
to take any risk he can just play his
normal stuff
but I like what arjun's done David now
even with the black pieces he is trying
to create an imbalance in the position
or at least asking Magnus does he want
to trade that Bishop for the Knight very
often that's what ends up creating a
messy middle game so Knight H5 and now
the ball is in magnus's court does he
trade this bishop for the night yeah
Arjun is also saying I'm in preparation
you aren't and uh 15 minutes he's
actually gained a few seconds since the
start of the game Arjun this last night
move planting a knight on the edge of
the board we've seen it backfire several
times on the tour you only want to put a
knight on the edge if you're 100 sure it
actually achieves something but you're
saying to Magnus okay I've looked at
this I've worked out the consequences of
any potential minor peace traits and uh
Magnus now is going in the tank just to
try and find a way to get Arjun out of
that prep and uh yeah a bunch of moves
here we most likely will see white
having to part with the bishop pair but
who's that gonna favor it is a very
locked Pawn structure in the center so
it's not clear here necessarily the
Bishops are superior tonight we had that
debate earlier but let's keep an open
mind for this one and this is a super
rare move I've got about seven options
that black has that has been played a
couple of times and light H5 doesn't
figure anywhere you could have improved
the Queen's position to B6 hitting that
B2 Pawn taken out the other Knight
developed it to D7 uh improved the
position of his King side Bishop
continued to develop it he moves the
same piece twice brings the Knight to
the edge of the board and this is why
Magnus is going into a thing tank
because he's never seen this before it's
a new move by Arjun and you're right it
looks like it's part of his prep yeah
just the breadth of his knowledge Eric I
see he's so young but he knows things
about every different kind of side
variation of every opening it's uh yeah
I'm very very impressed whoever is
coaches I want to learn he impressed
viciana in the title still India events
where they were analyzing a game and but
she looks at him was like are you not
done with your preparation and RJ went
like 10 moves deeper and has already
moved 30. so it's clear that he knows
what he's doing in a variety of openings
we've just seen that Knight capture the
bishop and then the White Knight
captured Black's light score Bishop so
if we take stock of the current position
white with a light Square Bishop black
with a dark Square bishop and you
typically you want to put pressure in
the direction of your pawns so black has
this Pawn Jane from B7 C6 D5 we see
those three Pawns in a line there and
white has the pawns from F2 to D4 so
black may be trying to make inroads
towards the center of the board on the
king side whereas white May angle
towards the queen side it's that Carl's
bod structure oftentimes white tries to
push pawns forward with B4 and B5 when
the time is right yeah I'm having fun
with arrows there Robert but essentially
those are the plants uh White often
starts a minority attack later you're
actually playing on the side where you
have fewer pawns whereas black often
tries to play on the king side or in the
center and meanwhile Magnus as well
going for just basic strategy here if
you have a light Square Bishop put your
pawns on Dart squares so you control
both color complexes and uh yeah just
very balanced so far I don't think Eric
I see is upset at all with the outcome
of the opening it looks like he's
achieved a solid base from here it's
going to be very difficult to outplay
the world number one because Magnus as
we mentioned very experienced in this
type of Pawn structure but uh yeah he
survives the opening no problems at all
last time we checked in an opposite
color Bishop position Arjun had a
massive problem so he definitely needs
to make sure he doesn't allow a big
attack on the king's side very often
when there are major pieces on the board
and you've got Bishops of different
colors you have to watch out for
attacking ideas that Knight on F5 needs
to be kicked out at some point you need
to make sure that white doesn't set up a
battery on the b187 diagonal and starts
targeting your king Arjun cannot go all
out in this game he has to at least try
to get a game four because that's when
he'll have the white pieces he can then
throw the kitchen sink Magnus he needs
to make sure this one doesn't go too
wrong yeah
yeah on breaks you can go for later and
uh yeah
technically kind of on paper at least
this should be up magnus's alley let's
see if Arjun after a bit of thought now
can find a way an effective way to place
his pieces he needs to make a decision
does he kick out the Knight now or does
he improve the position of his other
night maybe get it to F6 I don't see a
great Square for the bishop right now to
be taken out he could potentially also
develop the bishop so what approach is
he going to take will he go for the more
direct G6 that you were pointing out
yeah I don't know what he's hesitating I
would want to pick that white knight out
of my camp and out of my half of the
boat as quickly as possible and he has
eventually done it meanwhile I was
checking out the air quality here in
Oslo it's like we're okay yeah we're
good are you guys feeling healthy yeah
good and uh yeah Magnus meanwhile
retreating all the way back with his
Knight slightly surprising but uh he's
just looking for fresher pastures does
it seem like Magnus who knows that with
a win in this game he's going to win the
match is he going for a win in this
match is it possible to tell by the way
he's playing I think he was called off
guard so I think right now he's just
trying to right the ship because in the
opening origin played something very
rare and now he just has a stable
position but I do like arjun's position
from the point of view that he sort of
controls some of the pawn breaks that
look at the bishop on the light Square
staring into all of Black's pawns
nothing there the dark Square Bishop for
black and from the King it is slicing
across the board so at some point there
will be tension between the pawns once
the C6 Pawn goes up to C5 so I typically
say the side that controls the pawn
breaks inside of the advantage I feel
like Black's pawns are a little bit more
mobile and especially the queen side
pawns they can start moving forward and
meanwhile Magnus is paused which means
he's about to make a big decision and I
think that's to do with his King is he
going to Castle on the king so light and
just initiate that quieter game with
minimal risk or is he gonna maybe I
hesitate to say it Castle the other way
because that's where Black's Bishop is
pointing as Robert mentions you tend not
to want to Castle on the side where your
opponent's pieces are ready to pounce
and I think black could exploit that by
opening lines I think Magnus as well
could just consider not castling as I
say it
I was going to say just leave it as long
as possible play a bit of a waiting game
keep your opponent guessing but he does
commit and uh that's due to the match
situation he's a point up no need for
Unnecessary risks so do you think he
would have gone the other way if he was
down a point in the match it feels a bit
too risky but at least he would have
maybe hesitated or left it as long as
possible you could have made an argument
what I was going to say a bit earlier is
you could throw Harry the H porn up the
board especially this fianchetto porn
formation that black has in front of his
king that's often a signal to go and
attack but meanwhile we mentioned
playing on opposite sides of the board
normally white plays on The Queen side
black plays on the center every guy sees
making a mockery of us this B5 Pawn push
it's strategically extremely risky
Robert well that's a move that you can't
take back and you could regret depending
on what happens here look at Magnus
quickly replying bringing his Rook
aiming towards his backwards Pawn on C6
a pawn chain is only as strong as his
base Pawn there was a pawn back on B7
just a turn to go and now the C6 Pawn
becomes the base pawn and it's much
easier to Target so I think that Arjun
has fitting the pressure of the match he
made a move like B5 If This Were a
tournament game round one of a long
Swiss tournament or something like that
or even a long-term like Vikings yeah
I'm black I'm making a solid effort here
let's just hold the position but I think
he feels like he must play for more but
that could play to Max's benefit and we
see Magnus throwing his H Pawn up the
board so we see Arjun play with Barry
then we see Magnus play with Harry and
that pawn going up to H5 could be
dangerous for black yeah I'd rather be
playing with Harry right now because
white has a clear plan of attack you
step your king forward at some point
maybe you shift your Rook across back to
the H file to attack and uh support a
pawn push over there meanwhile yeah
where are these Pawns going if you ever
step forward with this Pawn the White
Knight actually happily lands on the
edge of the board and potential outposts
for it later and maybe this is what Eric
icy is going to have to go for just to
break out and just completely it explode
the center to open up his Bishop it
takes a bit of risk but uh you want to
activate this piece instead he's keeping
the tension advancing all of his bones
it's not clear what that's achieving
it's got to be said but uh yeah it's at
least aesthetically pleasing that black
is throwing pawns forward so yeah very
much influenced by the match situation
but not necessarily that effective
all right this is uh game three between
these two in the winners semi-final
there is another winner semi-final match
going on Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura they have played two draws so
far and are tied
what does it look like in game three
I've got to say it looks like deja vu
it's exactly the same opening they had
in game one of the day which was a very
balanced draw maybe Wesley had slightly
the better chances in that game but uh
both players have come back to the board
with small improvements uh Wesley set up
his pieces in a different way but same
port structure equally tense and very
balanced at the moment okay so we should
stay on this game for now for now yeah
at least the other match is guaranteed
to game four Magnus if he wins this one
yeah he'd end it here and now
and Magnus thinking after black has
advanced that Bond gained so much space
on the queen side I think what he's
considering right now is does he
continue with Harry the H Pawn is H5 a
move that Magnus is looking at because
that's clearly what he was hinting
towards but another plan that he comes
up with is to first move the king
forward so that the Rook can join into
the attack from the h file just sliding
down to that H1 Square because once the
H file opens that Bishop on D3 and that
Rook on H1 will be eyeing the black king
with big trouble I think for Arjun he
needs to break in the center as soon as
possible he needs to try to get the C5
break in and the only way that's going
to happen David is if he advances the B
Pawn to B4 hit that Knight so that it's
not hanging anymore once the Knight is
out of the way get that C5 break in open
the center yep Kick That Knight away and
uh I'm not sure what the C Pawn is
called Charlie
I used to live in a place called Barry
so I think starting with Barry the B
Pawn is the way to go and uh carry the
seat Pawn Yeah Yeah carry
that movie is a classic but you don't
want to be on the receiving end so after
C5 the point is the bishop one G7 sees a
new lease on life opening across the
diagonal but we've talked about the
isolated Queen Pawn a number of times
that if there is a trade of D4 for C5 at
some moment the D5 Pawn will be left
behind the good news though is that
Bishop on G7 becomes extremely powerful
and the bishop on D3 still doesn't have
a great home or a great diagonal to work
with so this would lead to it a good
activity for the black pieces and you
have to like that if you're all generic
icy yeah he's hesitating it feels like
you might get another opportunity but
you might as well go for it now and uh
what is forcing him to think step this
Pawn forward I say going this way you
could also go to the edge of the board
and this would result in a couple of
extra trades perhaps after uh Paul takes
porn we'll see a set of knights come off
the board and still the points remain
still this bishop is superior to its
counterpart on this nice long diagonal
yes you've got an isolated Pawn but it's
not the end of the world it's like to
make a move yeah he's about to make a
move he reached out for the mouse and he
makes it he goes with the queen movie
first sidesteps with the queen to E7 so
still keeping this option open of going
B4 to C5 but I'm just wondering if Arjun
is playing just a little 2kg just a
little too cautious yeah
I think he maybe sees the clock Magnus
has been burning a bit of time a couple
of minutes down there and he says okay
I'll keep the tension uh normally if
you're in must win situations which Eric
I see is almost in then you just want to
force your opponent to kind of stay in
their own head don't give them forced
decisions don't give them one or two
obvious moves at least uh make them
think on their own two feet and after a
while the White Knight drops back at
least now it's impossible to push carry
because Barry would then be on priest
but I do think this was a little bit
aimless from uh origin here because now
if you do want to push the C Pawn you
have to first push your beep on as we're
talking about but as soon as you play B4
it doesn't come with a Tempo the Knight
has already moved out of the way and
anytime you push upon you leave some
squares behind that B5 Pawn is covering
the light squares and the queen that
sits on D1 back at home will venture
into the black camp start attacking some
of the pawns so it's a big moment for
origin I don't think he can afford to
sit and do nothing because White's plan
with H4 to H5 throwing that pawn forward
bring the Rook behind it opening it up
for an attack it seems very clear I
don't see Clarity in Black's position
whatsoever whatso all whatsoever at all
one of those pick one but either way I
do think that white is about to take
advantage of some squares Left Behind
whoa and Robert he goes for the move
nevertheless and I think we have to
point out the move that you mentioned
there because it looks critical now to
White's trances uh you have loosened up
some light Square some serious
weaknesses either we can come in with a
bishop maybe attack The Rook or as you
mentioned drop the queen in to this
newly created Outpost and some serious
targets for the White Queen attacking
this Pawn of course uh ganging up
against this Pawn I guess the idea is to
just continue marching down the board
ignoring uh that maybe a pawn will drop
just to create a pawn Mass on the queen
side but uh yeah risky stuff from Arjun
meanwhile Magnus isn't obliged to look
at that side of the board even he could
continue push Harry the H Pawn forward
open that line for the white Rook you're
about to get an open file towards the
black king another um this is my
favorite Pawn structure I've got to
confess I mentioned I love the bishopath
the only thing I love equally as much as
the bishop hair is double death pawns
for black and for white and to play
Knight to F4 hoping for a trade and yes
it looked like I worsen my pawns but
actually I've opened up a line for my
Rook I've created a nice Outpost for my
knight on E5 supported by two strong
pawns and actually I've gained extra
Pawn cover for the white king and Magnus
goes for this he plays Knight F4 this is
very thematic in lots of different
openings than the Catalan and queen's
gambits in the caricon a bunch of
different openings and uh Magnus he's
hoping for a trade he's also said to
Eric I see yes you can break with Carrie
but you can't do it now I've prevented
you at least one more move because
suddenly this Pawn would be undefended
David the Deep one
it's probably not David but but yeah
he's making life difficult the knights
are off the board Magnus has my favorite
porn structure but uh will he be able to
turn this in his favor everybody though
has broken out and how scary is this
that Carrie is advancing
well it was the only break in the
position for black he had to make it and
I think it's all going to be about how
big a temple was that queen move for
Arjun should he have stopped this
nitrate on F4 because it just looks like
it's coming but with a little less power
now and white has got this idea of
advancing Harry the H Pawn as we've been
screaming but he can also win a tempo
right now with the E file open The Rook
can slide over to the open file attack
the queen rookie one and you've still
got to find a good Square for that Queen
because let's say you step over in front
of your Bishop David then the idea of
White's Knight jumping forward becomes a
big threat in the position yeah attack
the queen ask that awkward question to
her and as you mentioned you don't
really want to block your Bishop because
the Knight can step in and the trade
here will allow white a very nice
Advanced pawn and uh A Change Report
structure here for example well maybe
white just winter porn but at the very
least you isolate this guy uh David
Again David no mates at the isolated
Pawn in the center and uh yeah looking
very good for white I've got to say this
move is almost automatic what else could
Magnus be considering is he just going
to ignore the tension perhaps he could
for example just push a pawn I don't
think you want to allow black to connect
four and to continue advancing it's just
very very intense right now but it feels
like momentum is on magnus's side five
minutes though against nine and a half
he's got to speed up uh Eric I see at
least doing the right things breaking
out asking questions
he might build attention further with
the move H5 and then it's really all
about who wins the spawn race I have no
doubt that Arjun wants to keep marching
down with that c Pawn try to maybe
create a passer already and meanwhile I
don't see a clear attack on the king
side but things could get out of hand
very quickly on on the open H line yeah
uh Magnus somehow he hates allowing his
opponent long-term Trump cards like that
and if he allows the black pawn to
advance all end games will be favorable
for black so it feels like Magnus will
want to avoid that certainly that idea
is up in sleeve and it's going to come
soon but uh maybe he'll take your time
out first but it's interesting because
he was the one who invited it he brought
his Knight to F4 and after the trade he
doubled his own Pawn so if he didn't
like that he made an interesting
previous move to offer that exchange so
I do think he had oh wow he pushes F
Pawn so he kind of double Pawn he
doesn't like the double Pawn but the
pressure on the D4 Square behind it the
pawn on B2 that's what led him to leave
the pawns as they were he does not want
to open up that great Bishop on G7
instead he's going for the attack in a
different way and here's the big
question if black pushes the pawn
forward to C4 that releases the tension
in the center the bishop can slide back
all the way to B1 or even to C2 I'm not
sure which is better but the files
remain closed that's good for the
attacking side because when you're being
attacked you're gonna open up the center
here at the center will be closed yeah
and then Magnus would go in that attack
I think Tania was completely right there
I I'm surprised I must say that Magnus
went for this decision because now black
does have this long-term advantage of
these two very scary Advanced pawns uh
but he's not playing for long-term
factors he's playing short term going on
the attack towards the black king note
how it's four versus three on the king
side in terms of Pawns and once we
eliminate this Pawn far less shelter for
that black Monarch so uh yeah very tense
some surprising decision decisions for
both sides especially for Magnus on this
last uh last turn four and a half now
against eight and a half minutes could
the clock play a Factor last time he
left it very late Magnus he went down to
his final few seconds could we see a
repeat and very important for Arjun here
to not pick up that Free Pawn on D4 now
it looks like you're just winning a ball
in a Central Pawn but it's really here
you know you have to focus on as Jovi
says quality over quantity don't pick up
that Bond because once you trade it
white gets a free hand your Bishop on G7
is blocked white can trade off pick up
that broken see it and let's just show
that line because it's so instructive to
not get greedy here David oh you pick up
that rook and see it you pick up that
pawn on G6 create a weakness on the king
side and then just go H5 March in and
what is that Bishop on G7 doing it's
absolutely dead the D4 and the D5 pawn
mean nothing at all and this would be a
happy position for Magnus extremely
happy you could even temporarily go down
two pawns but look at the black
structure doubled and isolated pawns
here isolated Pawn isolated pawn and uh
more importantly this bishop on an open
diagonal far superior to its counterpart
White's Knight will just jump in landing
on this night uh this night on F5 where
it will definitely Thrive uh the White
Queen will join the attack everything is
in white trailer yeah this is beyond uh
uh Beyond contemplating here you cannot
allow this for arrogacy so greed is not
good in this position as you mentioned
Tanya it'll be what you call
compensation uh you know that term is
often vague what does that mean someone
has extra material but they have
compensation that would be very
clear-cut the white would just control
the Dynamics of the position so we see
Argent thinking here it is a critical
Choice he has been ahead on the clock
his lead on the clock has now been
halved and he's thinking do I take undo4
do I leave the pawn C5 do I push into C4
not an easy question to answer because
where's the build up what's the
improving move if he slides a rook from
f8 to E8 yes that's an open file but
you're not actually accomplishing
anything because white has all of those
squares under his control and let's not
forget that at some point H5 is going to
hit you and you need pieces around your
king so I think that Arjun is doing the
right thing here to really consider and
weigh his options but he's taking too
much time and I'm getting a little
worried on the clock we've seen that
come to haunt him in the last game in a
good position when he was well close to
actually taking the point just not
having enough time to convert that win
and when you're playing against Magnus
you really cannot spend this much time
on a move and if we didn't know who the
players were if we didn't know the clock
which side would you guys take right now
white or black wow okay I think after f
happy to take black right now as long as
I'm not playing Magnuson look at did he
just decide to pick up the pawn on D4
it's exactly what we said not to do
Tanya as soon as you said you'd prefer
the black pieces
[Laughter]
any move you hated oh my gosh we've seen
this exact variation the Rooks were
traded no H5 on the board no this is a
big problem I mean unless Arjun sees
some direct way to trade pieces off and
save his King the thread is clear just
Pawn takes Pawn on G6 will win white
upon and if you take on H5 we already
showed the variation the White Knight
could hop in uh the black king is
exposed so it's a that was a decision
that Arjun I don't think he made easily
I think he kind of was unhappy with some
of his choices anything that he could
have done would have given Magnus some
play on the king side but this looks
very straightforward for the world
champion yeah again it feels influenced
slightly by the match situation at least
where he's grabbing a pawn he's hoping
to survive the oncoming Onslaught and uh
then he might be a pulling up as black
but
will you survive that long it's uh it's
a very very big question and white has
such natural moves it's so difficult to
play especially in speed chess we say
that it's easier to attack than defend
here it's certainly white attacking on
the light squares that color complex is
all his uh magnuses right now White's
Rook is going to slide across to the H
file why tonight is jumping forward as
we said how does black defend you need a
bunch of time to try and even figure out
uh the foundations of the defense here
for black you have to go move by move
but
with these opposite color Bishops where
which proved his downfall actually in
the first game today
hard to find any advice for him once
that H Pawn is done on H5 I will
definitely pick white every day of the
year this is such a difficult position
and the fact that Arjun took so long to
capture that pawn on D4 and then once
again goes into a think tank is not good
news for the Indian fans and I think
Magnus almost looked like he was on
pre-move mode you know when he took on
D4 he immediately snapped up The Rook he
immediately snapped up the G6 spawn blew
out H5 on the board and sure Arjun can
be two pawns up but he's going to be a
king down if he picks up that H5 Bond
it's going to be suffering and he tries
to plug the horse in his King side with
his queen queen F6 holding together a
Pawn on G6 he's defending everything but
a trade only loosens the light squares I
imagine the White Queen coming in at
some point she can try a few different
angles to try and get towards that black
king look at the black King's diagonals
they're all on light squares and there
we go just occupying the open E file
first of all and controlling some
squares there very flexible with the
white Rook White Knight save enough
later just a nice little Queenie too
because it's multi-directional like
black can try to bring that Knight
forward to C5 to attack the bishop The
Rook can slide over to pin that Knight
on the C file so the queen slides out of
the Rooks path it makes use of the
default maybe there's an exchange
sacrifice in the works if you take that
Knight with your rook and bring that
blackwork off the last rank there could
be some danger for the black king so
that is not out of the question at all
the G6 Pawn is a target the white king
is perfectly safe and no risk whatsoever
the black king it's exposed and the
white Rook as we're mentioning go to H1
it can slide over to D1 at some point or
C1 or E1 a black has way too much to
look out for yeah still an ugly
structure you might be one point up but
actually this one you wants it out of
the way you want it out of the way of
your queen of Bishop on this uh diagonal
it's just blocking up your own position
clogging up your play and now down on
time for the first time really uh and
Eric I see in this game and he's
starting to realize the consequences of
his greed earlier we said greed was not
good and it really has backfired now he
just has to somehow cling on maybe he
just has to put a knight on f8 at some
point the rhyme goes Knight and f8 there
is no mate but the rest of your
opposition might collapse uh instead he
does go for Knight C5 and now Robert
your move looks extremely strong pinning
that Knight
don't see any downside to that what is
the plan suddenly some awkward tactics
along this file Magnus goes for it
instantly and he's in the flow Madness
yet again uh as soon as that turn in the
position happened he's played every move
instantly he knows that Nakamura advice
that I was giving everyone before that
you need to play good moves quickly in
these kind of time controls and it might
have been the best move but look at
arjun's Clark now he's the one down
under three minutes his King is exposed
he did just play Bishop to f8 a very
good move that frees up his Rook
unseated because he defended his Knight
but still the problems persist for our
generic icy even if he's eventually able
to take this bishop on D3 he's left with
the worst minor piece and his King
Remains the problem so I think that
Magnus he can build on his Advantage
right now but he needs to keep a lead on
the clock as well yeah he's still pinned
Derek I see so Magnus has a move or two
to create some threats maybe you can
approve the White Queen the White Knight
you want to look at your pieces and
think how can I cause damage to that
black king side but uh yeah it's all
about the clock as well and Magnus won't
want to repeat of that last game where
his uh yeah he was really suffering on
the clock went down to two or three
seconds when he played that crucial only
move yeah we're the winning this game
Magnus Carlsen will win the match uh our
guys he needs at least a draw to take it
to a game four the other winner
semi-final match Wesley so against
Hikaru Nakamura they have now played
three draws they are still tied
it's all going down to game for if we
have a winner in that game that will be
the winner of the match if it is another
draw then we will see another Armageddon
today
yeah meanwhile Magnus playing a bit of a
strange move retreating the white Bishop
it might well just get locked in on that
square if you're not careful you've also
released the blockade of Black's Central
Double D pawns and uh Rook C7 there just
at least putting the Rook on a dark
Square going for that dark Square uh
control unpinning his piece the Black
Knight now might be free to retreat
what do you think some chances of saving
this Pharaoh see or is it just long-term
suffering that last move by our turn
makes it so tricky because he's also
threatening to put the Rook on the open
E file surviving that bin hitting that
Queen and then we'll see this Knight
jumping onto the center of the board so
magnesium needs to be careful it's a
little telling that our silicon friend
eval bar seems to say that white is fine
now generally the bar loves material
right but here despite being upon down
it says that white is still doing fine
but this is tricky stuff now and Knight
to H4 so really freeing up the path for
the queen so that if black was to
threaten on the E file then white has
the option to actually jump over to G4
and Target that weak G6 spawn yeah
White's Queen has been opened up and uh
direct threat against the pawn next to
the black queen on G6 White's Bishop
yeah I just love Bishops it has a
long-range piece here poaching from afar
and it's still hard to see any way that
black Will Survive the oncoming attack
I'm surprised the evaluation Bar's
roughly in the middle I've got to say
because it feels so pleasant for white
it's one of these positions where the
evaluation board does not tell the story
uh you see it hovering in the middle
that means with objective best Play Our
Generation can hold this game but look
at this there's a knight and a bishop
staring towards he makes the move G5 and
wow that is a huge decision because he
allows that white knight to hop forward
in front of the black queen take over
the light Square so all of the light
squares are whites for the taking but he
is defending he's making sure he's not
giving up that pawn a huge decision with
just over two minutes remaining for our
generic guys see I think the White Queen
should step in front of that pawn
pinning it towards the black king and
just trying to bring your pieces closer
to the enemy camp wow and Robert there
is some mad tactics after G5 Knight F5
that we were mentioning was so tempting
but I think D3 was something that Magnus
didn't like really blocking that
Bishop's defense of the night and the
tactics just seem to work out for black
hair inside Magnus going for the other
idea that we were mentioning of getting
that Queen to G4 pinning that pawn so
you still can't pick up the H4 Knight as
the king is pinned yeah and next move
Magnus can either go back to try and win
this Pawn the last shelter for the black
king or he can jump into that beautiful
Square on F5 now that it's a bit safer
black does have this past Pawn however
and he has at least temporarily locked
in this white Bishop but Magnus Retreats
there are threats including Bishop takes
Pawn due to the fact that black knight
is pinned cannot recapture but also
swinging across with a white Rook you
could swing over and start going for the
black king right now
very very tense Arjun he's still alive
he's still got counter chances while
this Pawn is on the board but yeah
definitely from a human point of view so
much easier to play with white yeah
keyword while the phrase while that
part's on the board White's next move
might be the simple Rook over one square
to go ahead and win the pawn it's not
about this B2 pawn and things like that
that's irrelevant I like the move Rook
D1 just get rid of that pawn the
problems persist in Blast Camp white is
so safe and sound the king Knight and
queen they make sure that everything is
nice and compact nothing is hanging here
I think Rook sliding over to D1 is a
good choice right now just get rid of
the biggest thorn in your side yeah some
point sometimes the simple approach is
the also the strongest one and uh Rook
D1 guaranteed to win this Pawn back next
and the black's Position will collapse
long term both sides around one minute
though will Magnus go for this he often
looks for something a bit more
sophisticated uh which probably isn't on
the docket right now I think you should
just be eliminating that one source of
counterplay for black both looking very
calm how are they doing inside right now
Robert especially Arjun aragaisy you're
super nervous because this is one of
those games that's about 50 50 like all
three results are possible and so for
origin this is his chance he knows that
he doesn't want to rely on a win in game
four uh with mags in time travel he can
make the most of it here yeah
wow taking to one minute now Arjun era
guys he cannot lose this game he needs a
win in this one or the next one to take
it to Armageddon
Magnus made a bit of a face we've got to
say just for a second he uh quickly got
rid of all his emotions again but he
just for a moment he looked unhappy with
something I'm not sure whether it's his
last move he played his Pawn forward one
square a bit of a nothing move just a
bit of a cagey cautious one there and it
has given black the time to slide across
with the queen threatening a potential
Queen exchange if the black queen lands
on e4 in the center of the board if the
Queen's disappear black should be
relatively safe
with the Kings as they are Black's
King's so weak out in the open a queen
exchange is what every guys he's
dreaming of right now white needs to
stop that threat it needs to stop the
black queen from coming to E4 because a
trade on that will also solve the bond
structure problem Magnus does it with
Rook to E1 and now it just looks like
the momentum is slightly shifting
towards archon he does offer a rook
trade the pawn on D3 is still alive very
importantly once the Rooks are traded
off let's say you go rookie seven the
bishop takes it off and Magnus says no
trade because that would make Black's
life so much easier let's say you go
Queen D4 black can come in to to E4
offering that trade and this is bad news
for Magnus Magnus steps back with the
Rook uh to D1 and it just looks like
arjun's done everything right can he
well he can't go Queen E4 right now uh
David because the G5 Pawn is hanging
with check or can you the evaluation bar
we see that
he's played it he's gone in Black's
favorite the bar here and Magnus maybe
not realizing the strength of this pin
yes you can take a pawn restore the
material balance but after the black
Rook blocks this check suddenly where
does your queen go no attractive squares
and uh maybe you just slide one square
across suddenly there are all sorts of
night jumps and the Knights threatening
to come in with a check uh hitting the
king remember this Pawn in front of it
it's pinned big attack suddenly brewing
and this is the position yeah and
Origins I think all the best moves
Knight F4 check is a winning threat and
you see the evaluation bar dipping in
origin aragice's favor that white king
is suddenly the more exposed one of the
two the bishop on B1 is a bystander not
doing anything and Magnus slides his
King back to G1 so Knight F4 doesn't
come with a fork but it still is a
playable move attacking the Queen the G3
Pawn is pinned and we see that Knight F4
is indeed the best move with a winning
Advantage for black Wow Let's go back to
the game will he find his this move will
he plant his Knight on this powerful
Square it looks like he's gone for
something else no he attacked the queen
with his Rook instead not strong letting
Magnus back in the game perhaps and
while a quick few moves there the
knights have been traded off but a
Checkmate threat on the board Black's
Rook or blacks Queen want to jump in to
the H1 Square three seconds for Arjun
yeah Checkmate was threatened but no
longer the blackbrook forced away from
the open H file can Magnus defend maybe
survive the worst playing with seconds
Magnus Carlsen is struggling on the
clock yep six seconds against eight
there's gonna be blunders there's going
to be mistakes they're only human but
the Queens are off the board this is
great news for Arjun aragaisy look at
that black porn in the center it's tying
down the white rook and the white Bishop
he's essentially playing up a piece and
Magnus gesturing
the game
arjun's gonna strike back wow what a
turnaround this is with the black pieces
David which means he goes into the final
round with white but there's still work
to be done it's not over till it's over
against the world champion but this game
is over because Magnus just resigned our
generic I see wins and we have a level
match
wow that is huge our generic YC strikes
backs he ties the match before the
fourth and final rapid game Magnus
Carlsen loses his first game of the
Champions chess tour 2023 season
what is your reaction to that Robert I
don't know how to feel it just happened
it was surprising it was a bullet
scramble and this is Arjun aragaisy at
his best he knows how to play When the
clock is ticking on his final seconds he
kept the Queens on the board offered a
trade at the right moment and he made
Magnus come up with the tough Solutions
and the world champion the number one
player in the world he was unable to so
an earned Victory a career victory for
ardu generag icy I mean India must be
celebrating 19 year old everybody eats
Magnus Carlsen in a crucial game how
impressed are you with him now Tanya
this is a big moment just the way he did
it was just so impressive uh Kaya the
way he played the last few moves
especially keeping the tension and the
pressure on the board forcing Magnus
into Muddy Waters and that's where he
went wrong it was just impressive start
to finish with this he levels the score
goes into the final game with the white
pieces big moment for India and crazy
stuff going on in that third game what
happened in the end there David and it
was all a turnaround we were favoring
White's position we thought that Magnus
had everything under control it looked
very good for white but this was the key
move offering a queen trade sacrificing
willingly this black porn and after it
was captured suddenly it was black on
the attack attacking the White Queen and
as we saw going for the white king too
just to fast forward white survived
Magnus survived to an end game but uh
this one was simply hopeless these two
black pawns too strong the bishop about
to come in and Magnus made a further
mistake and lost it very quickly
self-destructing but well played to our
generic I see getting the win
welcome to Landover a kitten inspired
hexagon resource game for up to four
players
feature-rich map Builder to create
unique and creative Maps host or join
custom games where you can play live for
daily games with friends other Landover
community members or even solo games
against the Landover Bots
choose your initial settlements wisely
and then outweigh your opponents to
expand your Empire
more Villages and cities means more
resources for you to build outward and
upward
use landover's unique trade to build UI
to quickly and easily build whatever you
can afford
raise up the culture Tech Tree to gain
additional abilities collect depth cards
and grab the all-powerful Metropolis
don't forget to upgrade your military to
defend against the impending Barbarian
attacks and launch raids against other
players
prove yourself in rated games to earn
promotions and climb to the top of the
ladder
download Landover for free at
landover.io available on Android iPhone
and browsers
we're gonna head into a quick twitch
break if you're not a subscriber for
everyone else oh we're building up to
the final game in the rapid portion and
the winner of semi-finals
foreign
[Music]
how do you imagine our generic icy is
feeling now after beating Magnus Falls
he's in Cloud number nine and uh well
and also he has to be very careful now
because he can't be too happy because he
still has one game left to play and
Magnus he did look like he was flexing
early on you know it looked like he was
a supreme form but they do say Pride
become pride comes before a fall and
there you go there's his full and Magnus
will be raging so Eric I see if he wants
to take it to Armageddon Armageddon he
just has to hold tight yeah but uh if he
wants more then uh go for it yeah why
not yeah they are tied before the fourth
and final rapid game in the winner
semi-final in the other one Wesley saw a
nicaro Nakamura three drawers how will
you describe this matchup so far Mind
Games these guys are just messing with
each other just mentally because because
I have to say still Advantage Wesley
because Wesley of course had that
critical first game where he put Hikaru
on the back foot but these two other
games I mean it just seems like Hikaru
is getting nowhere and the last white
encounter with sorry in Wesley's last
white encounter he didn't really get
much either and Hikaru just managed to
wriggle through now Hikaru has the white
pieces and it's going to be crunch time
now yeah
wow it's not unlikely that we will see
Armageddon and the winner is semi-finals
but first the fourth and final rapid
games are coming up very shortly
we've got liftoff and an English opening
this time by Magnus oh and Robert he
goes to the move you have loosened up
some light Square some serious
weaknesses he tries to plug the horse in
his King's side with his Queen he makes
the move G5 and wow a huge decision with
just over two minutes remaining for our
generic icy
what a day
yes and these are the results so far in
the winner is semi-finals Magnus Carlsen
won the first one but Arjun erag I see
striking back in fantastic fashion and
game three they are tied heading into
game four Wesley Seoul and hikar
Nakamura also tied three draws game four
is starting in only a few seconds what
do you think David will we see armaged
on chess in the winner semifinals yes
and uh I think we will see it in between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura just
because they're both so good they're
canceling each other out they're playing
really high quality chess right now but
uh also this one
depends on Audrey now regice's approach
if he goes for it he might well have a
decent shot at Magnus especially while
Magnus is recovering from that that last
disaster but if I regret he wants the
draw I think Magnus actually would be
happy to just survive this game and take
it to those armageddon's if you if you
were arjun's coach Robert what would you
advise him to heading into this final
game with the white pizzas to find a new
coach
a good one but I do think that he should
play it relatively safe because Arjun
had the white pieces against Magnus
Carlson in tata Steel in her classical
time Patrol Magnus won with black so
there are no guarantees just because
you're the first move advantage that
everything is safe and well you want the
toss-up as the lower rated player I
think he wants to head to Armageddon you
don't know what the bidding is going to
be I don't even know what color either
player wants but I think that you want
to send this to armor again if you're
urgent and guys I think we're about to
get an Armageddon confirmed because uh
the game between Nakamura and so is
racing towards a draw I think it's going
to be confirmed any second now there we
go 2-2 that game was a Berlin draw the
Infamous game that's actually we
predicted here on the show yeah that's
true so if you did follow us from the
get-go today uh David did put up a
little bit of a hint in the studio uh on
the chessboard that we have in in the
studio and you were correct yeah it was
bound to happen these guys have played
the same exact draw plenty of times in
the past and it makes sense for both of
them to conserve energy it's going to
become down now to that Armageddon game
and uh who will be faster simply I think
they both want the black pieces my guess
they keep drawing right so you want you
don't have to win in that game
incredible so
right now Nakamura and Wesley so we'll
make their bids for the Armageddon and
the player with the lowest bid can
choose colors and will play with that
time usually they will then choose to
play with the black pieces and with the
black pieces you will win the match with
a draw or win the player with the white
pieces has to win but first this game
has to finish so they have to wait for
Magnus Carlsen and Arjun aragaisy to
finish their game if this is a draw
these two as well will head to
Armageddon yeah and this is a very
topical branch of the nimso Indian
defense it's an isolated Queen spawn
that seems to be another theme of the
day keeps cropping up everywhere and
this time it's Eric icy with the
isolated Pawn in the center black has a
nice blockade of blacks Knight on D5
Rock Solid well fortified but a small
threat there from him on the last move
White Queen the white Bishop did create
that battery forcing black to commit on
the king side there are some holes
around the black king especially on the
dark squares Canada guys you take
advantage of that if not then Magnus has
a very solid position
yeah I tend to like these positions from
the black side honestly I love playing
against the isolated Queen pawn and
Magnus himself have this isolated Pawn
structure in tata steel he used it
against Wesley so when he had the white
pieces so we'll see if Arjun is going to
be able to create inroads because you
create some weaknesses on the dark
squares that is clear the black pawns
all on light squares in the king side
but a very likely plan from Magnus
Carlson's point of view is to drop his
Bishop his dark Swisher back home as
soon as I finish my sentence he plays it
and now there are threats with Knight
Forks on the score the bishop just left
so that's why Arjun scoots his Queen
away but I feel like black is very solid
here yeah as soon as black solves the
issue of that problem child the bishop
on C8 the light Squad Bishop then uh I
think he'll call the opening a success
but still a couple of moves away for
Magnus Carlson to do that I mean while
white is very flexible the two white
Bishops do point that glare is all
towards that King side towards the black
king don't be surprised as well if Harry
the H1 makes another appearance and uh
starts to try and loosen up the black
structure over the wall of thorns on the
king side still early days of course and
Arguments for both sides who to prefer
here
yeah I think Eric I see it's nice to see
him keep some tension playing ambitious
opening not heading towards anything
safe not heading towards the draw I
think Armageddon it's just a toss-up and
Magnus is super uh experience there
might give him the edge so Eric I see
going for the win just developing his
Bishop now magnusly and I think that's
important for Arjun he's got the white
pieces he needs to try to make the most
of his chances when it comes without
going super rush but I did not expect to
see any quick draws here and I think you
were talking about what you would do if
you were arjun's coach I know arjun's
coach is three knot and definitely he's
told him to fight with the white pieces
with Magnus you know you have to take
every single small opportunity that you
get this last move that Magnus has made
Bishop to D7 at first it looks like wait
a second what about the pawn do you not
lose it of the trades on D5 but notice
that Knight on E2 David if white does
pick up Knight D5 after the trades and
you pick up that pawn the real Garnier
it opens up and you can gobble up the
night so the pawn is not on pre so
definitely a little trap that Arjun sees
I would be surprised while he does pick
up the Knight fixes the pawn structure
in the center and develops the bishop to
E3 now that the e-file is blocked he has
a direct threat of picking up that D5
Pawn yeah and he can Target it with his
Knight as well he can go for it with his
Bishop so some pressure for Magnus to
try and deal with in this position how
about magnus's coaches Eric and Iman how
do you think they're advising their
student right now I also saw Ari antaria
was streaming on magnus's Twitch channel
so I don't know who's the coach but if
you're a Max's coach you said just get
out of this one head to Armageddon you
are the stronger player so if you get
the white pieces in the arm again use
those to your advantage if you have the
black piece you just need to hold the
draw so I feel like four Magnus just
don't take unnecessary risk in this game
and he's not doing that I think he's
following a strategy of let's just be
solid after that topsy-turvy game three
when you were talking about what Eric
and man might be telling Magnus and he
said get out of this one I thought you
were going to say and head to the bar
okay
put on some techno you know yeah
doing the hard sound on the cameras
maybe there is some techno going on in
the chess brat house that's a pretty
strong house right now if area come on
Ariane Magnus just all hanging out yeah
the average rating in that house of what
like 20 is 600. they could win the
Olympia ad with that Squad easily
and uh they're playing in the process
League big favorites for that one
potentially yeah meanwhile just uh the
game following the plans we mentioned
some serious pressure on black isolated
porn it's mutual weaknesses now the
white d-pawn is protected for now but uh
potentially a Target later blacks
Central Pawn is the one that Magnus has
to take care of expecting him to just
take a kind of sad defensive move maybe
plant the bishop on E6 and hold it for
one move longer but I've got to say I
prefer White's position here minimal
risk as well for Arjun yeah I like it
and even though the center is fixed it
just looks like white is faster to
attack the D5 Pawn yes you've defended
it with one piece but what happens if
white just gets more pressure onto the
D5 Bond bring that Knight into the game
you can go to F4 you can bring it to C3
stop putting pressure already and it
looks like arjun's strategy of trying to
get a game with the white pieces has
succeeded so far it's definitely paid
off and now Magnus is he forced to keep
retreating for example Knight E7 just to
defend that pawn looks like it might be
the only way no Magnus finds it more
creative uh approach he plants his Queen
here saying yes you can win a pawn but
now I will totally wreck your Pawn
structure and uh yes you might be a pawn
up in the near future but you will live
to regret these weaknesses Arjun has
shown tendency to grab Pawns in the past
not just in that last game but uh
throughout the tour throughout his game
so he might be very tempted but I don't
think uh this is something I would
advise no definitely not if you take the
other way with the bishop up instead of
with the Knight what happens is black
takes back and then there's a rook that
gets planted on d8 so you don't hurt
your Pawn structure but you're not going
to remain upon a head a look at Black's
activity here both Rooks staring down
the center of the board the D4 Pawn will
be captured and that will ensure likely
material equality and maybe some extra
activity for black because of the more
active Rooks Yep this one I don't think
you need to give Magnus that much fun
you can you have a bunch of options
where Magnus is the one on the defense
so uh yeah maybe just bring a rook into
the game just improve this piece which
is doing nothing right now bring it to a
semi-open file maybe just push a pawn so
you don't get checkmated on the back
rank a bit later first he shuffles his
Queen across equally decent but now
maybe Magnus has an idea of jumping back
with the Knight I was going to say that
was necessary anyway but the White Queen
is a target for the night once it
arrives on this Flack
um still in the balance still very level
on the clock as well there's a standard
strategy though even in the French
defense where you have this kind of Pawn
structure if the white knight ever takes
on E6 you take with the pawn but that's
no longer possible after this move after
Knight takes E6 you have to watch out
because if you take with the pawn in
comes Bishop to G5 you skewer the queen
and the Rook behind it that would win
some material for white so Magnus has to
be a bit careful here I don't think it's
the end of the world if he takes back on
E6 uh with the queen after the Knight
takes the bishop uh so I think that
that's what he's relying on and honestly
we've talked about how good the bishop
pair is here the bishop pair doesn't
look that great in fact I would prefer
to have the Knight and Bishop in this
structure yeah this is especially a bad
piece another big Pawn on the board and
uh yeah it looks like Magnus has solved
most of his issues let's see if Arjun
can whip up anything can he be creative
and uh push Magnus off balance
potentially
what do you guys think if it was to go
into the Armageddon who would that favor
more do you think Arjun has
better chance than the Armor getting
compared to the rapid games or do you
think Magnus will just Crush that and
who would want black we mentioned Wesley
in Hickory they both probably want the
black pieces draw odds but it's not
clear between these two well I think
that all things considered going into
the match of course RJ wants to get to
Armageddon but I think that Max is the
favorite overall but origen has better
chances in Armageddon than he does in
Rapid time just just because Magnus is
the stronger player between the two
arches has been playing a great match I
mean he's been very impressive to be
down a point and then to be pressing in
game two not quite make it work and then
game three with black to beat Magnus
when it's tactics everywhere he's been
informed these last couple games but
Magnus Carlson I mean he's won how many
world championship titles 15 is that
right too many 15 I think is right yeah
but we did hear him say uh as late as
yesterday that he he feels that he is
slower than he used to be Magnus Carlsen
can we see that or is that just
something he's saying I don't believe
him yeah I think he's just saying it so
that people will start thinking it and
then he'll show everyone who's the boss
so I really think that we should let
Magnus Carlson's moves do the talking to
this point in the air things Masters
yesterday he was just amazing against
Alexi Serrano and we've seen what Alexis
Iran is capable of today as he took down
allereza faruja that was not an easy
matchup on you know it looked like on
paper higher rating two and a half no
big deal Alexi Serrano is super strong
so Magnus is fantastic I think he's just
kind of letting people think they have a
chance against him but when it comes to
the Whiteboard who's the favorite in the
air things Masters in the champ chess or
myself duh what's his answer yeah yeah
he is confident uh Magnus cross and
Arjun arag icy
with the white pieces in this game I
mean looking at it now do you see
chances for both players to win this
game at first I thought wait a second
white Scottish John's here you can come
up with the Rook Kaya here to the
seventh rank after this night retreat
but it doesn't really get you anywhere
does it David a black continues with the
plan to hit that Queen bring on the
Knight to F5 and at the end of
everything you can always challenge that
Rook on the seventh rank bringing your
own Rook to the seventh Rank and
offering a trade so everything's still
under control car and I think draw is a
likely result I'm up for another
Armageddon ah definitely yeah if you
look at the skeleton of the position as
well um all things being equal okay
Knight takes Bishop just happened but uh
it's exactly the same Pawn structure you
both have isolated pawns maybe they'll
both disappear a bit later on uh no
transfer passports on the king side
Queen side everything's symmetrical and
uh okay the first small imbalance of the
game Knight takes Bishop white has the
bishop pair but as we mentioned earlier
not an impressive uh set of pieces a
knight coming to F5 and very important
here that Magnus does pick up the Knight
with the queen because it would be a
huge blunder to pick it up with the pawn
uh David massive pressure once the
bishop jumps on to G5 hits that Queen
Knight on E7 has been if you fall back
to F7 then The Rook comes to C7 and this
would be a devastating attack on the
night and on the position uh I'm a
little surprised that Magnus is thinking
here because Queen E6 just looks like
the only move what am I missing don't
think you're missing anything Tanya
perhaps he's considering okay he does
play the best move I was gonna say
perhaps he's considering a
counter-attack not an automatic
recapture uh using his Knight to attack
the White Queen but why bother
calculating this when you have a very
healthy simple straightforward
alternative he does Recapture the Knight
and uh the threat remains of uh Landing
his Knight in F5 trading off more pieces
and getting closer to that draw so uh
still very balanced I'm not sure who I
take to be honest I think uh Arjun and
Magnus both equally safe in this
position I think I take black I just
feel like black is first of the punch
all of a sudden with Knight F5 about to
be played D4 is lose their back ranked
checkmates that white has to look out
for and they're also manifest
immediately threatens to win a pawn
forking the queen and the bishop on E3
so I'm actually a bit nervous here uh
for origin I'm sure they're good with
any Bishop C2 it actually might be the
most prudent let me take that Knight as
soon as it lands there but we've said
this before that in a position with
Bishops of the same color you want the
pawns to be on the opposite color of
your Bishop black pawns on light squares
but look at that Bishop on E3 staring
into its own pawns a bit defensive it's
not a bad position for white but that's
a small little Plus for black I think
that is the easiest path towards the
quality for Arjun because otherwise he
might find himself in some danger yeah
so now might be the moment to pull the
break just uh heading to reverse gear
and go towards that draw don't entertain
chances of winning anymore it will just
backfire and this is a big threat after
all so uh Arjun thinking this is a
critical moment in this game
he doesn't look too excited about his
position I've got to say Arjun just
looking off to the side there maybe
looking at the clock thinking okay I'm
down on time let's just uh neutralize
this one let's move on to the next game
and Armageddon it is just a one game
shootout and at the top level in one in
a one-off encounter you can see these
big surprises from time to time in a
long match that's where it's harder to
beat the likes of Magnus so he's done a
great job I think Armageddon is now most
likely what is the history of Armageddon
is it something quite new in the Chess
World or has it been around for a long
time came from that movie Armageddon
right
wait he was in that it's been a while
since yesterday
oh that's true Tyler is in that oh yeah
it's a good movie yeah that's a good
question
um I guess there's been debates for a
long time how to separate players
especially in knockout formats and I
know back in the days of the World Cup
which was called the world championship
in the late 90s early 2000s that's where
kind of these playoffs became more and
more popular but it's been around for a
while it's certainly kind of recently
that no we need it because there's so
many strong players in the world that we
need it more and more often and this
bidding structure I think it was
introduced by Norway chess uh maybe it
was somewhere else originally but uh
that one is quite new that's a new
innovation yeah sure
do you think they have started already
to think about the bidding process do
you or do you think actually they headed
into the match with the strategy for
bidding I think Magnus Carl since they
were winning this game because he has a
lead on the clock and the position is
not just completely dead in the water
it's not the one where okay we just make
simple moves and draw so I probably they
have some sort of strategy but I think
Magnus is like very far away from the
mentality of let's go to Armageddon he's
going to try to outplay origin in this
position because arjun's pieces are kind
of all over the place right now whereas
the harmony is in Black's camp and I
guess that's what makes him the best in
the world he's just focusing and trying
to win every single game yeah and
meanwhile some tactics on the board that
black Rook on the light square is
attacked White's Bishop on A4 staring
down at it and the White Queen keeping
those Rooks honest the black Rooks can't
move for fear that they will lose
defense of each other meanwhile Magnus
does have some threats against this dark
Square Bishop it's tactics everywhere
suddenly I'm trying to do some quick
calculation but I think I need a bit
more time yes and I could expect Arjun
Eric I see Magnus both to go into the
tank over the next few moves there is a
cool sequence here that saves white
because Knight takes E3 as we'll bring
up a now sporty it looks like it's
almost crushing because after Knight
takes Bishop Bishop takes Rook on E8
Knight takes Rook on D1 you say oh give
me that other Rook on dude that looks
great give me the material but Queen E1
is not just check it's mate that King
has no Escape squares that would be game
over so that's why you don't take this
Rook on d8 right away you instead throw
in Bishop takes F7 with check
distracting the queen away and once the
queen takes the bishop the White Queen
takes the Rook with check the Knight on
D1 Falls at the end of this variation
and that leaves white way too much
material ahead so this is what Arjun is
relying on here because Knight takes
Bishop 23 looks very powerful but it
actually would not be as good as it may
initially appear and that's why Magnus
has stopped he's for sure calculated
this whole line he's probably seen
exactly the same moves that Robert has
just there and now he's looking for
Alternatives that's how the play is
calculate they look for the most direct
attempt if it doesn't work then they
backtrack and look for Alternatives
because if Knight takes Bishop was
strong then he could just go for it
instead he has to try and figure out how
to keep this Rook intact and not many
two not too many squares for it I guess
you just have to sidestep that's not
ideal it's a bit of a sad Square bit of
a passive one but you have to protect
your fellow on d8 and still you have
ideas of Knight takes Bishop I think
white has to take a time out now to
defend against that and the game goes on
White's Queen can't quite go Pawn
hunting yet I think you need to take a
time out to defend your bishop and
you've got a good way to take that time
out because you can't jump over to the
G5 square with your bishop and hit that
Rook on d8 because notice that pawn on
B7 that you were pointing out David and
I'm just wondering can't Arjun on the
very next move once you save The Rook uh
pick up the B7 Pawn because you never
want to play a rook B8 that is just ugly
very ugly move here Black Rock on a
passive Square suddenly white has ideas
maybe jumping in with the Bishops and
threats just adding up worse comes to
the worst you come here and you take the
Knight and then you say okay at least I
have more active pieces the White Queen
is really nicely placed and still in a
risk for Arjun uh so Magnus may be
looking for something better I'm not
sure if anything better exists other
than just moving this Rook to safety you
need to step it out of this diagonal he
could also be looking for example at
shifting this Rook across attacking the
White Queen this looks very tempting and
maybe the tactics change uh if the White
Queen is forced onto a different Square
again you've got to calculate the
implications of Knight takes Bishop but
rather than going down six seven moves
variations let's let magnets do that and
uh yeah in this position it feels like
Arjun is certainly trying to press maybe
he doesn't believe in his chances in
Armageddon but he is taking significant
risks and move like Bishop A4 you've got
to calculate really really well because
suddenly there are these types of
sequences that require Precision this is
ambitious played by Arjun if he wanted
to bail out then I love that idea of
dropping back with the bishop and trying
to trade the Knight and the bishop and
not allowing this activity that we see
by Magnus but these last few moves have
definitely hinted at Arjun wanting a
game in this one Queen C7 on the board
and big questions big tactics Magnus is
taking his time he's about two and a
half minutes behind on the clock in a
critical moment yeah maybe he is getting
older and slower he's really slowed down
this last game or two maybe the
confidence dented by that last game but
uh yeah it's surprising that he's
thinking so long now because doesn't
seem to be too many decisions if you
can't take that white Bishop you have to
react to the attack on your Rooks right
and so he oh he finally moves The Rook
to C8 so he attacks the queen and just
like earlier if the pawn on B7 is
captured I think it's a slide that Rook
on over again chase the queen behind it
is his Pawn on B2 and the white king is
kind of Airy so there are many ideas for
black to go after that white king
especially if the Knight captures that
bishwan E3 a moment this is a very
tricky position of both sides with their
chances but Magnus and Arjun they're
showing that they're not making a
peaceful draw like in the game between
Wesley so and akara Nakamura they want
to Duke it out here in game four yeah
and uh this is really impressive both
players still continuing taking really
ambitious decisions on every turn I'm
wondering where that Queen goes now
you've got to be a bit careful it feels
like a bit of a dance between the White
Queen and the black Rook wherever she
goes she's gonna get attacked how do you
sidestep how do you evade all of those
threats but can we be greedy can we
continue Pawn hunting that's the acid
test of the black idea I'm not sure we
can it's not too many safe squares
there's one two three maybe or you could
offer a queen queen trade if you want to
play it super safe but uh can Queen
takes Pawn happen I'm a bit scared of
this uh type of skewer hitting the queen
and also hitting the Rook behind it but
we do have this move to try and offer
the trade of Queens this feels like a
safety first approach if you get the
Queen's off you should be safe you
should live to fight another day but
Arjun says no no Queen trade yet I'm
continuing to play for the win and still
this threat remains what is magnus's
idea maybe he'll get this Rook out now
with Tempo he has given up a pawn Magnus
so he has invested uh some material into
this sequence and uh White Once uh once
Archer moves the queen will perhaps
remain a pawn up at least for a move or
two but as Robert says counter play on
B2 counter play on E3
once black steps with the with the other
Rook attacking the queen I don't see
another Square for white except to go
Queen D7 and offer a queen trade but
that would mean that black will have the
option to perhaps pick up the B2 pawn it
just seems like we have so many trades
the E3 Bishop will be picked up the
queen will be traded The Rook slowly
traded the pawn will be picked up and
eventually we'll have this rook and
opposite color Bishop end game yeah
I don't know how that's going to end
let's take a look not sure how I think
I've done it the wrong order already but
let's say I flicked in a rook trade
first and everything just disappearing
off the board a moment ago it was so
tense and uh three moves later we have
this just some really simple end game
with opposite color Bishops this one I
think we can say should be a draw with
best play but uh I think I would take
black slightly just because this Rook is
so active and potential weaknesses in
the white Camp uh so Arjun reluctantly
seeing it going for this yeah could we
see that whole sequence happen starting
perhaps with a rook trade uh Magnus just
hoovering everything off the board and a
draw the most likely
yeah it's a big decision here for Magnus
because if he missteps right now it
could be like game two where Magnus gave
up a pawn early and then never got it
back until the very end when he was able
to secure a draw so he needs to be
careful I thought he's been playing very
well energetically but he is down
material so I think okay we're seeing
all the pieces swap off it's about that
time uh are there any winning chances I
don't really see it for other side I do
think all the pieces are gonna be
swapped and we're heading towards a
split point
yep and uh two armageddon's potentially
that'll be exciting super fun
for choice I have to say you know a lot
of people think that Armageddon it seems
like an unfair way to sort of end it we
see so much flagging I love it it is so
much fun and it really comes down to a
different form of the sport you know it
has to you have to keep you have to keep
control over the clock your nerves just
need this different skill set yeah to be
good at Armageddon it's Bill fire and
you need to make a strategy for the
bidding for which color you want to
choose
I would love to hear the players
thoughts when they're making that bid
yeah what's going through their mind and
why they decide on a certain time I'm
always curious what they predict their
opponent is about to be right like if
you bid say 14 minutes is it because you
thought your opponent's gonna go very
low and you just want white anyway or do
you think your opponent also is going to
go quite high and so that you at least
have more time to get the black pieces
because you know it's a strategic thing
that is hard to figure out in advance
and you never know what your opponent's
thinking I do believe it changes based
on how the four games have gone and we
do know that usually the white player
will have 15 minutes because the player
with the lowest bed will choose the
black colors how low can you allow
yourself to go
how low can you go I think I think Rishi
answered that question that was Robert
that story he uh did seven minutes and I
think everyone's 15. against 15 and
everyone's like are you sure you know
the base times 15 he said yes and he
played Pablo pankaratov and pankarovs
have crushed him because he just didn't
have time to calculate the position so I
think most people bid around 11 12
minutes that's the safety and we saw
that in ghukesh and momentov they both
did 12 minutes then 11 45 and 11 minutes
so uh that's the standard I would say
okay yeah
yeah I mean while all of the pawns all
of the pieces are disappearing from this
game still some chances while the Rooks
remain on the board but if we do see a
rook trade which might well happen in
the next few turns then this game will
be a draw I mean well we also see Magnus
Carlson's uh air quality stats for the
first time I think this tournament and
uh oh not looking great in the
chatsborough house and the chess Bra
House red CO2 levels it's been a long
day he needs to open a window perhaps
air quality is poor oh it's quite humid
there as well very warm though out in
Toronto right now so Magnus as the day
draws on that could have an effect on
his level of play uh we noticed that in
past Seasons where it uh yeah definitely
has direct consequences
I've noticed in armageddon's Magnus
usually likes to get the black pieces I
remember the first that epic Armageddon
that happened between Magnus and Hikaru
in when it was back with the Magnus
Carlsen Chester and what a match that
was and Magnus eventually went on to win
that with the black pieces in an
Armageddon it's gonna be interesting to
see how much he's willing to bargain on
the clock to get the black pieces yeah
and actually is this format almost
unique I know chess.com have done it for
a while but normally armaged interests
in World Cups for example over the board
games it's normally just with blitz
chess five versus four and uh with rapid
chess it's a different strategy right
you have
10 11 minutes if you uh if you choose
black sometimes that feels like enough
time to still play an objectively strong
game and it gives the players the choice
because if you're in an Armageddon where
they just tell you you have six minutes
your opponent has five but that's just
how it goes it's cool to see the players
they take different strategies and well
there's not much strategy left in this
game the pieces have come off the board
opposite colored Bishop in the end game
even though white is up a pawn it
doesn't give good winning chances so I
think we're just seeing the final moves
on this one before we do head to the
bidding and Armageddon
yeah Magnus looks really chilled right
now most of us wouldn't be if we were
one point down against a giant like our
generic icy but uh Magnus knows you just
blockade on the dark squares White's
only past born the extra Pawn on the D
file easy to blockade and uh we'll see a
bunch more uh trades we might even see
the players repeat I don't know how much
longer Eric icy will press this
the one thing that I think black needs
to be careful about is not to allow the
two connected past Pawns in the center
it might still be a job why go for that
especially with the Airborne still alive
it can get a little bit tricky so once
white goes for the G4 break exactly keep
that F Pawn on F5 so that white doesn't
get two connected boss bonds yeah so
allow the trade but on your own terms
you need to stop the white Pawn the
white epon joining it's uh it's made
that the d-pawn and everything else is
blockaded yeah we're not hanging around
here Armageddon all right it's getting
close you guys we will see two
armageddons uh most probably to decide
the winner is semi-finals two players
will go through to the winners final and
two players will be knocked down to the
losers bracket to play losers
quarterfinals tomorrow
wow yeah that's uh after this win
earlier from Magnus Carlsen I just
assumed he'd be there I assumed he'd be
uh in the winter semi-final but wow fair
play to Argentina Regice he does get the
draw in this one and we're there two
Armageddon scouted out the drama
continues this is fantastic news we're
going to see two Armageddon games to
decide the winner is semi-finals Arjun
Eric icy taking Magnus Carlsen to a tie
break in 10 minutes it's gonna start
they now have a few minutes to make
their bids so Robert what what do you
expect now what what will happen
I think that Magnus Carlson he will pick
a lower time than our generator so I
feel pretty confident Magnus will get
the black pieces in this Armageddon game
how you don't agree Tanya I think that's
what Magnus wants but I think that's
exactly what art turn wants as well if
he definitely doesn't want to give
Magnus the Jaws that's going to be super
tough so it really just comes down to
the bit it's so important but also to
find that balance that if you do get the
black pieces you don't fall too short on
the clock and then we have another
Armageddon as well David Wesley so
against Hikaru Nakamura what do you
think will happen in the bidding process
there I think it's going to be a bidding
war for the black pieces they all start
at 14 minutes 59 then they'll both say
14 minutes 58 and I don't know how low
they'll go but uh it definitely feels
like a draw is the favorite in that one
so whoever gets the black pieces will
start with the advantage all right it
will be revealed very soon what is the
results of the bidding Armageddon is
coming up get ready for the action you
guys
[Music]
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to take that your
world champion and it's taking longer
than two words there's something wrong
with the adventure there's something
wrong but I believe in when we're
talking in the 60s and 70s even the 80s
and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I have
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
to draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
[Music]
foreign
probably cheering for his fellow Indian
Arjun Eric icy right now getting ready
for Armageddon against world number one
Magnus Carlsen right now we're going to
take a quick twitch break for everyone
who are not subscribers for everyone
else coming up very shortly we're gonna
reveal the answer to uh the puzzle that
we had today
foreign
[Music]
s to decide the winner is semi-finals
this is going to be dramatic certainly I
mean I personally can't wait to see who
will choose the white pieces because
last year on the tour we saw everyone
who chose white one yeah so I reckon
these players are so fast that it's
going to be a big advantage to have more
time on the clock yeah Magnus Carlsen
our generator guys here after four rapid
games they are tied two points each our
generic guys he must be heading into the
Armageddon feeling quite confident
winning a game against Magnus I think he
will be doing his exercise and just
getting pumped because this is his
moment in the Sun and of course if he
wins he goes on to the winners bracket
and Magnus Carlson goes down to the
losers wow and oh gosh I mean who would
have ever thought about that yeah and
Magnus Carlsen in Armageddon no
increment do you think he is less of a
favorite against the origin or bigger
oh you know backness is Magnus you know
I don't think I've seen him lose too
many Armageddon matches
um he's quick he's fast he's got great
instincts and Arjun is quite honestly
gonna struggle there yeah and then we do
have uh Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
they played Four draws today so
it's like David said you know you could
think that they want to have the black
pieces where with a drawer you win the
match so what will happen in the bidding
process with these two
oh I'm not actually sure whether we will
see Hikaru actually bid to have the
black pieces I think he's so fast he
knows how to draw out the game to Great
length so I'm going to suspect that he's
actually going to put on a high bid and
they have to remember when he faced off
Daniel dubov in the play-ins I mean
Daniel duboff actually bid quite low and
Hikaru just dragged the game on for all
eternity so my prediction is that Hikaru
is going to go for a very conservative
bid all right well no matter what
happens two players will go through to
the winner is final tomorrow two players
will be knocked down to the losers
bracket and the loser between Magnus
Carlsen and Arjun aragaisy will face go
cash tomorrow and the loser is
quarterfinals and go cash has been a big
topic for us today he won his match
today on the losers bracket against
mamadol
and the young Indian
also has composed a study that we made a
little puzzle from and we're going to
reveal the answer to the puzzle now yeah
he uh he's a genius in every sense of
the word and of course we were following
the end of this study that cash had done
and it was a very complicated study and
a lot of people didn't actually get the
answer right Hey so uh Keisha we take
everyone through yeah the answer before
we reveal today's winner let's do that
we're going to bring up the puzzle and
reveal the answer to this very
sophisticated study composed by
Ivanka take us through it okay so a lot
of people actually guess that white
should simply get just good Pawn hunting
grab the rook and uh take that pawn and
unfortunately this would be a big big
mistake because simply it allows the
Knight back into the game the Knight
would jump to the F3 square and Order
and some extra Defender so we go back to
the original study and that we can see
here that you've got to use the right
time the Knight is offside now is the
perfect time to hunt the king and you do
that with your own King by playing King
to E8 you're closing the net upon the
king and unfortunately there really
isn't that much that black can actually
do black can try to go Pawn hunt you
know not Pawn hunting porn promoting and
actually push the G Pawn one square
further and here is where the magic
happens as they say the Rook will give a
check to the King King has to travel on
dark squares and now this is good
technique the white king will actually
follow the black king but travel on the
light squares and again there's a lovely
lovely mating net being set up and once
the black porn steps forward again then
The Rook comes to the edge of the board
on A6 and look at that the rook and the
bishop are combining very nicely and
mate on A8 is just unavoidable so Rook
comes whatever moves and there you go
there you see it incredible it is
absolutely incredible because it's it's
just comes from nowhere that's the thing
about this this whole study and the fact
that he composed it at the age of 15 and
also this is like move 12 along the
whole variation is just incredible yeah
good cash what uh chess genius the young
teenager is we did announce we will pick
a winner someone who has given the right
answer to this puzzle and it's Gustav
correctly guessing King E8 because Black
Knight is trapped and black cannot
defend Checkmate very nice answer and he
will get an air things
and it's even better because it's been
signed by Magnus Carlson such as a very
very special prize congratulations to
Gustav Magnus Carlsen is right now
getting ready for Armageddon coming up
in a few minutes
it's a very topical branch of the nimso
Indian defense that's a big decision
here for uh Magnus Magnus looks really
killed right now most of us wouldn't be
if we were one point down against a
giant like our generic icy fair play to
origin era I think he does get the draw
in this one and we're there two
Armageddon
still no bids has come menu guys and
only minutes until the Armageddon is
starting what are the players doing
I was guessing they're keeping each
other guessing uh it's that
psychological warfare of the bidding war
yeah
all right well we are waiting now for
the bids Robert can you remind us again
the regulations for the Armageddon for
sure so 15 minutes will be the base time
you cannot bid above that the side that
chooses the lower amount of time let's
say you choose 10 minutes I choose nine
minutes I gotta choose my color you will
get 15 minutes and if I choose nine
minutes I will likely choose the black
pieces and if we draw our game I move on
sorry to say Kyle
I likely would against you Robert
so that are those are the regulations
you guys and we are very curious will
the players what will they Bend who will
get the white pieces who will get the
black pieces both matches here in the
winter semi-finals have gone to the
Armageddon Magnus Carlsen against
sergeant aragaisy and hikar Nakamura
against Wesley so we are waiting now
impatiently for the bids and in the
match between Wesley Sony car and
Nakamura you have predicted that they
both really want the black Pieces Just
judging by the flow of the previous
games there's been nothing in it really
whoever had the black pieces was Rock
Solid and found really convincing ways
to defend and uh yeah opening wise as
well they have bulletproof repertoires
so I feel that yeah black is a
significant uh Advantage here for
whoever gets those pieces and we have a
bin coming in here we have it Wesley
slow has been 9 minutes and 44 seconds
hikara Nakamura 9 minutes and 28 seconds
I mean Hikaru Nakamura could choose
colors obviously he has chosen the black
uh pieces he will play with 9 minutes
and 28 seconds Wesley so with the white
pieces will have 15 minutes you're
saying wow Tanya because the government
wins the bid by 16 seconds unbelievable
so he gets to choose the black color and
gets the result or he will most likely
pick that because that's the Armageddon
strategy that we've seen and you know
we've got these two armageddon's coming
up but what's really striking to me is
how different the two matches have been
Wesley and a car will just look like the
approach for these two players from the
very start was to get to this point yeah
incredible we have the other bed as well
in the other match up let's see
Arjun Air Guys he's been 11 minutes and
59 seconds Magnus Carlson bidding 10
minutes and one second that's
very close and Magnus winning the bid
has chosen to play with the black pieces
he will have 10 minutes and one second
versus Arjun aragaisy with the white
pieces having 15 minutes what do you
think of that bed uh David well I think
we better strap in because it's
definitely going to come down to a race
on the clock later for the place with
the white pieces they're going to have a
huge clock Advantage from the get-go and
uh yeah they'll be need to uh they'll
need to be quick on the mouse almost
five minutes Advantage for archon and
about six minutes for Wesley and we saw
Magnus and Arjun in that photograph I
think both of them are pleased yeah
Arjun gets a five minute Advantage
Magnus gets the pieces that he wants and
it's um yeah archon has to win on demand
yeah not an easy task and in the other
one Hikaru with a little over nine
minutes on the clock you said you should
have around 11 minutes is this danger
for Hikaru Nakamura well for any mere
mortal 11 minutes sounds good hikaran
Nakamura has not proven to be mortal I
don't think anyone's checked his blood
pressure recently he is just amazing at
bullet chess he moves so quickly but for
Wesley so he is as solid as they come he
needs a stop that right here he needs to
play an opening that challenges akaru
does not allow him to go forcing
variations and use the Croc as a weapon
I think Wesley can do that he is the
chess.com Global champion from a year
ago he beat ikar Nakamura not an
Armageddon but in the match he's shown
he's capable of doing so I think Wesley
will have to go for an opening the
Hikaru can't possibly expect and I think
for Hikaru this is a big grudge match
exactly because of that he wants to get
his revenge yeah and it'll be refreshing
to see Wesley kind of let loose and just
go for his opponent go all out for the
win it's very rare that we see Wesley
take risks we know he's capable he's so
talented his instincts are so good but
wow it's deja vu yet again it's a repeat
of game one and game three of the match
it's the Italian game where we see this
become a very quiet maneuvering battle
has Wesley come with some surprises up
his sleeve he hasn't got anywhere he
hasn't made any ground in terms of an
opening advantage in those previous two
battles but here he needs something a
bit different look at this we're already
on move eight nine and and Hikaru has
played every move almost instantly but
once there's more time it started with
so I don't believe armor again has
increment so that's true uh that might
these games might have to be restarted I
guess oh might be an abort that because
yeah and we see Hikaru throw his hands
in the air he's like what is happening
technical issues that there's not
supposed to be increment and you know
very often this disturbs Hikaru a lot he
said about how much he hates being
disturbed once the game is on he's not a
happy guy right now and also just gave
away what his plan was because if Wesley
repeats this opening all of a sudden now
hikaras think uh should I go for the
same exact plan or will I have to mix it
up because now we'll see knows what to
expect oh this is a cry prices
hikaranakamura now with a smile on his
face but shaking his head yeah this is a
disaster this is exactly what you don't
want in an Armageddon and Robert the
point that you brought up that the
opening is gone what you had up your
sleeve your opponent knows now and look
at both these pairs they're absolutely
stunned what do they do now just shift
switch shop openings yeah it looks like
Wesley was reading a computer screen
maybe he's prepping this line now that
he knows what Hikaru is going to do
um I wonder if there's a restart in the
other game it looked like both games
started with the Italian opening but no
we're off again and the clock times will
be corrected I hope there we go Hikaru
down nine and a half minutes to play
this game and it's a race to the Finish
sudden death now uh no increments and
Wesley changes it up no more Italian
game oh my God yeah Hikaru is not going
to be happy about this and this is
exactly what happened in his playoff in
the Swiss qualifiers as well when he was
playing against Daniel DuBois and I
think he had the same situation where
eventually they had to restart the match
and it was an absolute disaster and
Hikaru mentioned that in his interview
later
yeah and meanwhile strange strategy here
from Wesley so to change things up it
feels like you might as well just repeat
the same mood to get back to the same
position and you both fight from the
same uh kind of the same level playing
field but okay he's gone towards the
Berlin and a very closed locked up
situation here and looked up Pawn
structure black has double pawns but has
the bishop pair that's compensation the
reason I'm surprised is that Hikaru
Nakamura he has a reputation of being
the expert in this type of structure to
both colors do you think this is a bit
of a dirty play by Wesley to change up
the opening once it's been revealed it's
just so awkward for the players now yeah
yeah I mean but you just have to they're
professionals they've had to deal with
all sorts of circumstances it's LED them
to be the best of the game and they're
playing a normal opening right now so I
think that for Wesley he's using his
time uh Hikaru moving very quickly to
start as David said he is the leading
expert perhaps in the black side of
these exchange Spanish and what we see
is black has these double pawns over
there on the C file a white Pawn
structure uncompromised is in perfect
order but black has the pair of Bishops
and he would try to use that to his
Advantage yeah and Hikaru he often keeps
his opponents which side he's uh kind of
keeps his opponents guessing which side
is he going to Castle we do see that the
pair of Bishops is gone white spent a
couple of moves uh trading off Black's
light Squad Bishop normally a very
strong piece but the remainder of the
pieces blacks pieces here they look very
well placed in offering a queen trade
he's bullying Wesley now with a thought
of a drawish type of end game and uh
Wesley in a must win situation I would
be surprised if we see the Queens come
off there we go he Retreats you just
can't take the Queens off and uh allow
Hikaru to lock that up with the draw
very easy play for black if the Queens
disappear at least now a bit of
maneuvering and uh yeah Hikaru playing
super fast still a five minute
difference between the two players
though or four and a half minute
difference will that come in handy later
for Wesley the white nice is on a nice
weather sorry very nice Square as you
were pointing out because it also wants
to find itself to land on the F5 square
area opportune moment and very important
for Wesley to keep all the pieces on the
board as many as he can to keep the
pressure going to get Hikaru low on the
clock this is an Armageddon there's no
increment flagging your opponent is a
huge part of the game strategy here no
shame in that whatsoever and Hikaru
going all out here he pushes Harry the H
Pawn forcing White's Queen to fall all
the way back to its original Square yeah
not good news necessarily for Wesley so
but wow Hikaru in a situation where he
only needs a draw he's pushing all his
pawns forward it's like you said earlier
Roberts uh your baseball now is a bit
weak pause don't move backwards some
holes in the black Camp uh what do we
think of this one where's the black king
gonna go most likely it's going to go
long to the queen side now and the
problem for why is there no Pawn breaks
that's why he pushed the pawn up to G5
he took away control of the F4 square
look at Black's pawns and Bishop
covering all the important dark squares
so all he pawns on the board the Rooks
are not doing anything all of Black's
pawns protected I like what Hikaru has
done here he is playing an excellent
game thus far and does Wesley you need a
win therefore you have to open up lines
you have to open up with those Pawn
breaks and he prepares that with C3
getting ready to push his Central Pawn
but David when you have to win a game
this is exactly the kind of position
that you want with Wesley has to win on
demand this is the position where you're
playing for all results where draw is
the least likely he's aiming and he's
dreaming to get that Central break in
but Hikaru stops it to me the way
hikarus played the last few moves it
looks like he's channeling his anger
about what happened at the start of the
game into the position
now he's doing a great job gotta say I
like what he's done he's actually kept
his King very flexible in the center if
the black king had gone to the queen
side there would have been levers there
would have been ways to open up lines
for uh the white pieces but now he's
advancing slowly towards the white king
not necessarily uh leading up to an
attack but at least putting that fear
into Wesley and uh as well in a muscle
in situation you have to burn time on
the clock here the onus is on Wesley you
are the one trying to find those ideas
trying to create something and at some
point Wesley will slow down my biggest
question is where is this style of game
every other time they play each other
like they're so solid they essentially
are kind of holding back a little bit
and now when a draw does not suffice for
Wesley he shows that he can make the
game interesting from the very start
black has finally Castle kingside this
game reminds me of the one from the
candidates between five and a carwana
and Hikaru Nakamura five on a one night
game with the white pieces because
eventually he opened up the position and
here that is exactly what Wesley needs
to do I think he is going to take this
bishop we just saw that the Knight Will
recapture and then d-pawn pushes forward
finally the position opens up that's
good news for the Rooks that have been
sitting idly in this position and now
all of a sudden it's full steam ahead
West is going for just that this is
getting into dangerous territory for
hikaru's King which looks okay for the
moment but watch out keep an eye on him
yeah that beautiful Pawn white uh porn
center right now I can barely talk it so
quick but uh yeah that beautiful Pawn
Center for white so flexible a threat on
that D4 Pawn right now you can step it
forward you can step the E point forward
you can just hold things together with
the White Queen a bunch of choices for
Wesley technically in uh Armageddon you
should try and keep the tension as long
as possible that's what they advise at
least but if you spot an opportunity go
for it and uh Force Sakura to calculate
he's still got more than seven and a
half minutes though this should be
enough still in the balance despite
white structure looking really nice and
healthy right now and who would you pick
here Tanya Robert oh my God like neither
I do not want to be in that situation in
an Armageddon look at the position David
the D4 Pawn is hanging it just feels
like black is the one who's putting the
pressure asking the questions here
Wesley needs to answer if he pushes that
pawn black snide eventually after the
trades can find itself on a really nice
Square on F4 uh it is looking dangerous
for both sides but this is Armageddon
and that's exactly what happens yep and
Wesley keeps the tension not stepping
forward with either of his pawns yet
keeping hikar regressing very wise I
feel and now it's pressure on black how
do you unravel how do you keep the black
king safe while uh finding better
squares for your pieces I think it was
smart not to initiate the trades because
that gives Hikaru some easier moves and
easier plans now with seven pounds
remain beside we see hikar step forward
with his own pawn and Wesley can do the
same he does not want to just trade push
your Pawn for a D5 keep the position
closed uh you have connected pawns your
knight can reroute from its Outpost on
C4 I would love to go and venture over
to the king side and cause the black
king some harm so that night would love
to eventually get to the F5 Square I
think Pond pushed D5 is absolutely
necessary right now for West you cannot
just trade that gives hikar way too easy
of the next series of moves yeah big
question if the Black Knight does land
in the center at some point do you
consider taking this Beast off the board
maybe this Knight is worth a rook and
you do get a point in return you are
left with this Rock Solid Center for
white and uh if you had time now to just
play one more move you'd have maximum
control as Robert mentioned another F5
here and black will not survive but uh
does Wesley have that luxury and I think
you should start with this one uh
pushing the pawn forward and later try
to reroute the White Knight
Hikaru looking pretty relaxed and the
time Advantage is disappearing less than
two minutes between them now he's played
so Speedy Hikaru and that's the dream
scenario for Hikaru right if he's able
to get wrestling down to the same amount
of time as he has and then he's got the
result odds also this could be big
disaster and Wesley trades on C5 that's
a shocking decision just allowing black
to solve the pawn structure problem as
well as the Knight gets so much activity
yeah suddenly this Black Knight stares
down at some really weak points if you
ever move your knight out the way now
then the black queen will be ready to
swoop and pick off these weaknesses and
look at what Hikaru has done he's
throwing a thorn into the white side
this black H Pawn if you capture it your
structure is ruined the white king is
going to be weak forever if you bypass
this pawn and step forward then there
will always be checkmating ideas against
this King thanks to this Pawn Hikaru
he's using all of his experience here
and it feels like Wesley he's let it
slip no Advantage for white at all and
remember Wesley has to win this game
with the white pieces any other result
means Hikaru Nakamura goes through to
the Winner's final in the other one we
have Armageddon between Magnus Carlsen
and Arjun aragaisy as well there were no
technical issues in that game as far as
I know so these two are playing Arjun
aragaisy with the white pieces as to Win
It Magnus Carlson is playing with the
black pieces
what's happening in that one I'm just
looking over Magnus is a pawn up I don't
see too much compensation for everybody
but still complex in that one I think
Magnus is uh big favorite now the
biggest problem from Magnus he's down
four minutes but he sells five and a
half minutes remaining for himself he's
doing very well he's in control over the
board and the clock manager is there all
right and you guys shout out if we
should go over to that board it seems
like there is a lot of drama on this
board though yeah potentially and wow
Wesley just bypasses this Pawn I'm
shocked I've got to admit okay we see
the bar reacts because now look at the
white king it's cage there's gonna be
all sorts of mating threats against it
and it has to take a time out to step
back towards the center I would be
terrified of the black queen the Black
Knight combining as a fierce endure
against that King later on and what you
want to really do is get that Queen
working with that H Pawn you want to
Target that E4 Pawn who is the defender
the pawn on F3 get rid of that push that
jeep on all the way down Gucci for
attack the defender Hikaru finds another
way to get the queen into the mating
action he wants to open up the e-file if
Wesley picks up that F5 Bond at some
point that Queen will drop down to E2
threatening a deadly mid on G2 yeah
let's just show that because that would
be a huge mistake now uh capturing this
point would allow the black queen in and
uh black would win yep simply this is
going to end in Checkmate some huge
material losses I think for white if you
want to prevent this so uh okay maybe
Wesley has something else up his sleeve
you could try and attack this Pawn which
is temporarily temporarily loose you
could slide your queen across to
threaten it but black then I think would
be very happy to continue stepping
forward and opening up lines yes you're
opening up the black king but here the
white king is a big Target as well and
blacks pieces have more control over the
center therefore switching over to the
king side shouldn't be too much of an
issue time Advantage completely gone wow
looking very good for Karu that anger
has really driven him in this one yeah
and you see it on his face right his
body language like all right I got this
one look I can lean back a little bit
but a car is playing a perfect
Armageddon game from the start it was
great opening preparation the type of
position that he thrives in he is one of
the world's leading experts he has so
much experience and now it's an open
position the white king in worse shape
than black oh and plus he did take on F5
and queen E2 we were just talking about
that maybe there's Rook D2 that saves
the day but we're starting to trade
pieces off Wesley so needs to win the
game there are no winning chances that I
see in an end game yeah yeah if you just
want to draw us Hikaru you just trade
off the Rooks uh the White Queen has to
defend you trade off the queens and then
you just pick up this Pawn it's level
material if anyone is better here it's
black these pawns are extremely weak
clear path for the black Rook towards
these pawns and uh wow Hikaru I think
he's gonna take the win in this one and
uh okay Wesley defending with his Knight
Instead This is hanging by a thread for
white yeah but you can just attack the
Knight the e-file is open bring your
your Rook on that file hit that night
the defender of that G2 meeting attack
the this is getting worse and worse for
Wesley but I don't think he had the
option to trade the queens and go into
that end game which is just suffering
for white and playing for two results
this has gone all wrong on the camera
he's like a hunter he's focused in on
his prey now he's trying to get climb
into the computer screen he knows that
the win is near and he Bobs his head
he's going for that white knight that
final Defender if he eliminates it just
make my company there's a brilliant
tactic here I mean if we just can bring
up a variation it looks like white can
save that Knight with sliding The Rook
over from D1 to E1 the problem is that
the blackwork will still take the Knight
the queen could take the Rook you gain
some material right no you get checkmate
on the G2 Square that's game over so it
looks like Wesley so is losing material
in this position unless he trades the
queens and if he trades the Queens the
queen C4 check he's not going to be up
any material it's going to an end game
where black actually will be ahead F5
will drop D3 is in trouble rookie two is
coming now west has no winning chances
here yeah black is the one playing for
the win if anything and you can see on
the body language now Wesley he is not
enjoying his position at all let's go
back to the players Hikaru so focused up
on the clock up on the position
yeah just a masterclass
the only good news for Wesley is that
this is not happening all over the board
so he doesn't get to see Hikaru like
this right across because that can be so
intimidating look at hikaru's body
language you've been talking about it
he's going back and forth and he knows
he's got this in his hands he was
furious at the start of the game and
with the black pieces this has been
crushing actually yeah and it's also an
end game between eragite and Carlson
where Magnus has a big Advantage so you
might come down to the clock there
whether Eric I see can flag Magnus uh
looking unlikely at this moment but it
looks like having the black pieces in
the arm again big Advantage yeah
and you guys call out if you think we
should shift the boards it's looking so
good for Hikaru Nakamura
and uh now all he needs to do move the
Rook to a safe Square there we go
retreats I think Wesley has to start a
counter-attack maybe bring the white
Rook on the open file there we go up the
board I up some of those weak black
pawns you do have the three verses 2
advantage on the king side if you can
hit some of those pawns win some of
those pawns at least there'll be some
imbalance so uh not just that David
there's also an idea to pick up the A5
Pawn watch out for that you defend G5
with your Rook with your move Rook G7 I
think it's on the board can white
actually go for this tactic of picking
up the A5 Pawn you sacrifice your knight
but then black snide is hanging on C5
yeah I think you have to go for this
otherwise you might just be suffering in
an end game due to the weakness of this
pawn and Knight takes Pawn to show it it
has happened it has landed on the board
if this Knight was captured uh then the
Black Knight drops you called it Tanya
but Hikaru ignores it he activates his
rook and he's so active right now still
some devastating threats against the
white king uh if the white King's forced
into the corner then there will always
be tricks White's night moves and now I
would want to give a check I'm not sure
whether you need to rush but also this
Pawn is undefended suddenly it feels
like black still has this one under
control black is doing very well but for
Wesley this is the best that he's had
all game the objective evaluation is
good for black but now he's some chances
look at those black pawns on H3 and G5
they're going to be needing those Rooks
defending them but the problem is the
white king can't get into the action if
that King could just jump up to G3
somehow Through The Rook then you're in
good shape but you can never cross the
second rank that Rook on E2 can slide
two squares over in front of the white
King deliver it a check so yeah the king
is not escaping up the board and that
means that black has everything under
control and white needs to watch out for
a threat like Knight D2 at the right
time at an opportune moment because he
still might have the resource to jump
back with his own Knight to D4 in
response to that but definitely if
Black's Knight can join the rook and
pawn into the attack it will be bad news
for Wesley's King wow and he's advancing
his Pawn forward this is not going to
help him win though at the very least
you just trade off this Pawn in every
set of Trades that happens black gets
closer to the win Hikaru looks away
maybe he's thinking of something thing
else maybe the Black Knight could have
jumped in as Tanya mentioned anyway but
he does eliminate all danger and he's a
minute up on the clock very best Wesley
can hope for is to trade off all the
pieces but actually a night capture
would allow the Black Knight to jump in
decisively this one looks over almost at
least in terms of winning chances for
white so I want to give a quick shout
because Magnus Carlson looks like he is
about to at least draw his game and the
near future so it looks like Magnus and
Hikaru in the driver's seat that would
mean a clash between them I believe
that's what everyone typically is
waiting for in these types of events
already on day three in the air things
monster is on the 2023 season clash
between a car and Magnus incredible wow
I think we're about to see a draw here
White's Rook steps up if Hikaru wants he
just gives a check and repeats the
position a dance between the Rooks and
you look at him and you know that's
going to happen he he's not gonna he's
not gonna push this one he might even
know that he's better but he's just
going to give a check Force whites Rook
to come back and then go drop back yeah
oh wow it's over Wesley so with a draw
in this game Wesley is knocked down to
the losers bracket Hikaru Nakamura makes
it through to the winners final that
will be played tomorrow he's gonna face
either Magnus Carlsen or Arjun aragaisy
let's jump into that Armageddon game
Magnus Crossing with the black pieces
only needs a draw in this game Arjun has
to win it what's happening and it's
definitely not going to be a win for
Arjun unfortunately he's a pawn down in
a rook end game Magnus has three minutes
no chance really of flagging him here
despite the lack of increment and I
think the players have agreed to a draw
Magnus is through it's confirmed that
means ladies and gentlemen on day three
of the air things Master is we will see
a Winner's final between Magnus Carlsen
and Hikaru Nakamura we couldn't have
asked for a better winners final
completely unexpected Magnus Carlson
versus thought but the good news is for
the fans of origin arag icy and Wesley
so their term is not done the double
elimination format leaves them in the
thick of things and so of course our
eyes will be on Magnus and Hikaru the
beasts of online chess but Wesley so and
our gym they still have their chances
yeah and uh Arjun what if it gave it
today winning a game against Magnus as
well just amazing stuff and coming back
in that third game with the black pieces
the way he played I think there is a lot
of positive to take away from it and he
knows he has one more shot he has one
more life left in this tournament he's
definitely going to make the most of it
and I think that win gives him a lot of
confidence going forward yeah Tanya it's
good cash against every guy she's smart
your loyalties
okay do you know how commentators it's
supposed to be not biased that's my
Approach for tomorrow yeah yeah and
David we got Armageddon chess today
what's your reaction what was it like uh
it was exciting unfortunately just for
the place with the white pieces every
guy seeing Wesley so they never got
going it's just a masterclass in terms
of control from hikaranakamura and
Magnus Carlson not taking risks
controlling things uh keeping the clock
under
um yeah under watchful gaze as well and
yeah in the end it was just deserved
results for those two have we learned
anything in terms of bidding Robert what
seems to be a good strategy it shows
that Hikaru and Magnus they can go to
that nine and a half ten minute range
but we saw how close it was between
Wesley and nicaro they both desperately
wanted the black pieces so there's some
Game Theory involved someone call up a
professor get some advice because you
know at some point you're just figuring
out my opponent wants this and I want
that how do we bid properly in 9 minutes
and 28 seconds that was a car's bid he
thought that Wesley would go near that
time so both players on the same page
yeah the Strat seems to be that you want
the black pieces but you don't want to
fall below nine minutes
and Magnus Carlsen what can you say
about his performance today David it
wasn't as smooth as previous days as
yesterday where he was really in top
form I think he was really shaken by
that defeating game three against
saragasi where it did turn around quite
quickly when it looked like Magnus was
cruising in control but Eric guys he got
the win so Magnus Hugh will be happy to
have got through today he'll be really
relieved but tomorrow what a fight it's
going to be he's going to have to up his
game he's got to be better than he was
today Magnus to take down Hikaru I think
Magnus is really looking forward to that
one yeah he loves playing against
Chicago definitely I mean everyone is
looking forward to that one we are
hoping to get some reactions from the
players
and we're joined by Hikaru Nakamura the
winner of the match against Wesley so
big congratulations Hikaru
oh thank you so much it was a tough
match but I've had a way to win the
really the one game that mattered
definitely uh take us through first of
all your thoughts behind the bidding in
the Armageddon there
yeah I mean I was actually very
surprised how close it was I thought
when I you know it's funny originally I
was gonna bid in the 950s because I
thought there's no way Wesley would go
below 10 minutes I thought I was gonna
be like 9 50 9 55 to something under 10.
um but then I'm like okay I'll go as low
as I can because why leave it's a chance
of somehow a bit so basically my mind I
was thinking how much time am I willing
to give him like if I have to play with
the white pieces how much time is it am
I at the point where it's like if I
can't beat him with white Then I then
it's like so be it and I basically
thought it was nine and a half minutes
or a five and a half minute time
Advantage was which is how I came with
928 and um yeah he bid 944 I think
whoever got the black pieces if they
survived the opening was gonna have
great chances to move on and it just
happened to be me yeah so you basically
bid on your limit there with 928
well I mean I I maybe maybe I'll play
Magnus a bit lower you never know but uh
sort of I I just yeah I basically looked
and I thought okay what is the time at
which you know if I have to play with
white and and you know I play and let's
just say I don't win the game where am I
going to be like it's like okay I have
this time Edge that's life you know
Wesley was better than me and I I put it
five and a half minutes so I wouldn't
say it's necessarily the max against
Magnus but at least for Wesley that was
my thought process and it worked out so
I'm pleased definitely it was a big
upset though in the start of the game
some technical issues increments started
running Wesley when you restarted the
game chose another opening what was the
going through your head there
I mean I have the same situation in the
in the qualifiers I mean I I play it
again so I think do Bob I think it was
and um I played do Bob in the second I
think rapid game and I played I played
like E4 c5936 and they aboarded the game
and then we started again and you know
it's to me if the moves have been played
and it's not like one side is winning or
losing I I don't know it seems really uh
it feels like one of those Unwritten
rules that you don't just suddenly play
a different opening at least that's my
attitude because I did consider it when
I played dubo I thought okay oh maybe
I'll just play D4 something different
because I've seen these planks something
was like I mean you've played the moves
you shouldn't really take them back so
that's just my personal opinion I don't
I don't really feel like it's correct
but uh you know that's it's what it is
and when you're doing online chess
obviously things things can get a little
bit wild definitely and I think the
whole chess world is so excited to see
you back on the Champions chest or
Hikaru now with a new format double
elimination the time control being 15
plus three what do you think about it so
far
um I mean the format is great because
now I'm in the top three I think so I
definitely qualify for the next
tournament
um which which makes me very very happy
uh yeah overall it's very similar to
previous years in The Knockout phase I
mean I think double elimination
definitely makes it more interesting you
can have like a bad day and come back
and still win the whole event so uh for
the fans I think it's it's better
um and yeah it's it's just it's kind of
kind of crazy to be in this situation
but that's what it is yeah
and acara you and Wesley always neck and
neck and you often play this Berlin draw
so what was going through your mind
heading into game four making that draw
was it for the memes
well I mean first of all like Armageddon
is always better content than having no
arm again I think that's there are tie
breaks or Armageddon are always better
than not having them that's the first
thing but I mean really Wesley and I
have played a lot we played in the uh
chess Global championship last year in
in Toronto and I mean that match was
actually very similar to this it's just
at the very end I tried really hard to
push a one with white in the seventh
game and it didn't work out it backfired
Wesley won that game won the last game
um and then he won the tournament very
deservedly so uh and this match was very
similar and I just told myself I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do anything insane
there I have the white piece in the last
game and I felt very confident I'm just
I mean to me the thing that's surprising
is just how low Wesley did because like
I said I assumed that I was going to bid
lower than him I never I really never
thought there was any way he was going
to bid below like 11 minutes I just
didn't see it happening so I'm just glad
that I went with what I thought was Max
I think if the colors were reversed
there's a very good chance that Wesley's
in the final instead of me
but it is you in the winners final
against Magnus Carlson tomorrow Hikaru
what's going to be your strategy and
plan heading into that big match
um I mean no strategy no plan uh this is
pretty much a vacation from far worse
things that are going on in my life
right now or far more depressing things
shall we say so uh for me I mean this is
this is like this is uh almost a
vacation getting to play chess so I'm
just enjoying it as much as I can how
difficult is it when uh stuff is going
on in your personal life to be able to
focus in a mental sport like chess
well you know if the first thing is that
you know luckily I seem to be pretty
decent at this game called chess
especially in Rapid and Blitz formats
um and that definitely helps a lot
because I I mean like yesterday for
example I I basically was just pounding
nothing but caffeine for uh for about 10
hours or so maybe not 10 hours but like
right right up until I played against
um you know like life is what it is you
know people people people pass on things
happen that's how it goes um but for me
I think really it's just finding the joy
in playing chess and separating
separating or compartmentalizing things
and just you know it's you just try to
play and for me I think um as I said
luckily I seem to have pretty set
openings I seem to be fairly decent at
it and um it definitely helps when when
you can kind of just play on feel as
opposed to having to waste you know
hours or weeks or months about world you
know on on Preparation and Magnus
obviously knows about that all too well
so that's what it is
we're sending warm thoughts uh towards
uh you and your family and wish you best
of luck in the winners final tomorrow
thank you so much you guys appreciate it
thank you for joining us
all right it's going to be such a big
Winners final tomorrow Hikaru against
Magnus Carlsen and I think we're also
joined by Magnus congratulations on
another match by Magnus
yeah thank you so before I start asking
you about tomorrow's big Winners final
you end the day with Armageddon here can
you first of all take us through your
tactics your thought process in the
bidding process there
um I thought
uh 10 minutes would be uh would be nice
and I saw a bit 1001 sort of hoping that
he would be bids exactly 10 minutes and
I would get white because I thought that
would be uh
um then then I thought that would be
good for for me as well uh so that was
um basically just uh
uh bid something where I felt good with
both outcomes okay so you were even
though uh you were happy without the
bidding turned out
yeah it was fun okay
um
so yeah no worries there could you
reveal to us what would sort of be your
limits were you bidding on your limit or
could you go even lower
I mean I sort of had to make it up on
the fly but uh uh I mean you can play
very decent chess with much less time as
as that but this is probably like close
to where I would feel like comfortable I
would say all right and and two days
into the air things Masters how do you
feel about the way you're playing
Chestnut Magnus
um I was so happy with the way that I
played the the final four games today
um first game was very good uh
good decision making
um but yeah the the last three games
weren't uh
weren't so good
um especially the third game was pretty
unnecessary
um he did find a lot of good resources
there I thought I thought I was out
playing him a bit but it turned out like
he was always staying in there and then
I got short of time and he found this
research with 24. so that was a bit
relaxing because I thought like after I
survived the second game I thought
um that uh
the match was if not over then close to
it but um that was not the case at all
Magnus it's been a few days now since
you've landed in Canada what's uh what's
it like out there
um it's pretty much the same as in
Norway if the weather the culture
um also there are a lot of Norwegians
here so
it's pretty much the same
we've been wondering if it's a lot of
sound a lot of my music and stuff going
on in the background when you're playing
are they keeping quiet or or what's
happening in the house when you are
playing the tournament
uh no no no that's fine uh the the boys
are having having fun but I can't really
hear anything so uh it's it's a house
that's well set up for
um for people both streaming and doing
other things yeah definitely and
tomorrow Magnus a big Winners final is
coming up I think the whole world the
whole Chess World is cheering because
it's gonna be Magnus Carlsen against T
card Nakamura are you excited about that
uh I haven't thought so much about it
yet but uh it's been a long time since
we played rapidly again she thought
against each other
um and uh what he has shown here uh and
what he showed in the rapidm uh sorry in
the world rapid as well is that it's not
so easy to
um to to beat and today he managed the
feat of going through without a single
win so uh that's gonna be sort of the
main challenge I think tomorrow to uh to
create winning chances yeah and Magnus
your last extended match against Hikaru
was the speeches Championship he of
course took that one down does that play
on your mind at all or is it a new
tournament and a new mindset
oh well he's done well against me
um for for a while now so I um
yeah it certainly won't be easy
and with Hikaru in the mix this new door
format Magnus also your you've been very
vocal about how much you enjoy speed
chess and playing these events also
about how you feel about classical chess
especially after toddler steel it was
completely spent you looked completely
spent uh no classical World Championship
coming up this year for you how
significant is the champion Chester on
the air things Masters for you this
season
no it's it's big and uh
uh now we have a have a unified tour
with um
with all the best players and uh it's uh
it's really a prestigious so I really
want to do well yeah my name is we wish
you best of luck tomorrow and the big
winner is final and thank you for
joining us
thank you
so you're so excited we are excited I
bet everyone at home is excited about
tomorrow's winners final between Magnus
Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura this is the
bracket we're only two days into the air
things monsters day three coming up
tomorrow we're gonna start out with
losers quarterfinals Wesley so against
Alexa Serana Our Generation two
teenagers both from India up against
each other is that very prestigious for
both of those two young players Danielle
you know the Indian fans are going to be
torn because I know that they love both
these players a lot so it's gonna be
tough to pick one it's a huge match for
India for these two players to keep in
the race they're good friends they
understand each other's style a lot and
that's never pleasant but I think
tomorrow it's not going to be about
friendship all of that's going to be
forgotten they're going to come out all
God's blazing yeah and on the losers
bracket it is best out of two rapid
games with Armageddon tie breaks if
necessary we also then have Wesley so
being knocked down from the Winner's
bracket today
to face Alexa is around and you are a
big
uh yes you say many nice things about
about Alexander basically Robert what
chances do you give him against Wesley
so he just beat Ali razor farooza
convincingly today so he can beat
anybody on the planet I don't say that
lightly we saw how happy Serrato was
today he was impressed by his own chest
it means the world to him and Wesley so
he's coming off probably what feels like
a disappointing performance he drew that
final game but he really didn't have a
chance it was a solid Affair but not
nothing spectacular of the likes we've
seen from Wesley so so I think Alexis
Serrano has serious chances and you have
to watch out for the opening preparation
okay wow so that's going to be exciting
as well we're going to start out day
three with the losers bracket before the
Big Winners final Magnus Carlsen Hikaru
Nakamura what'd you expect David I can't
wait I predict that both of them will
bring their best chests they can hit
these really high levels but as Magnus
mentioned creating winning chances
against these guys it's a mutual thing
that creating winning chances that's
going to be the hardest thing it could
well go down
to the Armageddon again yeah division
one is uh turning into something super
exciting you guys but there's also two
more divisions going on in the air
things monsters division three and these
are results from today in division two
and some big news to you guys
never turned up for his match
is that a surprise no it's not a
surprise and the reason why is not
because he didn't want to play he was
traveling he was in transit to his
over-the-board classical tournament I
feel pretty uh confident he'll be back
tomorrow that's what double elimination
is for but Jana Pomchi hands the match
over to Alexander predicate but in terms
of people who are showing off their
chest might five in a carwana beating a
very tough opponent two and a half he
moves on great showing by the American
Superstar who probably wants to find
himself in division one next time aha so
winner is semi-finals coming off in
division two tomorrow as well as losers
quarter-finals and Jana ponyachi he will
then use the second life and play on the
losers bracket tomorrow that's your
predictions certainly all right
what a day what a day you guys this has
been a long day it's been a fun day and
we have more excitement coming up
tomorrow with the big Winners final and
losers quarterfinals so join us again
we hope you have enjoyed the chess today
and we'll keep enjoying it tomorrow
but uh wherever you are in the world
have a good night have a good day and
we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]